TO SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER THREE. A
WE HAVE A RELATIVELY SPARSE
SHOWING THIS MORNING WHICH MAY
BE A OF WE HAVE A SHORTAGE
GENDER I PREFER TO THINK OF IT
THAT WAY. THAT'S NOT THE FACT
THAT. WE HANG UP. AS FOR THOSE
OF YOU WHO ARE TRYING TO DECIDE
WHICH FORM OF GREETING TIAS-
ALBUM THAT BUMP. HELLO CAN I
PERSONALLY THIS MAY CHANGE NEXT
WEEK BUT I'M LIKE INTO JAZZ
DANCE. OF FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO
WERE JUST DYING TO KNOW. OF. MY
COLLEAGUES TELLING ME THAT'S
TOO MUCH INFORMATION BUT REALLY
ISN'T. OF WE'RE GOING TO
DISCUSS THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSALS FOR TRANSPORTATION
DEPARTMENT SAYS I THINK
EVERYBODY HERE. ALREADY KNOW
SENT- ALSO- THE CHP WILL BE
WITH US LATER ON IN THE AGENDA
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF ITEMS ON
THE VOTE CALENDAR BUT NOT ABLE
TO ROLL CALL VOTE YEAH UP. HOLD
UP VOTE ONLY WE ARE PULLING THE
ISSUE FIVE OFF OF VOTER WAIT
FOR THE- MOVING INTO THE FUTURE
MANY. OF THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
IS OF. GREAT AND MADE THAT'S
BECAUSE SAFETY STANDARDS OR
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HEARD
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION ON THE EFFORTS
THEY'RE GONNA BE TAKE AND THAT
GUARD. THE OUR FIRST DEPARTMENT
IS. EXCUSE ME ARE THEM AS THE
PUBLIC TRANSIT RIDERSHIP
INFORMATION ITEM ONLY ISSUE ONE.
IN MISTER TAYLOR YEAR HER FOR
THAT A CAN STEP FORWARD. I
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU DROVE HERE
BECAUSE THERE'S A BAN ON
FLYING. OF YES FROM YOUR
INSTITUTION IS THAT RIGHT- AT
TWO PM YESTERDAY YES THEY
ANNOUNCED THAT THEY NO LONGER
PERMITTED. BUSINESS TRAVEL THE
AIR. THOUGH AND HERE YOU ARE
SO- I READ BECAUSE I THINK THE
CONGO AUTOMATED VEHICLE IN
ORDER TO TALK ABOUT PUBLIC
TRANSI AND- THANK YOU FOR
MAKING THAT EXTRA AFTER. THAT
ACTUALLY I THINK IS A SERIOUS
ISSUE AND THAT IS OF A WE HAND
ON- INPUT- IN OUR IN OUR
HEARINGS HERE AND MUCH OF IT
COMES IN THE HOUSE. FROM THIS
IS THAT AFTER HERE IN
SACRAMENTO BUT WE DEPEND PUBLIC
PUT IN A SOME OF THIS WITNESS.
YOUR SELF AND OF COURSE THE
PROCESS. IS A POLICY CAN.
ALMOST SOLELY ON COMING FROM IS
STEP OF THE EIGHT TO TESTIFY
BOB THIS IS AN ISSUE ENTER THE
PEOPLE NOT BEING ABLE TO COME
BY VIRTUE OF POLICY OR OTHER
CONCERNS IN CONSIDERATION AND
I'M HOPING- THAT WE ARE GOING
TO BE ABLE TO MAKE CHANGES IN
OUR- CITIES. WILL ALLOW FOR
REMOTE. THINGS LIKE THAT- TO
ALLOW US TO AS BEST WE CAN
CONTINUE TO CONDUCT THE
IMPORTANT BUSINESS THAT WE
HAVE- AS WE MOVE THROUGH THE
LEGISLATIVE FOR A CYCLE. OF THE-
LOOK WE'RE GONNA BEGIN OF THIS
DISCUSSION WITH- LA SO REPORT.
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING AND
EUNICE ROW AT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE SO I WILL BE
SPEAKING FROM THE HAND THAT
THAT WAS HANDED OUT TO YOU AND
THAT'S HOW THEY WILL ALSO BE
AVAILABLE ON THEIR WEB SITE. M.
L. COMMITTEE STAFF AT BEST TO
PRESENT- A COUPLE OF BACKGROUND
PIECES ON TRANSIT. FIRST ON AND
THE ROLE TRANSIT HAS AN
REDUCING GHG EMISSIONS
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS- AS
WELL AS SOME BACKGROUND ON IN
STATE FUNDING OF TRANSIT
SERVICES IN THE STATE. SO IF
YOU TURN AGE WINE. THE
TRANSPORTATION IS THE LARGEST
SOURCE OF GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS IN CALIFORNIA AND
THEIR RESEARCH BOARD ESTIMATES
ABOUT 39% OF GHG EMISSIONS
COMES FROM THE TRAIN STATION
SECTOR AND A LARGE CHUNK OF
THAT COMES FROM ON RESOURCES
INCLUDING PASSENGER VEHICLES
AND TRUCKS BUSES. AND THE
REMAINING PORTION OF THE AT
EMISSIONS FROM THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR COMES
FROM THINGS THAT L. I. SHIPS
AND PLANES BUT THE MAJORITY
TRUMP I'M SORRY SAYS. AT THAT'S
THE- A LOT OF ATTENTION AND
PAID. AND HOW THE C. CAN EDUCE
GHG EMISSIONS FROM THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR AND ONE
POTENTIAL STRATEGY IS TO. SHIFT
THE NUMBER OF FOLKS THAT ARE
DRIVING PRIVATE VEHICLES TO AB
MORE EFFICIENT MODES OF TRANSIT
I'M MODES OF TRANSPORTATION
INCLUDING TRANSIT. AND SO I AND
PAGE TWO YOU CAN SEE THAT
TRANSIT HAS THE POTENTIAL TO
SAM CONGESTION AND FUEL
EFFICIENT AS A RESULT- PRODUCE
LESS GHG EMISSIONS THAN PRIVATE.
VEHICLES SO VARIOUS TYPES OF
TRANSIT HAVE BEEN ESTIMATED ON
AVERAGE TO ESTIMATE TO EMIT
LESS A MISSION STAND A SINGLE
OCCUPANCY VEHICLES SO FOLKS
DRIVING ALONE IN THEIR CARS.
BUT OF COURSE THE EFFICIENCY OF
THESE MODES ARE REALLY DEPEND
ON TWO CRITICAL FACTORS
OCCUPANCY- AS WELL AS ENERGY SO
OF COURSE THE MORE FOLKS THAT
ARE WRITING UP I STILL LOWER
MISSION IS PER PASSED MILE. SEC
I AM SAID THAT ENERGY IS ALSO A
KEY FACTOR IN DIET AT. HYBRID
BIAS WOULD PRODUCE LESS
EMISSIONS PER MILE PER FIRST
SAYS AB. I DIESEL FUEL BUS. HI
AND SO I'M MOVING ON TO KIND OF
THE SECOND PORTION OF THAT THE
BACKGROUND ON TRANSIT- THE
FUNDING SO TRANSIT IS FUNDED
THROUGH A VARIETY OF SOURCES-
BUT NEARLY HALF OF THE STORE
SAYS ARE COME FROM LOW. LOCAL
TAX REVENUE. I'M IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN CALIFORNIA. THERE ARE
TWELVE BILLION I'M WAS BUDGETED.
AND WAS SPENT FOR TRANSDUCER
PROCESS IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN- AND
BUT FOR THE PURPOSES OF THIS
PRESENTATION OF FOCUSED- FIND
KIND OF THE STATE PROGRAMS FOR
TRANSIT. I'M FIND PAGE FOUR- WE
CAN SEE THAT IN MORE DETAIL
SAID DIFFERENT STATE FUNDING
PROGRAMS. FOR TRANSIT SERVICES
AS THE FIGURE ON PAGE FOUR AND
SHOWS THE MAJOR SOURCES- THE
STATE LEVEL THAT FUND TRANSIT
THIS TRANSIT STANDS AT EXCEPT.
THE MAJORITY I'M- IT'S FUNDED
BY THE STATE SALES TAX ON
DIESEL TIME AND IT'S ALLOCATED
OPERATORS ON A FORMULA BE SAYS-
IN IT ALLOCATE NEARLY BILLION
DOLLARS IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
TEAM. I OTHER PROGRAMS. SMALLER
ON KIND OF VERY IN THAT SOME
ARE. IT'S A DEDICATED
SPECIFICALLY FOR TRANSIT OTHERS
ARE KIND OF MORE BROADER
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS WHERE
TRANSIT PROJECTS CAN BE FUNDED-
TICKET AREA IN THE WAY THEIR
ALLOCATED SUMMER COMPETITIVE
GRANT PROGRAMS OFFERS OUR
FORMULA I'M PROGRAMS. TA I'M IN
THE ALSO. TYPES OF- PROJECTS HE
FINDS SOME CAN FIND NO CAPITAL
PROJECTS- LIKE PURCHASING
PROCESS BUT OTHERS- I ALSO
FOUGHT OPERATIONAL COSTS. AND
SAID. I'M AND THAT CONCLUDES
OUR PRESENTATION- HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS
THAT YOU MAY HAVE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MISTER TAYLOR SHORT
I'M IN SO OF YOU INTRODUCE
YOURSELF- YES I I'M BRIAN
TAYLOR AND A PROFESSOR OF URBAN
PLANNING AND PUBLIC POLICY IN
THE UCLA LET PUBLIC AFFAIRS AND
I'M DIRECTOR OF THE INSTITUTE
TRANSPORTATION STUDIES AT UCLA
I'M ALSO CHAIR OF THE COUNCIL
OF DIRECTORS OF THE USE YES TO
TRANSPORTATION STUDIES AT
BERKELEY DAVIS IRVINE UCLA. AND
WHAT HAVE TO DO ABOUT REAP
WE'VE BEEN DOING AT. ON THE A
THE FACTORS BE FOLLOW TRANSIT
RIDERSHIP RECENT YEARS AND NHà
WHAT BEHIND THAT WHAT COULD BE
DONE IT DIDN'T AND HOW WE CAN
REALIZE THE BENEFITS OF
INVESTMENT IN SUBSIDY OF PUBLIC
TRANSIT IN ORDER TO GET BOTH
MOBILITY BENEFITS AND
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS FROM
THAT INVESTED ACTUALLY COMMENT
ON A COUPLE OF POLICY PROPOSED.
TALKED THAT WE ARE INTO THE OF
BILLS IF THE VERY LARGE OF
REPORTS
TRANSIT RIDERSHIP IS ERODING IN
CALIFORNIA AND- AND AROUND THE
COUNTRY THIS CONCERNED ABOUT
THAT BUT TO KEEP IT IN THE BIG
PICTURE IS WELL IT'S DOWN IN
ABSOLUTE TERMS IT'S RELATIVELY
MODEST SO THE DECLINES- ARE NOT
ENORMOUS BUT IT'S A LITTLE
ALARMING THEY'RE GOING IN THE
DIRECTION THEY'VE BEEN GOING
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE THE LAST FEW
YEARS WE'VE BEEN ECONOMIC UPS
THOSE. GO TO OTHER OF. WHAT'S
MORE CONCERNING. IS NOT THE TOP
LINE NUMBERS BUT THE WRITERS
PER CAPITA OR THE TRIPS PER
PERSON. BECAUSE CITIES IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE BEEN GROWING.
AND WHAT WE'VE SEEN IS THAT
SINCE ABOUT TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
OF THE START OF THE RECEPTION.
WE HAD A DECLINE IN PER CAPITA
RIDERSHIP- ACROSS THE US. IN
CALIFORNIA PARTICULARLY IN
GREATER LOS ANGELES. THAT
WASN'T NECESSARY A SURPRISE
DURING SEVERE ECONOMIC
DOWNTURN. THINGS DID TO IMPROVE
COMING OUT OF THE RECESSION.
BUT THEN WHAT'S- IT'S ABOUT
FORTY. IS THAT. CAPITAL SHIP IS
BEEN GOING DOWN AGAIN. BUT
SIXTEEN THEY WERE THEM BECAUSE-
AGAIN ECONOMIC AND WOULD
PROTECT. OUR SHIP THESE. THE
MOTHER. ROCHE BASRA ACROSS THE
OF A RAY RIDERS REBEL OUT OF
THE WRIST BUT IT TO HIS STARTED
DOWN AS WELL SO WE HAVE WE HAVE
TWO MAJOR TRANSIT ROAD
STATEWIDE THAT ALSO TING
RAPPERS ADDED AND THAT WILL
BRING A LOT MORE. ON ONE THING
I WANT TO SAY ABOUT THIS IT'S
IMPORTANT UNDERSTAND IS THAT IT
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION IS
ENORMOUSLY ASYMMETRIC ITS
ASYMMETRIC SPACE ASYMMETRIC
TEMPORARY TEMPORALLY IT JUST
DOESN'T SEVEN EVENLY
DISTRIBUTED SO FIRST THING NO
IS IT A FEW PEOPLE MAKE MOST OF
THE TRANSIT. SEC IF YOU NAME
CITIES. THE TRAIN TRIP. HEARD
IS THAT A FEW ARE I AND THOSE
OPERATORS CARE MOST OF THE
PASSAGE. SO IT'S EXTREME UNEVEN
WITH TO THE NOT PORTION OF
ELATION SO JUST COUPLE OF THE
EMINENT IT PULLS A IT IS AB.
THERE ARE TWO MARKET PUBLIC
TRANSIT PLACES THAT ARE HIGHLY
AGGLOMERATED WHERE IT'S
DIFFICULT TO DRIVE AND PARK. IN
THE SECOND ARE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
LIVED ACCESS TO BILLS THOSE THE
TWO KEY MARKETS AND LET ME JUST
GIVE YOU A- COUPLE OF. AND THAT.
THIS POPULATION DENSITIES IN
AND HAVE AS PEOPLE PER MILE
WHICH ARE THERE PLACES IN LOS
ANGELES IN THE BAY AREA THERE
LIKE THAT IF WE LOOK STATION
WIDE ONLY 30% OF THE US
POPULATION LIVES IN PLACE AS
WITH OVER TEN THAT PEOPLE
SQUARE MILE. BUT OF ALL. PLACE
IS ABOUT. SIX OUT OF TEN. ICAL
HOUSEHOLD ACTUALLY BEEN TO COME
A LITTLE BIT STATE IN AND
ACROSS THE- ABOUT 5% OF ALL
HOUSEHOLDS DON'T HAVE A VEHICLE
IN THEM OKAY. THE POST
HOUSEHOLDS ACCOUNT FOR ALMOST
HALF OF ALL THE TRANSIT IN THE
IN THE COUNTRY ALMOST HALF IN
CALIFORNIA. ENORMOUS A CEMETERY
A FEW OF THOSE HOUSEHOLDS
MAKING A LARGE NUMBER TRIPS IN
A FEW NEIGHBORHOODS ARE
CARRYING MOST OF THE STRIPS. SO
IN LA. A DATA WE DID AND I KNOW
COATED HIS DANCING SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT THIS IS THE WHOLE
REGION WE LOOK AT THE WHOLE AG
READ. ABOUT TO SET ALL OF THE
PEOPLE IN THE SCARE AN AVERAGE
ABOUT FIVE TRIP ON. I ABOUT BUT
TWELVE TRIP SEBRING'S IT UP
222% OF THE POPULATION BUT
ABOUT 78% OF THE POPULATION
RIDE THE FEWER THE TRIP A MONTH
THERE ARE MOST OF THAT AT ALL
AND SO IT MEANS IS THING HAVE
TO THAT POPULAR VERY HAVE
TRADING USE IT HAS OUT. FOR OUR-
THE A LITTLE BIT THE POPPY CAN
HAVE A- AND THAT'S WHAT WE SAW
SO FOR EXAMPLE WE CALCULATED
FROM TWO THOUSAND TEN TO TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN. OF THE LA
MATCH AND IT 472% OF ALL OF THE
STATE'S RIDERSHIP LOSSES IN A
PART OF THAT BECAUSE IT HAD
SOME OF THE MOST HELP. NICE LOT.
AS IT HAD OF ARJUNA PEOPLE VERY
FREQUENT RIDE. IN THE BAY AREA
OF WE HAD SORT OF HEARTENING
COUNTER CYCLICAL TRENDS WITH
THE BAY AREA ACTUALLY UNTIL
THREE YEARS AGO WITH WAS DOING
TO ADD RIDERS BUT ALMOST ALL OF
THOSE WERE RUN TRANSBAY BART
TRIPS THE RIVER THE REGION MUCH
LIKE THE REST OF THIS WHICH IS.
THE ROAD. THIS IS WHAT IT WHICH
IS A SAM CISCO CB. WITH HIS
SIGNIFICANT GROWTH IN
EMPLOYMENT WAS KIND OF CARRYING
THE WHOLE STATE ALONG WITH WITH
RIDERSHIP INCREASES. WHAT ARE
SOME O THE REASONS BEHIND THIS
IS. WE HAVE CHANGES IN THE
ENVIRONMENTS WITH WHICH TRANSIT
CAN OPERATE SO THESE OF THESE
THESE DENSE HIGHLY A LOT RATED
PLACES. OTHER IS CHANGES TO
ACCESS TO OTHER MODES OF THOSE
WE THINK ARE THE OTHER THINGS
THAT ARE MADE BEHIND IT.
OUTSIDE OF THE- YEAH. THE
BIGGEST STORY SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND REALLY IN THE TWO
THOUSANDS HANDS. IS WE'VE SEEN
INCREASING AUTO ACCESS AMONG
LOWER INCOME HOUSEHOLDS
GENERALLY HI I'M HOUSE OF ALL
HOUSEHOLDS HAVE BEEN INCREASED
AUTO A- BUT IT'S BEEN. LONG
DOES THE RIVER HELLO. OTTO SAYS
OUT OF. YES THAT MEANS. IT IS.
REDUCTION AND VEHICLE
HOUSEHOLDS STATE. REMEMBER I
TOLD YOU THAT 5% CARRIED ALMOST
HALF THE RIGHT. LOOTING HERE
ZERO. BE GOOD HOUSE OVERALL
ABILITY BUT IN TERMS OF THE
SHIP IS QUITE DE BE THOSE
PEOPLE ARE WRITING SO FREE AT
BAY AREA INTERESTINGLY HAS NOT
HAD THAT THAT A CHANGE IN
VI<c.cyan> EXCESSIVE TALK LATER WE</c>
DID. STE IS THE MALL THAT
ESTIMATED ALL ALL OF THE
TRANSIT RIDERSHIP LOSSES WE'VE
SEEN IN THE TWO THOUSANDS. IT
CAN BE EXPLAINED LARGE BY
INCREASE IN AUTO ACCESS IN
PLACES OUTSIDE AREA- AND IN
THAT THIS IS DETAILED IN THE
REPORTS THAT WE'VE DONE. AND
JUST FINISHED. REPORTER FOR THE-
THERE IS A SIGNIFICANT INCREASE
IN THE DISTANCE BETWEEN JOBS
AND HOUSING IN THE REGION AND
WE SUSPECT THAT THAT'S REAL
RELATED TO THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING CRISIS. SO WE'RE-
THINKING IN THE BACK AS WELL S
THAT WE'RE SEEING MORE AFFLUENT
COMMUTERS COMMUTING INTO JOB
CENTERS. BUT AROUND THE REST OF
THE STATE STAYING. OFF PEAK
TIES IN SUBURBAN SYSTEMS ALL
OF THOSE SYSTEMS AND AS- ABOUT
THIS IS THAT THERE'S ONE
MARKET. GOING IN AND OUT OF
DOWNTOWN SERVICES GOING TO THE
BIG JOB CENTER TO SORT OF
HOLDING UP IN THE BAY AREA. BUT
TO THE BAY AREA ALSO LOSE IT
DOES OFF PEAK THE MIDDAY
EVENING. IS OUT IN BURBS ALL
THOSE IS GOING. WE THE- HALE
HIS HAVING DONE THE WAY RIGHT
HAS MARKET IS TO BE PEOPLE
TRAVELING TO AND WORK AN UNDER
BASIS BUT IT MIGHT BE A MAKE
AROUND DURING THE DAY OR AND
SAT EVEN. GOING TO THE AIRPORT.
CASE SO PART OF THAT. IN AN
RIDERSHIP IT OTHER TIMES BEEN
LIKELY AFFECTED BY RIGHT HILL
AS WELL WHAT ARE SOME OF THE
POLICY IMPLICATIONS JUST TO
WRAP UP AB. WE'RE SEEING FEWER
REDUCE TRANSIT DEPENDENTS OVER
TIME IT OR CHOICE WRITERS WITH
ACCESS TO CARS IN THIS IS
PARTICULARLY THE CASE IN THE
SENSE IS THE BAY AREA. NOW IF
YOU'RE JUST LOSE. STRATEGIES TO
GET OCCASIONAL RIDERS TO RIDE
MORE AND TO GET PEOPLE WHO NOW
NEVER RIGHT TO WRITE
OCCASIONALLY AND- EFFORTS TO DO
THAT ARE REALLY LIKELY TO BE.
HAVE MORE AUTO OWNERSHIP IN IN
AND FOR EXAMPLE LOWER INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS THERE OFTEN VEHICLE
DEFICIT HOUSE WHICH IS. A CAR A
LICENSED DRIVER. CAN HOUSEHOLD
WHERE THERE MIGHT BE THREE
LICENSE DRIVER IN ONE CAR SO
THERE'S STILL TRANSIT USE THEIR
IN DOING MORE TO THOSE
PASSENGERS A WRITER'S IS IT IS
WELL A SECOND. AREA IS THAT WE
SIMPLY HAVE TO THINK ABOUT
CONFRONTING MANAGE PRIVATE
VEHICLE TRAVEL. AND IF THEY'RE
IF HEAVY RAIL HAS A THIRD RAIL
IF THERE'S A THIRD RAIL IN POP
IS TRYING TO MANAGE THAT ICAL
TRAVEL. BUT WE HAVE WE HAVE
SCARES THE NEXT. WORKING MORE
PEOPLE. ARE IT. IS HAVE A
POSITIVE. THE ENVIRONMENT ON
CAN ALL IN SLOW DOWN TRANS. AND
WE CAN READ HER HANDS AROUND
THAT. IT'S NOT SOMETHING THE
TRANSIT TRANSIT. CAN TINKER IN
THIS WAY BUT- HAND. AT NOT LET
HAVE MUCH OF. YOU CAN SEE. IF I
WAYS PETER THE ROAD HOW. WE
DRIVE PARKING BETTER BUT RIGHT.
IT PEOPLE OFTEN MISSES THE
ACTUALLY MAKE IT A BETTER
RIDING BUT PEOPLE ARE MUCH MORE
JUDICIOUS THEIR USE OF THAT. I
THREE BECOMES A MUCH MORE TO OF
IT EVEN HAS BEEN FIRED IT'S
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT RURAL
AREA BUT IN IN CAN. AREA NOW.
IT IS IT IS EFFECTIVE. I WILL
TURN OF ANY PART BECAUSE IT
MOVES TO ME. PLEA THREE STREETS
WITH THAT IN LONDON. IN IN A
THIS THERE CAN JUST PRICING TO.
PAY FOR THE LONDON UNDERGROUND
UPGRADES I NEXT BENEFIT WAS A
HUGE INCREASE IN BUS WRITER
BECAUSE NOW LET'S MOVING AROUND
SO MUCH WORK. SEC THAT'S SORT
OF PERVERT THIS. TRANSIT WHICH
IS A YOU KNOW IT A POLICY
THAT'S BEING. TALKED ABOUT A
LOT AND IT TRANSIT WELL PUBLIC
IT'S SO CERTAINLY SOMETHING.
OUT IN AS A MENTION TRANSIT
USERS TO DEPORT
DISPROPORTIONATELY LOW INCOME.
AND ENFORCEMENT EXPENSIVE. OF
AND ALSO. IN FEAR OF INTO THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM THAT
MAYBE WE- DO SO I THINK THAT
THERE'S THIS THIS ARGUMENT FOR
WHY CHARGE FAIRS AT ALL IN AYE.
IT IS WORTH A LOOK. THE
NEGATIVE I'M NOT GONNA COME
DOWN HARD IN THIS POSITION WHEN
WITH OTHER. BUT I DO WANT TO
POINT OUT JUST A COUPLE OF
OTHER THINGS. WE KNOW THAT. THE
MORE EXPENSIVE TO PROVIDE
TRANSIT TRIPS ARE CONSUMED ON
AVERAGE BY THE HIGHEST INCOME
WRITERS SO THINK WITH THIS WITH
SOMEONE DRIVING. GOING IN THE
PEAK HOUR IN THE PEAK DIRECTION
TO THE SENATE THIS IS A
BUSINESS DISTRICT IN LA OR-
SACRAMENTO OR THE BAY AREA.
THAT COSTA INTO SYSTEM A LOT OR
THE- DAY TRIP ON A BUS OR A
WEEK ENERGY TRIPPIN OFF. XIN
FIFTIES THE SKI THE ROCK. IN
HIGHER THAT. THE SO. L. WE SAY
THAT THE SUBSIDIES HER. PER
MILE THE MUCH HIGHER FOR A-
THERE'S A LOWER INCOME RIGHT.
IF WE PROVIDE FREE TO EVERYONE
THAT DOESN'T CHANGE ANYTHING.
THAT THAT UNEQUAL SUBSIDY IT IS
THE SEVEN THE COST OF PROVIDING
A FREE RIDE SOME KINDS OF
WRITERS INSPIRED. IS THAT VERSE
PERHAPS. EQUITY ISSUES BECOME
AN ISSUE WITH FOR TRANSIT. A
SECOND IS THAT AB WELL SYSTEMS
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT LOSING
RIDERSHIP THEY AGAIN SCALE
THEIR SYSTEM FOR THEIR PEAK
DIRECTION PEAK DEMAND. THAT'S
WHAT DRIVES THEIR- SO BART
RIGHT NOW IT FINISHING THAT
COURT THE PATH TO THE EXPANSION
IN THE- IN THE THAT CENTRAL AIR.
THREE THREE BILLION DOLLARS
THEY'RE LOOKING AT. EIGHT
BILLION. THANKS TO GRAY THAT IS
BASED AS AN. AMANDA THE PEAK
TIMES IN COULD INADVERTENTLY
INCREASE COSTS A LOT. SO OF THE
FINALLY THERE IS RESEARCH ON
FARE FREE TRANSIT AND IT DOES
SUGGEST THAT LOWER INCOME
RIDERS WILL TEND TO RESPOND
MORE THAT TH HIGHER INCOME
WRITER SO THAT THERE IS SOME
EVIDENCE THAT BENEFIT CAN
ACCRUE TO PROVIDE CARE FREE IT.
THERE'S GONNA SUCH PEOPLE ARE
MORE LA IN THE WRIST TO BETTER
TRANSIT SERVICE THE LOWER
TRANSIT PRICES THAT IS THAT
EVEN A PLAN COME LEVELS PEOPLE
ARE MORE RESPONSIVE LOWER WHAT
TIMES IN YOUR TRANSIT SERVICE
EVEN IN LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS
SO. ABOUT TWO WEEKS THREE
HUNDRED AND MILLION DOLLARS IN
ELIMINATING FAIR IS A DO WE
SPEND THREE AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN INCREASING THE
FREQUENCY AND RELIABILITY A BUS
SERVICE. ON AVERAGE OF WITH
MORE RIDERS DOING BATTER AGAIN
THAT THAT'S NOT IN ALL CASES
AND THERE MAY BE A CASE AND I
COULD TALK ABOUT IT IF YOU HAVE
QUESTIONS ABOUT A WIN. WHAT
CIRCUMSTANCES COME RIGHT. AND
IF IT MORE. HE CAN OFF BEACON
BECAUSE HIGHER INCOME WRITERS
TO RIDE IN THE PEAK ACTION THE
PEAK HOUR. DOING THINGS LIKE
SAYING YOU PAY ONLY FOR THE
PEAK HOUR PEAK DIRECTION TRIPS
AND THEN WE PROVIDE YOU FREE
TRANSIT AT ALL OTHER TIMES. WE
LIKELY HAVE MUCH. LOWER
FINANCIAL HIT BANDED UP. AND
WOOD I THINK IT FREE TO A- AND-
A WAY A DELIVER THOSE BENEFITS
TO LOW INCOME ROCKERS
ENCOURAGING WILL. BE SHIPPED.
GETTING THE- BENEFIT. FOR S. S.
SENATE BILL ONE WHICH WE- FUN
FOR THE- THAT WE'VE BEEN DOING
WE DATA MAJOR STUDY AND N.
OCTOPUS GAG- THAT WE RELEASED
ON LA. DID A SECOND THAT WE
JUST REALLY TO THEM HE'S AND
WE'RE DOING A STATE WIDE
ANNOUNCES THAT WE'RE GOING TO
RELEASE- PROBABLY IN THE EARLY
SUMMER AT LET. HAVE FOR AT WITH
MONEY FROM CAP. AND ALL OF THAT
IS MATCHED BY FUNDING FROM FROM
SB ONE AND- ALLOWED US TO GEAR
UP AN EXAM THIS PROBLEM SO
QUICKLY WHICH WOULD HAVE BEEN
HELD IN. THE PAST MUCH.
ACTUALLY ALLOWED YOU TO MOVE
FOR WITH THE COLLABORATIVE THAT
IS. PROJECT NOW PRODUCING. THE
INFORMATION THAT YOU BROUGHT TO
US HAD ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THAT JUST- A
REMINDER. THE MAT. MEDIA
CAUGHT. HI HOW. THE ROLE. MONEY
CAN. HAVE A- WE GONNA THROW BUT
IF YOU DON'T MIND WE'LL TAKE
ROLE AND TO VOTE ONLY CALENDAR.
LET HERE FONG GARCIA YEAH
MULLIN PATTERSON BRASS. RIVAS
SO WE HAVE A QUORUM AND- WE
WILL MOVE ON TO THE VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR DO WE THE- TAKE MORE
THAN ONE DOLLAR YES WELL. ALL
THE ITEMS I IT'S A IT'S A S.
SEVEN THREE MIRACLE- WAIT.
WHILE I PULL FIVE BUT YEAH YEAH.
RIGHT MORE. IF THANK YOU BLOOM
I FONG GARCIA MULLIN PATTERSON
RADIUS RIVAS. I THINK THAT IS
THE FIRST OF THE SEVERAL YEARS
THAT I'VE BEEN SHARING THAT
SUBCOMMITTEE SO CONGRATULATIONS
EVERYONE. YOU UP PROFESSOR YOU
MENTION BUT- THIS- KIND OF
CONNECTIVITY BETWEEN- FREE
TRANSIT LOW INCOME WRITERS AND
ALSO TALKED ABOUT I'M SORT OF
SEE AS- AS TEN OF FIVE ACCESS
TO. BILLS THE RACING AUTO
ACCESS IN COME COMMUNITY THE
BOUNCE OF WHICH FOR BLOWING
ISN'T IT. I THINK THIS WILL
PLAY BETTER ELSE IS WHAT
POLLUTION ELLEN THE UP AND THEN
CONGESTION. HOW DO WE ADDRESS
THOSE ISSUES OF THE ISSUES OF
POLLUTION AND CONGESTION AND
MAINTAIN A MARKER TO THE XIN
THAT HAS THAT HAS TAKEN. SO OF
THE WAY I WOULD PUT IT IS THEY
HAVE SPENT THE BETTER THAN A
CENTURY DESIGNING CALIFORNIA
CITIES AROUND PRIVATE VEHICLE
TRAVEL. AND IT SHOULDN'T
SURPRISE US THAT AFTER IS EIGHT
THE PEOPLE WHO CAN ACCESS ICAL
DO A SIGNIFICANT IF IT'S- THE
PROBLEM IS. THAT THE COLLECTED
USABLE THAT TRAVEL IN IT IN
POSES ENORMOUS BURDENS ON ON
THE ENVIRONMENT AND ON SOCIETY.
AND THE WAY WE PUT IT IS THAT
PROBABLY IS NOT A BAD THING
THAT THAT IN SOME REAL WHEN
COME HELL SO WE'RE ABLE TO
DRIVE A LITTLE MORE. ALL HAVE
AN OBLIGATION TO CREATE IT
SENT. TO THE EVERYONE LOVES
LESS. AT THOSE THINGS ARE NOT
NECESSARY IT ALL ADDS I DON'T
WE'D WANT ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY
TO. I BEEN FORTY OUT OF
SOMETHING THAT APRIL EVERYONE
ELSE ENJOYS. AND THAT'S WHERE
THAT'S WHERE I MADE THE COP
ABOUT YOU KNOW THE TRANSIT
OPERATORS. DOING EVERYTHING
THEY CAN TO AND IT'S REALLY
RIDERSHIP. IT IS OPERATE WITH
ONE HAND TIED BEHIND ACT IS A-
THE PROCESSING POWER. THAT MAKE
IT EASY EN CONVENIENT FOR
EVERYONE TO DRIVE TO MOST
DESTINATIONS AND AS LONG AS WE
HAVE THAT. IS GOING ON LIKE.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE THE
STRUGGLE AND- THE DELAY HAVE IS
AT THIS PEOPLE IF YOU WERE ON
PUBLIC TRANSIT AND STUCK IN
TRAFFIC IN ITSELF FIND TO GET A
CAR AND DRIVE. THE LOWER YOUR
TRAVEL TIMES EVEN AS YOU IMPOSE
MORE DELAY. THE PEOPLE LEFT ON
THAT TRANSIT VEHICLE THAT'S
SOMETHING WE'RE IN ACTUAL
BEHAVIOR RESULTS IN INTO A
COLLECT TIONAL RESULTS. AND SO
UNTIL WE HAVE SOME OF AN
INCENTIVE SYSTEM IN PLACE.
WHETHER IT'S SOMEONE THE
REGULATE THROUGH PARKING. USE
OF ROADS OR WE DID AT LEAST IS
TO PRIVILEGE. MOVEMENT OF HIH
IF IT'S A VEHICLE AND ROADS AND
I KNOW THAT AN ISSUE HAS BEEN
INCREASING INTEREST IN IN A IN
A FOR EXAMPLE BUS LANES
DIFFICULTIES IN POUNDS OF AND
TING THOSE. THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS CAN PRIDE IS A STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION. THINGS
AREN'T AREN'T.AND THERE IS
THROUGH. THE USE TAX THE OTHER
KINDS OF THINGS THAT WE DO. WE
CAN REGULATE MOVEMENT ON THE
CROWDED STREETS AND ROADS TO
VARIOUS KINDS OF PRICING
SCHEMES THAT WE CAN THEN
PROVIDE. DRIVERS WITH LIFELINE.
SURE THE- AROUND. ALL OF THAT.
TRAVELING FOOT BY BIKE BY BUS
AND BY SCARED RIDE TO IN SEASON
TRACK. AND THOSE THINGS WILL
CALL INTO PLACE BUT RIGHT NOW
TO BE THE ELEPHANT IN THE ROOM
IS SOMEONE OWN THEIR CAR AND
DRIVING IT ANYTIME THEY WANT ME
WHERE THE- ANSWER OFF THE
TABLE. AS LONG AS THE IS WE'RE
GONNA BE STRUGGLING AROUND. IS
OTHER OPTIONS. IF WE'RE ABLE
TEST A TAB THAT. I THINK THAT
THE OPPORTUNE. OF CREATE MORE
TRACTOR TRANS WORK OUT WE
BECAUSE- DEPEND ON IN PART ON
IT ABILITY TO MOVE A LOT OF
PEOPLE THE SAME DIRECTION THE
SAME TIME. AND IT DOES THAT
WORK YES HI CONSIDER HOW. WAIT
SIR. COMES VERY ATTRACTIVE. BUT
THE DIFFERENCE EVERY MINUTES.
WILL BOULEVARD OR ON MARKET
STREET. AND HALF HOUR OR HOUR
SERVICE IN IN AND OUT PINE.
WHERE IS ENORMOUS. WHERE WE
GONNA GET THE- WHERE CARS ARE
ACTUALLY THE M<c.cyan> HARM TO ME.</c>
TRY TO THINK ABOUT MAY PRICE
AUTUMN AND ONE. AND NOT
NECESSARILY ME THE FACT THAT
INCOME PEOPLE HAVE ACCESS THEM
ON THE BUT A CONTRADICTION ONE
OF THE- IS IT TO. FOR TO SAY
THAT AT THE PRESENT TIME. IN
URBAN AREAS GENERALLY SPEAKING
THAT THAT. SINGLE PASSENGER
VEHICLE USE IS AT CAPACITY. IN
OTHER WORDS IS THERE A DO WE
ADDITIONAL CAPACITY- IN THE
ROAD SYSTEM TO ABSORB. UGH AT
ADDITIONAL SINGLES USE VEHICLE
TRIPS THAT THAT VARIES
ENORMOUSLY FROM PLACE TO PLACE
ENORMOUSLY EVEN WITHIN BIG
CITIES LIKE THE BEAR AND LA I
MEAN WE'VE DONE AN ANALYSIS OF
TRACK DELAYS. LA REGION FOR
BOTH AND YET THE NET. MONTANA
ON SERVICE STREETS THINGS ARE
NOT SO BAD BUT IF FOR EXAMPLE
THE ARC BETWEEN THE SANTA
MONICA PIER IN DOWNTOWN. IS NOT
ACTIVE PASSIVE IT'S WELL BEYOND
CAPACITY AND SO THAT THAT'S YOU
KNOW IN IN NOW WHAT WE'RE
SEEING IS IT'S MOVING OUT OF
PEAK PERIOD AND ALL DAY. THAT
HAS SIGNIFICANT ECONOMIC
IMPACTS BECAUSE IT SLOWS THE
ABILITY TO MOVE TO VARIOUS.
COURSE INVITE TAXES WILL BE
PATIENTS PER MILE GO UP
SIGNIFICANTLY EVEN. SELECT YOUR
STILL CHIU THE CONSUMER MORE
MILES IT IS CONGESTED I WENT IN
AND RAN JERRY IT'S BAD FOR THE-
BAD. THAT'S RIGHT. THEN
DEFINITION IT. IF WE WERE FOCUS
A LIMITED RESOURCE AND EFFORTS
ON THOSE AREA WHERE THE
CONGESTION IS GREATEST- I WOULD
ASSUME THEN THAT WE ACHIEVE THE
GREATEST VALUE. YEAH IN THE WAY
TO THINK ABOUT. THE NET WITH
THE FLOWS OUT OF THAT IS THAT
LET'S TAKE THAT ARE BETWEEN
DOWNTOWN IN SANTA MONICA OR WE
COULD DO THE SAME THING FOR THE
IN THE BAY AREA. THE NATURAL
RESPONSE THIS IS. THERE'S ALL
THIS TO GO ON RUSSIAN OF
ACTIVITY. AND WE'RE HAVING A
LOT OF TRAFFIC RESULT- SO
THEREFORE WE HAVE TO LIMIT THE
INCREASE IN THE THAT THE- MORE
ACTIVITY IN THAT AREA IN ORDER
TO ALLOW THINGS TO WORK THERE
WERE EVERYWHERE DRIVE ONTO A
ROAD ANYTIME THEY WANT ANYWHERE
THEY WANT. SO WE START WITH
THAT IT'S ALMOST LIKE THE FIRST
THE FIRST POSITION IS THAT
EVERYONE CAN DRIVE ANYWHERE
THEY WANT ANYTIME THEY WANT AND
THEN WE'RE GONNA JUST THE FORM
OF THE CITY TO FIT THAT. AND
THAT. THE LEVEL WE HAVE. HIS
BOB. ENGELS TO LAY. DEVELOP WAS
BUILT A AREAS. WERE PUSHING
DEVELOPMENT FARTHER OUT AND
THAT'S WHERE THE BAY AREA WERE
SEEING THESE INCREDIBLE
INCREASES IN COMMUTE DISTANCE.
EXAMPLE WHICH HAVE EVEN MORE
PERNICIOUS ENVIRONMENTAL-
IMPACT THOUGH. THE TO THE
DENTIST. IN MAKE IT DIFFICULT
FOR IN THOSE PLACES. THEY
BECOME THOSE PLACES BEING THE
DENSE DEVELOP PLACES THEY
BECOME MUCH MORE ATTRACTIVE TO
ME. ON FOOT. AND BY. ON
WEDNESDAY. MUCH EASIER TO GET
AROUND BUT LONG AS THAT THIS.
FILM CAR. WE IT OF THAT THE WAY
OF ALL POSSIBLE OTHERS THAT CAN
ASSIST RESPONSE EITHER WAS
MANAGE THE PRIVATE VIA. OR WE
SAY WE TO WREAK THIS A- THE
FOR. POSITION EVERY INCH BILL
TO DRIVE ANYWHERE THEY WANT
ANYTIME THEY WANT AND I THINK
THAT DISK A LOT OF THE DAY OF
THE DEBATES WE HAVE. AREA IN LA
YEAH. I WILL ARE ONE. A
QUESTION IN OUR COLLEAGUES
OPPORTUNITY TO. ASK YOU
QUESTIONS. WE HAVE THE HIGHWAY
PATROL HERE- TODAY TO A PRESENT
TO US- LATER ON IN THEIR BUDGET
ISSUES UP IS- HAVE HAVE YOU
DONE RESEARCHER YOU'LL WEAR
RESEARCH ON THE IMPACT OF
THESE- AT CAPACITOR BEYOND
CAPACITY STREETS. LAW AND-
RESPONSE TIMES FOR EMERGENCY
VEHICLES. I HAVE NOT DONE
RESEARCH ON THAT THERE IS
RESEARCH ON THAT. AND I COULD
REFER YOU TO I DO WANT TO MAKE
ANY COMMENT ON THAT THAT HERE I
DO KNOW FROM THE ONE PIECE THAT
I READ THESE QUITE A FEW YEARS
AGO IS THAT. THE AVERAGE DID
SAID THAT YOU NEED TO TRAVEL IN
THOSE PLACES LIKE TO THINK OF
IT IN A IN A DENSELY DEVELOPED
AREA. THE AVERAGE DISTANCE TO
HOSPITAL IS MUCH LOWER THAN IT
WOULD BE AN KALANGA- SO THAT
THE QUESTION OF HOW MUCH THE A-
A IS GOOD. YOU KNOW AT SOME
POINT IN HEAVILY CONGESTED
ROADS AND- IS THE VEHICLE. HAVE
TROUBLE GETTING THROUGH BECAUSE
PEOPLE PHYSICALLY CAN'T MOVE
ASIDE BUT I'M GOOD AT I WOULD
REFER YOU TO RESEARCH ON THAT
RATHER THAN FLOOD OF COURSE IS
A- FOR THOSE OF US WHO LIVE IN.
URBAN AREAS VERSUS RURAL AREAS
ONE OF THE- ASSUMED AMENITIES
IS BEING CLOSER TO MANY
SERVICES INCLUDING EMERGENCY
SIR THROW. UP I THINK GUYS IN
THERE I WOULD INTERESTED IN
SEEING THAT RESEARCH IF YOU
HAVE. TO GET TO ME. FOR I JUST
A FEW QUICK QUESTIONS IN TERMS
OF YOUR AT YOUR WORK YOUR
RESEARCH- IN TERMS OF THE
SURVEYS YOU DEVON PEOPLE WHO
RIDE AND USE PUBLIC TRANSIT IS
CONVENIENCE FACTOR AND GENDER
THE RIDE HAILING RIDE SHARING-
PLATFORMS- DO THE PUBLIC
TRANSIT. OPERATIONS DO THEY NOW
HAVE TO ADD. YOU KNOW CHANGE
THE BUSINESS MODEL OF THE WAY
THEY OPERATE IF AND I LISTEN
BAKERSFIELD. THE OUR PUBLIC
TRANSIT IS MOVING MORE YOU
TRYING TO INSTEAD OF HAVING
PEOPLE GO TO THE BUS STATION
BUT- PICKING THEM THEM UP AND
MOVING MORE OF A- A MOVING
TOWARD MORE RIDE SHARING MODEL.
WHAT WHAT WOULD YOU- WILL WILL
WHICH IS COMMON SPEED SO.
THERE'S A LOT OF REACH GENERAL
STATUS OF IT HERE'S SUGGEST
THAT PEOPLE WHO. THE TRAIN THEN
HOW ARE AVAILABLE FOR THE TRIP.
ARE YOU HAPPY WITH REPUBLICANS
EXPERIENCE IN THIS SORT OF
MAKES SENSE IF YOU THINK ABOUT
IT. THOSE WHO DON'T HAVE A CAR
AVAILABLE FOR THEIR TRIP. ARE
OFTEN LET LESS HAPPY WITH IT
IT'S IN ONE CASE SOMEONE HAD AN
ALTERNATIVE. IS IN PUBLIC. IS
THE FELT AN ALTERNATIVE TO
THEIR TRIPS WERE THAT WOULD.
THE HAVES. IN THIS IS. THAT IF.
BUT NOT NOT STATISTICALLY
RIGOROUS WORK BUT KIND OF FOCUS
GROUP WORK THAT SUGGESTS THAT
PEOPLE WHO DEPEND ON TRANSIT A
LOT BUT HAVE THE OPTION OF
OCCASIONALLY TAKING A TNC TO BE
MORE SATISFIED WITH THE TRANS
AND AS AT VARIOUS POINTS MUCH I
WAS COMPLETELY TRANCE. AND
GREAT 42820% SOMETIMES IT WAS
NOT SO CONVENIENT- YOU KNOW AT
THE BUS STOP RUNNING- SOMETHING
LIKE THAT AND SO WE COULD
PROVIDE NICE COMPLIMENTARY
SERVICE NOW THE OTHER THING
THAT MENTIONED IS THAT AGAIN
TRADITIONAL STREET FIX GET
PUBLIC TRANSIT FACT IT PLACES
WHERE A LOT OF PEOPLE TRAVEL
SECTION TIME. IS YEAH IT
PROVIDE. WHERE WRITING THE SAME
DIRECTION SAME TIME IN THOSE
CASES VARIOUS KINDS OF
PARATRANSIT WE USED TO SAY OR
EVEN THESE KINDS OF SERVICES
ABLE TO AT A LOWER PRICE
PROVIDE HIGHER QUALITY SERVICE
BUT THAT CAN OR- COULD YOU GET
INTO AREAS WHERE THERE'S A
HIGHER COUNTRY IN SCHOOL NEAR
LIKE THAT. PUBLIC IT'S PAYING
OFF ECONOMICALLY AND
ENVIRONMENTALLY SO WE CAN THINK
OF IT IS PERHAPSTHE POTENTIAL
FOR COMPLEMENTARY THIS. RIGHT
BY ANY OTHER. A COUPLE OF
OTHER- OF PRESENTERS WE HAVE
THE TRANSIT AGENCY FOLKS HERE
MON FORWARD. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY THIS
MORNING. HIS. THIS PIMENTEL
ANDERSON YOU'RE GONNA KICK US
OFF YET THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER CHAIR MICHAEL PIMENTEL
DEPUTY EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
THE CALIFORNIA TRANSITION
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA'S
PUBLIC TRANSIT AGENCIES I WANT
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE- FOR
HOSTING THIS TODAY. HOW WE WORK
CLOSELY WITH COMMITTEE STAFF-
TO ASSEMBLE A PANEL OF TRANSIT
PROFESSIONALS ARE GOING TO
SPEAK TO- THE VARIOUS EXTERNAL
CHALLENGES THAT ARE FACING
TRANSIT RIDERSHIP THINGS A FACE
DAY IN AND DAY OUT THAT MAKE IT
HARD TO- BALZER TRANSIT
RIDERSHIP IN THE- LIGHTS IN THE
STRATEGIES. THAT THE DOING I TO
THAT TO INCREASE TRANSIT
RIDERSHIP WITHIN THEIR SERVICE
TERRITORIES AGAIN JUST WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR
INTEREST IN THIS TOPIC. AND
MORE THE WISEST DIVERT.
NATIONAL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND BLUE AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS CONNIE
CHUNG AND THE SENIOR EXECUTIVE
OFFICER OVER SERVICE
DEVELOPMENT. AT LOS ANGELES
METRO. I JUST TO GIVE YOU A
LITTLE BIT OF CONTEXT LA METRO
IS THE THIRD LARGEST TRANSIT
AGENCY IN THE COUNTRY. WE CARRY
ABOUT ONE POINT TWO MILLION.
BOARDINGS USING OUR TWO
THOUSAND BUSES AND ABOUT ONE
HUNDRED MILES OF RAIL LINES.
AND WE'RE CONTINUING TO GROW WE
HAVE ABOUT THREE MAJOR RAIL
EXPANSION PROJECTS CURRENTLY
UNDER CONSTRUCTION. WE HAVE A
LOT MORE TRANSIT PROJECTS IN
THE PIPELINE IS NOW. WE HAVE
FIVE BEFORE I FROM SUCH AS
TRANSIT WHICH IS MORE ON DEMAND.
SOLUTION FIRST LAST MILE AND
OTHER TYPES OF TRANSIT SO PORT
OF PROGRAMS. UNFORTUNATELY AS A
PROFESSOR TAYLOR MENTIONED ARE
RIDERSHIP HAS BEEN DECLINING
PASS TWO YEARS. WE SEE PROBABLY
ABOUT IT FOR THE- SAN. THIS
TIME. TEMPORE THAT WE OUGHT TO
I WHAT THE FACTORS ARE BOTH
INTERNAL EXTERNAL THEY'RE
IMPACTING. AND HAD WE HAD THOSE.
AND READING THROUGH A PROFESSOR
TAYLOR'S WORK- THE ISSUE IS
SPEED COMES UP A LOT-
ESPECIALLY IN THE BAY AREA-
ANALYSIS- FASTER TRAVEL TIMES
MORE COMPETITIVE TRAVEL TIMES
ARE ARE REALLY A KEY TO. THE
SUCCESS OF TRANSIT AND THAT
AND- WE HAVE A NEXT GEN BUS
RESTRUCTURING PROGRAM GOING ON
RIGHT NOW WE'RE LOOKING AT THE
ENTIRE BUS NETWORK
RESTRUCTURING IT TO BE MORE
REFLECTIVE OF THE WAY PEOPLE I
WILL TODAY. AND THEN PUTTING
THE TRANSIT US PART OF
INFRASTRUCTURE TO SUPPORT THAT
AND A LOT OF PEACE OF THAT FOR
STRUCTURE PROGRAM IS REALLY TO
IMPROVE SPEED RELIABILITY A. K.
A. BUS LANES- SIGNAL PRIORITY
AND SO FORTH- WE FEEL THAT
THAT'S A- COMPONENT. I SAID.
AND ONE OF. A BUS ONLY IN
FLOWER STREET BETWEEN DOT A.
80% OF THE PASSENGERS ARE THE
PEOPLE THAT FLOW THROUGH THAT
COURT. SO THE BUSTLING WAS
REALLY USEFUL IN TERMS OF
IMPROVING THE OVERALL TRAVEL
TIMES DOWN THE CORRIDOR BY AN
AVERAGE OF FOURTEEN PERCENT.
AND IN SOME SEGMENTS OF THE
QUARTER WE ACTUALLY SAW AN
INCREASE OR AN IMPROVEMENT IN
SPEED. BY UP TO THIRTY PERCENT.
AS WE WANT TO CONTINUE TO BUILD
OUT OUR MOSTLY NETWORK
CURRENTLY HAS ABOUT TWENTY
SEVEN MILES A BUS LANES WE'RE
LOOKING AT A MEANT BEING. OUT A
HUNDRED OVER A HUNDRED MILES OF
US NEEDS THROUGH OUR- NEXT GEN
BUT STUDY. AND A LARGER THAT
THE SUCCESS IS REALLY THE
ENFORCEMENT OF LANES. SO WE ARE
SPONSORING BILL ASSEMBLY I A.
B. A TWENTY THIRTY SEVEN AND IF
YOU BUY TERM BLOOM PER OFFERING
THAT. BUT ALL METRO TO WORK
WITH. THEN THE OF LOS ANGELES
TO IN AUTOMATED BUS LANE
ENFORCEMENT. AND SO THAT'S A
CRITICAL COMPONENT OF THE
SUCCESS OF BUS LANES I AND THE
SUCCESS OF TRANSIT ITSELF.
ANOTHER AREA OF IMPROVEMENT
THAT WE SAW AND PROFESSOR
TAILORED TOUCHED ON IT IS
REALLY. A FREQUENCY. BECAUSE
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT SHORT
DISTANCE TRIPS. YOUR YOUR TIME
ACCESSING THE BUS STOP OR
WALKING A ROLLING TO THE BUS
STOP. AND WAITING FOR THE BUS
IT EQUALLY IMPORTANT AS YOUR
MOM VEHICLE. TIMES PERCEIVED
MORE OF YOUR TIME. ENTER YOUR
AND TO AND TRIP. SO IMPROVING
FREQUENCIES IS CRITICAL IN
TERMS OF ATTRACTING PEOPLE OR
MAKING TRANCE. COMPETITIVE AS
THE FOR SHORT. THAT WILL.
RESEARCH NOTED THAT ALMOST HALF.
CENTER AT. IN LA COUNTY OF WHAT
SO WHAT ARE YOUR TRANS OR WHAT
NOT OVER HALF FOR ALMOST HALF
OF THE ARE ONE AND FIVE MILES
SO THE RELATIVELY SHORT- AND
THE CHAIR AND GENTLY HAPPENED
DURING THE MIDDLE OF DAY INTO
THE EVENING AT PM PEAKS IN OUR
WAY INTO THE WEEKENDS SO LARGE
OF OUR NEXT STEP IS REALLY TO
PROOF BUT SEE. OUT THE TODAY OF
THE WEEK AND FOCUS THE- WHEN
YOU WE CAN PUT OUT THERE ARE
PART OF THE PAYMENT SO TO SPEAK
TO PUT THAT FREQUENCY IS
THROUGH SPEEDING UP THE BUS
NETWORK BECAUSE WHEN YOU SPEED
UP THE BUS NETWORK THAT BUS CAN
MAKE MORE TRIPS OUR I CURRENTLY.
TO JUST QUICK THE INFILL
GRANDEST UP SNAPPLE WE INCREASE
THE FOR WITH RICK RELATIVELY A
VERY LITTLE ADDITIONAL- OFFER
COST. NOW COMPARE PETTIT MRS
ONE ASPECT BECAUSE THAT ALLOWS
TRANSIT TO BE A VIABLE- TRAVEL
OPTION BUT WE ALSO NEED TO BE
ATTRACTIVE TO BE ABLE TO
ATTRACT PEOPLE INTO TRANSIT.
AND WE HAVE A LOT OF PROGRAM
WHEN I RIGHT NOW WHETHER IT'S
R. OF WIFI ON BUSES A USB PORTS
ON THE BUSES WE'RE TRYING TO
IMPROVE OUR BILL TIME AND
PATIENCE. CRITICAL I BILL IS
BECAUSE WE PEOPLE DON'T SEE THE
BUS THERE WHEN IT'S SUPPOSED TO
BE THERE BUT THEY CAN GET ON
THEIR APPS. AND SEE THAT THE
BUSES COMING WITHIN TWO MINUTES
A THREE THAT'S- EASY CONCERN HE
HE IS. WE PROJECT FATHER IN
THIS SECURITY A WATER VIEW AS
WELL AS SIDEWALK AND ALSO WASTE
TO IMPROVE FARE PAYMENT AS WELL
NOW I KNOW PROFESSOR TAYLOR DID
TALK ABOUT FREE FAIRS AND I
UNDERSTAND THERE ARE SOME.
PROPOSALS ON THE FLOOR
REGARDING FREE FAIRS WE HAVE
SEEN THAT THAT HAS PROVEN TO
INCREASE RIDERSHIP BUT WE WANT
TO BE CAUTIOUS IN TERMS OF
THOSE BILLS BECAUSE- AS
PROFESSOR TAYLOR SAID WE DON'T
WANT TO. MINIMIZE OUR REVENUES
POINT THAT WE CAN PAYING OFF
LEVELS. WE CAN WITH A TENER
SINCE THE STATE A GOOD REPAIR
SO WE WOULD LIKE TO WORK WITH A
WITH STATE LEGISLATORS. TO BE
ABLE TO FIND SOLUTIONS WHETHER
IT'S FINANCIAL SOLUTIONS TO- TO
SUPPORT THE USE OF PROPOSALS OR
OTHER MECHANISMS TO PROVE- AS A
SERVICE FOR PEOPLE WITH
GREATEST NEEDS. SO THEY CAN
ACCESS OUR OPPORTUNITIES. AND
THAT CONCLUDES MY COMMENTS THIS
MORNING I DO WANT TO. BRING
YOU ATTENTION TO THIS- SHEET
THAT'S IN FRONT OF YOU HEY. HI
THIS IS THE START OF A ONE
JUROR TO PAY. ON OUR NEXT STEP
BY STEP IN YOU CAN GET MORE
INFORMATION- FROM THAT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WITH BOB. IN THE
GRAVEL MIKE YES THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN BLOOM- I
APPRECIATE THE JAZZ HANDS I'M
I'M I'M ADVOCATING THE WINK AND
SHOOT THAT WE CAN POINT. OF HI
MY NAME'S CARL STORK ON THE C.
E. O. FOR THE MONTEREY SALINAS
TRANSIT DISTRICT IN MONTEREY
COUNTY CALIFORNIA- MONTEREY
SALINAS TRANSIT PROVIDES FIXED
ROUTE AND ADA PARATRANSIT.
SERVICES THROUGHOUT THE CENTRAL
COAST REGION AS FAR SOUTH AS
TEMPLETON IN THIS OBISPO COUNTY
AND AS FAR. AS THE SAN JOSE
AIRPORT- INTO SANTA CRUZ DOWN
TO BIG SUR A ONE FIFTH OF THE
COAST OF CALIFORNIA IS IN THE
MONTEREY SALINAS TRANSIT
OPERATING AREA WELL THE SWEET
NATURAL SOURCES THERE TO
ABSOLUTELY SIR THE HOTTEST
THING ON. OF THIS PEBBLE BEACH
BY THE SEA AND OF THE LOWEST
THING. AREAS OF THE STATE
CENTER SOME LUCAS OF THE
MIGRANT- FARMWORKER COMMUNITIES
ALONG HIGHWAY ONE A ONE OF THE
MOST BEAUTIFUL AND PRECIOUS
COASTLINE IN THE WORLD NOT JUST
THE STATE THANK YOU- THE
ECONOMY OF MONTEREY COUNTY IS
DRIVEN- GREATLY BY THE
AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY FOR
BILLION DOLLARS YEAR
HOSPITALITY. THREE BILLION
DOLLARS. A YEAR ANOTHER BILLION
EACH BETWEEN EDUCATION CAL
STATE UNIVERSITY MONTEREY BAY
SEVERAL COMMUNITY COLLEGES THE
NAVY POSTGRADUATE SCHOOL IN
DEFENSE LANGUAGE INSTITUTE-
ALSO- COMPRISE EDUCATION AND
DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE- WE HAVE
SEVERAL. FOR HER TO GET A CAMP
ROBERTS AS WELL IT IS ONE OF
THE FOUR PLACES TO LIVE IN THE
COUNTY- THE ACT I. PURCHASED A
CAR BOMB IT SOME GREATEST
EITHER. ACCOUNT THAT HAS TO DO
A LACK OF WHAT WE'RE NOT PART
OF THE STATE WATER SO THERE IS
NO NEW HOT THERE ARE NO NEW
HOMES BEING BUILT ON. SOFT
MANDATE THIS IS HOUSE WORK.
FIVE PEOPLE. CHECK SHEETS
TENDING BY CLEANING ROOM THEY
CAN LONGER IN MODERATE LIVE OUT
THE AREA SALIM I AND EVEN THE
SELENA VALLEY WE HAVE THE SOME
OF THE HIGHEST PERCENTAGES OF
PER CAPITA OF US UNDOCUMENTED
WORKERS AS WELL AS HOMELESS IN
MODERN ANY- NO LOCAL TAX FOR
FIXED ROUTE PUBLIC TRANSIT
WITHIN OUR COUNTY WE DO HAVE A
SMALL LOCAL STACKS FOR EIGHTY
EIGHT. SERVICES BUT ARE STILL
COMPLETELY ENDED ON FEDERAL AND
PDA FINANCED- TO RUN OUR LOCAL.
EXTRA TRANSIT INTO A NUMBER OF
PARTNERSHIP THAT I WILL SPEAK
TO LATER- WE NOTICED-
COMPARABLE TO THAT OF TESTIMONY
JUST HER MISTER TAYLOR.
UNDERSHIRT PETE WRECKED THE
RECESSION STARTED THE OVEN
AFTER THE RECESSION WE NOTICED
A RIDERSHIP WAS NOT REBOUNDING
ALONG WITH THE ECONOMY AND
PRIOR TO THAT YOU COULD JUST
TRACK ARE RIDERSHIP- TO THE
UNEMPLOYMENT STATISTICS- AS
EMPLOYMENT WENT UP RIDERSHIP
WHEN I. WAS NO LONGER HAPPENING
SO STARTED TO LOOK AT WHAT WAS
WHAT WAS HAPPENING AND WHAT WE
FOUND IS THAT A LACK OF WILL
HOUSING HAD PUSHED THE- INCOME
RIGHT. THE FIRST OF SELLING AND
MY- OUT IN THE MORE REAL OTHER
WEATHER WAS LAST AND NOTE AVAIL
AND EVEN OUTSIDE OF THE SOME OF
MY OWN EMPLOYEES- COMMUTING
FROM LOS BANOS SAM JOAQUIN
COUNTY OVER THE CHECK UP THE
COMING BURKE. I IN MY- NICE.
BUT I'M NOT SURE I'D WANT TO DO
IT EVERY DAY- SO INCREASED
ACCESS THE CALIFORNIA DRIVER'S
LICENSE THROUGH AB SIXTY WITH A
HIGH NUMBER OF UNDOCUMENTED
WORKERS- YOU SAW. PRIOR TO THAT
BOTTOM 1% GROWTH. IN DRIVER'S
LICENSE ISSUED ONLY ARE WITHIN
THE FIRST TWO YEARS AFTER- THAT
LAW WAS PASSED WE SAW DOUBLE
DIGIT INCREASES FIFTY. PERCENT
INCREASES AND NOT THAT STABLE
OUT 223% GROWTH. EACH YEAR NEW
DRIVER'S LICENSE WE'VE
INCREASED THE NOT EVERS. THE
SHIP. FINING I HAD EXCEPT KERR
I THINK THAT WAS BORN THE STATE
JUST HEARD OUR PREVIOUSLY SO
THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING IN OUR
COUNTY SO WHAT SALINAS TRANSIT.
OF SINCE WE COULD ALL DEPEND ON
OUR TRIP. LOW INCOME RIDER WE
HONOR SHIPS ARM WITH OUR
UNIVERSITIES COMMUNITY
COLLEGES- AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE- WHERE THEY'RE THEY'RE
ACTUALLY PROVIDING MORE FUNDING
TO US AND WE BRING IN AND FAIRS
OFF FROM PASSENGER SPECIAL
FORCES. THAT MAKE THE SERVICE
IS FREE. OUR STUDENTS FACULTY
STAFF JURORS ARE IN THE CASE
THE MONTEREY BAY AQUARIUM IN
THE CITY OF MONTEREY THEY FUND
A 100% OF OUR COSTS TO PROVIDE
FREE SERVICE- CANNERY ROW IN
TROLLEY VEHICLES ACTUALLY ON
THE CHARLIE VEHICLES THEM STE.
I GROWTH. FREE TO PASSENGERS
HAS HAS ACTUALLY- OFFSET OUR
LOSSES AND YOU YOU'LL SEE IF
YOU'LL JUST LOOK AT OUR TOTAL
RIDERSHIP IT HAS GROWN SLIGHTLY
OR IT'S FLATTENED OUT OVER THE
YEARS WE HAVE SEEN IN XIN
RIDERSHIP THIS PAST YEAR DO YOU
ARE IT THE LADY TO. I HIGHER
DRIVE. ARE BUS DRIVER NOT A
POSITION THAT YOU PEOPLE TO A
TO APPLY THE TYPE OF OURS TYPE
OF WORK THAT YOU DO- THE
WORKING CONDITIONS- THE ISSUE
THAT YOU'RE FOR THEIR FACED
WITH EVERY DAY DEALING WITH
THAT OUR PUBLIC STREETS AS YOU
ALL KNOW IS THE CONVERGENCE OF
OUR STATES MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS
OPIOID CRISIS. PORTABLE HOUSING
CRISIS. TRANSIT AND OUR DRIVERS
ARE THE ONES WHO ARE ON THE
FRONT LINES OF THAT AND- IT'S
JUST NOT ACTIVELY JOB WE'VE
ACTUALLY HAD TO CUT BACK
SERVICE TO OUR COMMUNITY DUE TO
A LACK OF DRIVERS AND THAT'S
BEEN HAPPENING ALONG THIS
BROWN'S AROUND CUT OFF IF
DINNER QUESTION DOES THAT.
HOUSE ALSO A PLAN TO YEAH I AM
YEAH WE LOSING WE'RE LOSING.
MECHANICS IT'S A LITTLE EASIER
FOR THEM TO PICK UP THE TOOL
BOX AND GO TO ANOTHER STATE IN
THE TECH THERE'S WITH THEM BUT
DRIVERS. WHAT WERE WE'RE- DONE.
RUMORS ARE READ AT A VERY PACE
AND WE ARE I HAVING TROUBLE
REPLACING THEM WITH MILLENNIALS.
SO WE HAVE OUR RECENTLY DONE
SOME FREE FAIR- EXPERIMENTS TO
GROW WRITER WE USING OUR LC TOP
LOW CARBON TRANSIT OPERATIONS
PROGRAM FUNDS ARE AND I WANT TO
GIVE YOU SOME RESULTS OF THAT-
WE DID FREE FAIRS WEEKENDS ALL
THE- SO. LETTER COMMUNITY
WITHIN OUR AREA QUALIFIES FOR
THE USE OF THESE TYPES OF
FUNDS- WHAT HAPPENED ON THE
WEEKENDS WAS FIXED ROUTE
RIDERSHIP DOUBLED. WHICH WAS
GREAT AND WE HAVE THE CAPACITY
TO HANDLE THAT BECAUSE THAT WAS
RELATIVE. LOW RIDERSHIP ON THE
WEEKENDS ANYWAY SO WE'RE ABLE
TO EXPAND THAT WE HAD A 20%
INCREASE. OUR FEDERALLY
MANDATED EIGHTY A SERVICES AT
ALL THIS CORRECT MISTER
TAYLOR'S TESTIMONY- WORRY SAID
THE HIGHEST SUBSIDY- TRIPS ARE
LONG DISTANCE COMMUTER ROUTES
THAT'S TRUE FOR FIXED ROUTE
SERVICES BUT FOR TRANSIT
OPERATOR WHO HAS TO READ-
COMPLY WITH FEDERAL LAW. YOUR
EIGHTY EVERY SAYS ARE FAR THE
MOST WE SUBSIDIZE VERSES AND WE
HAVE NO ABILITY TO TURN THOSE
TRIPS DOWN WE HAVE SET REACHED
AN FOR. PARKS EVEN CAN OUR
DROUGHT SERVICES SO ALTHOUGH I
WE RUN RISK OF LOSING. EIGHTY
TWENTY PER THE WEEK. ARM BASED
ON THAT SUCCESS WE WORKED OUT A
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND HAD
SEVERAL CAN'T COUPLE CAMPUSES
IN SALINAS HARTNELL COLLEGE-
ANOTHER CAMPUS AND SINKING SKI
IN SOUTH COUNTY WHERE THEY WERE
ALL THE SEPARATING THEMSELVES
TO RECEIVE A HALF DISCOUNT HALF
FARE DISCOUNTED FOR WE TOOK
THAT TO A FAIR. ANY HARTNELL
COLLEGE THE WITH THE ID RIDE
ANYWHERE ON MST SERVICE AT ANY
TIME. ARE JUST BETWEEN AUGUST
AND JANUARY OF THIS YEAR
COMPARING THAT THE AUGUST IN
JANUARY OF THE PREVIOUS YEAR A
TEN FOLD INCREASE. IN FIXED
ROUTE RIDERSHIP MATCHED BY A
TEN FOLD INCREASE IN THE EIGHTY
A RIDERSHIP. WE ARE HAVING TO
ADD DRIVERS ADD BUSES FOR
SAFETY CONDITIONS STANDING ROOM
ONLY ALONG THE HIGHWAY HIGHWAY
ONE A ONE GOING AT HIGHWAY
SPEEDS. IT'S A SAFETY. WE DON'T
HAVE THE CALL. OF THE EIGHTY
EIGHT- AS WELL SO. SERVICE IS
GREAT NOW WE'RE HAVING TO
RENEGOTIATE THIS CONTRACT WITH
HARTNELL BECAUSE WE WERE TOO
SUCCESSFUL- WITH THAT AND SO-
IT'S ULTIMATELY UNSUSTAINABLE
AT THIS POINT AND WE ARE AT WAR
SO WE'RE LOOKING TO RENEGOTIATE
WITH THE BUS DRIVER SHORTAGE
IT'S CALLED UP- TO KEEP UP
WITH. UP OF GROWTH- SO. THAT A
IT'S THE EIGHTY A SERVICES THAT
ARE THE REAL CONCERN FOR OUR
OPERATION WITH REGARD TO
OFFERING FREE SERVICES- OVER
HALF OF OUR EIGHTY EIGHT TRIPS
ARE MADE BY PERSONS UNDER
EIGHTEEN AND OVER FIFTY FIVE-
IN OUR COMPANY THEY'RE MOSTLY
GOING TO DIALYSIS- SERVICES AND
THE ELDERLY ARE GOING TO ADULT.
ALZHEIMER DAY CARE SERVICES-
OUR COMMUNITY SURVEYS- SUPPORT
WHAT WAS RECENT RECENTLY
TESTIFIED TO MORE NON WRITERS
PEOPLE WHO DON'T CURRENTLY RIDE
THE BUS WILL SAY THEY WILL
CONSIDER. AND WILL RIDE THE BUS
IF WE CAN MAKE IT FASTER. IF WE
CAN BE MORE FREQUENT. AND ONE
WAY WE CAN DO THAT IN MONTEREY
COUNTY WE HAVE NO HOV LANES WE
HAVE EIGHT MILLION VISITOR
TRIPS PER YEAR TO A COMMUNITY
OF A HUNDRED THIRTY THOUSAND ON
THE- PENINSULA- AND THEN
ANOTHER A- HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND SALINAS VALLEY WE HAVE
UP ALMOST TWO THOUSAND
AGRICULTURE. SLEEPER A ALL
ACCESSIBLE ONLY BY TWO LANE
HIGHWAY- WE'RE TYING TO BUILD
THE BUSWAY ALONG HIGHWAY ONE
WERE TRAFFIC IN THE MORNINGS
BECAUSE WHEN I HAD FILES PROP.
PRIEST ARE YOU SEE. UP WE'RE
BUILDING THIS BUS LINE USING A
HOPEFULLY USING T. I. R. C. P.
FUNDS. CAP AND TRADE FUNDS AND
SOME FEDERAL FUNDS. HOWEVER
WE'RE STUCK IN A VERY LONG
ENVIRONMENTAL PROCESS- THAT
WOULD BE THE SAME AS IF I WAS
BUILDING A LANE FOR CARS-
BUILDING PROJECT THAT WILL
REDUCE VMT TWO MILLION DOLLARS
TO MILLION MILES PER YEAR- AND
SAVE OVER FIFTY THOUSAND TONS
OF CO TWO. I WOULD HOPE THAT WE
COULD FIND SOME WAY FOR THESE
TYPES OF PROJECTS THAT REDUCE
CARBON EMISSIONS IN REDUCE VMT
THAT WE CAN FIND SOME WAY TO
EXPEDITE. OUR ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEW SILLY WE CAN BUILD THESE
PROJECTS FASTER. AND GET THE
ENVIRONMENTAL RESULTS WE WANT
AND THE ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITY
AND MONTEREY COUNTY AGREES WITH
ME. SO WE WOULD BE VERY
SUPPORTIVE AND I AM ANYTHING WE
COULD DO TO HELP BUILD THESE
PROJECTS FASTER WHAT'S THE-
ESTIMATED TIME AND FOR YOUR
ENVIRONMENTAL TERM YEARS. AND
YOU KNOW WE'RE GOING TO CLOSE
THE COMMISSION OKAY PARKS WHICH
DOESN'T. IT'S ALONG THE WEST
SIDE OF HIGHWAY ONE IN AN
ABANDONED REAL QUARTER THAT HAS
BEEN USED FOR SINCE NINETEEN
SEVENTY- IT'S DISTURBED RAIL
PROPERTY THAT WE JUST WANT TO
PAY EVEN GO OUT SIDE OF THE
HIGHWAY ONE TRAFFIC. I'M
INTERESTED. THAT CONCLUDES MY
TEST MIGHT BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS ARE MOVING ALONG
THANK YOU VERY AND LASTING-
WHEN WE MOVE TO THE NEXT
SPEAKER OF IN WRITING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR HAVING US
THIS MORNING MY NAME IS CLARK
GABLE GOES I SERVE AS THE
DIRECTOR OF LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS
COMMUNITY RELATIONS AC TRANSIT
ARE WE'RE HEADQUARTERED IN
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA IF EACH HAS
SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA SINCE
NINETEEN EIGHTY. WHERE THEY
EASE IS LARGE THE PROVIDER THE
TRANSIT. OWNED BY THE- OF THE
BAY IS GOVERNED BY A SEVEN
MEMBER PUBLICLY ELECTED BOARD
OF DIRECTORS. THE AGENCY WAS
CREATED AS A SPECIAL DISTRICT
BY THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE.
IN NINETEEN SIXTY. AYE WE SERVE
I TO COUNTIES PORTIONS OF
ALAMEDA AND CONTRA COSTA.
SERVING THIRTEEN CITIES AND
INCORPORATED AREAS I FROM SAN
PABLO ALL THE WAY DOWN TO SOUTH
SOUTH FREMONT- WE OPERATE A
HUNDRED AND FORTY NINE BUS
LINES OVER A THREE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY FOUR SQUARE MILE SERVICE
AREA. IN ANNUAL IS PROVIDE UP
FOR FIFTY THREE MILLION A
RIGHTS AVERAGING ABOUT. A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND- WEEK A I. EIGHTY
TRANSIT INTO NINETEEN AND
EIGHTEEN ARE WE'VE ACTUALLY
SEEN A VARIETY OF IT
INITIATIVES THAT HAVE RESULTED
IN SIGNIFICANT IMPROVEMENTS TO
THE QUALITY OF OUR OF OUR
SERVICE. I RESULTING IN
RIDERSHIP INCREASES OR AGENCY
DURING A PERIOD. DURING WHICH
NATIONAL NATIONALLY THE PUBLIC
TRANSIT INDUSTRY FAR RIDERSHIP
DECLINES AS AS IF YOU'VE AS YOU
HAVE BEEN HEARING THIS MORNING.
IT TWENTY NINETEEN AC TRANSIT
SYSTEM WHAT RIDERSHIP HIT OVER
FIFTY THREE MILLION REFLECTING
A TWO POINT 5% INCREASE OVER
TWENTY EIGHTEEN RIDERSHIP
FIGURES. ARE TRANSBAY SERVICE
WHICH YOU HEARD ABOUT THIS
MORNING WHICH CARRIES WRITERS
ACROSS THE THREE BAY AREA
BRIDGES SIDE A FIVE POINT 8%
INCREASE IN RIDERSHIP YEAR OVER
YEAR. SOME THE FACT THAT WE
BELIEVE TRIBUTE TO OUR- RIGHT
SHIP INCREASES. NUMBER ONE SIGN
INFUSION. OF SALES TAX DOLLARS
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN AFTER ALAMEDA
COUNTY VOTED TAX CELL. AND WE-
TOOK A RISK SHOP WORK INCREASE
REQUEST IS IMPLEMENTED ARE. OUR
GET STARTING IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
WE START TO SEE POSITIVE.
GENERAL IS IT AND UBER. IN
DOUBLE THE BUSES WHICH YOU WILL
SEE. ALONG THE EIGHTY OR CROSS
THE BAY INTO FRANCISCO WE TRY
IT WE INTRODUCED INTO OUR FLEET
IN DECEMBER ON THREE LINES
THOSE THREE LINES ALONE. TWO OF
THEM SAW INCREASES IN A ONE
YEAR OF 24% ONE LINE 530%
INCREASE IN RIDERSHIP IN THAT
WAY SINGLE YEAR. AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER A SEAT THAT IS GOVERNED
BY PUBLICLY ELECTED BOARD OF
DIRECTORS WE ARE ONLY ONE OF
THREE TRANSIT AGENCIES IN THE
ENTIRE COUNTRY. THAT IS- THAT
HAS A PUBLICLY ELECTED BOARD
WHICH MAKES IS UNIQUE IN A
COUPLE OF WAYS FIRST BECAUSE
OUR BOARD IS DIRECTLY ELECTED
BY THE VOTERS ARE BOARD MEMBERS
HAVE ONLY ONE VERY SPECIFIC BOB
AND THAT IS. PRESENT
CONSTITUENTS ON OUR TRANSIT
BOARD THIS IS DIFFERENT FROM
MOST AND THE AGENCIES IN THE
COUNTRY ARE TYPICALLY COMPRISED
OF BOARD MEMBERS ELECTED AS
COUNTY SUPERVISOR MAYOR
COUNCILMEMBERS. THEN APPOINTED
TO SIT ON THE BORDER LOOK WHICH
IS AGENCIES WHAT THIS MEANS FOR
US IS THAT DECISIONS THAT
IMPACT US. SUCH AS LAND USE
DECISIONS ARE DECISION STARTING
LOCAL STREETS AND ROADS SUCH AS
ELIMINATING LANES ADDING SIX
NORTH BY PLANE. BURKE THIS IS
IN TERM BECOME LEADER FOR. OF.
SHOW THE RIGHT AWAY THESE
DECISIONS- THROUGHOUT THIRTEEN
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS IN OUR
SERVICE AREA. I'M IMPACT OUR
SERVICE RELIABILITY AND
ULTIMATELY- HAVE AN IMPACT ON
OUR RIDERSHIP. WE HAD A FEW
TRAINS THERE ARE FORTUNATE TO
HAVE RECEIVED A SMALL STARTS
GRANT AGREEMENT FROM THE
FEDERAL TRANSIT ADMINISTRATION
WHICH COUPLED WITH OVER FORTY
ONE MILLION DOLLARS IN STATE
FUNDING AND REGIONAL FINDS OUT
WE ARE UNDER CONSTRUCTION ON
OUR FIRST ON OUR FIRST BUS
RAPID TRANSIT SYSTEM- THE EAST
BABY OUR TEAM. WE EXPECT TO
OPEN THE SYSTEM TO THE PUBLIC
IN THIS. YEAR I BRT PROP SO
OFTEN DESCRIBED AS LIGHT RAIL
ON WHEELS BECAUSE THEY HAVE THE
POTENTIAL TO DELIVER THE
FREQUENCY AND RELIABILITY A
LIGHT REAL PROSPECT AT A
FRACTION OF THE COST 80% OF OUR
BY SYSTEM OF OUR THIRTY SYSTEM
WILL OPERATE WITHIN A DEDICATED
BUS ONLY LANE. OUR PROJECT
PRESENTE TO IT AND THIRTY TWO
MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT IN
THE COMMUNITIES OF OAKLAND AND
SAN LEANDRO. AND WHILE IT'S
ONLY NINE AND A HALF MILES IT
IS GOVERNED BY THREE. DIFFERENT
BODIES THE CITY OF OAKLAND THE
CITY OF SAN LEANDRO AND
CALTRANS BECAUSE A PORTION OF
OUR CORD OR RUNS THE COUCH. TO
WAIT. I'M WE ARE A GREAT
TRAFFIC SIGNALS NONE OF WHICH
ARE OWNED BY US- WHICH ARE
GOING TO BE EQUIPPED WITH
TRANSITIONAL PRIORITY WHICH
WILL ESPECIALLY. GIVE BUSES
PRIORITY BY ALLOW TRACK YOU
KNOW TO REAP REAPING GREEN OF
YOUR TICKETS WITH SECOND THE
SYSTEM DETECTS THAT BUSES WITH
THE RANGE. OVERALL ARE I'M
INCLUDES. STATIONS THAT WILL BE
SIR NEW. ELECTRIC LOW GEN BY.
WE ARE. OFFERING NEW SIR TO OUR
WRITERS LIVE. FREE IT IS
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THIS.
HAS OVER TWENTY YEARS TO GET TO
THIS POINT FROM NINETEEN NINETY
NINE TO TWO THOUSAND ONE EIGHTY
TRANSIT GATHERED COMMUNITY
INPUT ON HOW AND WHERE TWO. MEN
TRANSPORTATION IMPROVEMENTS IN
OUR SERVICE AREA. THIS
PARTICULAR CORRIDOR WAS FOUND
TO HAVE HIGH RIDERSHIP AND HIGH
CONTROL RIDERSHIP INCREASES.
WHAT WAS ORIGINALLY PLANNED AS
OVER FIFTEEN MILES SYSTEM
BETWEEN SAN LEANDRO OAKLAND AND
BERKELEY WAS REDUCED TO THE
CURRENT ALIGNMENT ACT FAST TO
GAIN APPROVAL ON THE BERKELEY
CITY COUNCIL. PRIMARILY DUE TO
FEARS OF KING REDUCTIONS AND
PUSHED BACK ON THE NOTION OF
GIVING UP A VEHICLE TRAVEL INTO
BY THIS. THE BUT PUSH BACK
AGAINST PARK LIMóN IT WAS
STRONG ENOUGH TO HAVE. STOPPED
SHORT OF CITY. AND WHILE WE'RE
STILL FORWARD. I WITH OUR PART
AGAIN SAN LEANDRO CALTRANS AND
ASK IT'S A VERY COMPLEX
RELATIONSHIP WITH COMPETING
INTERESTS THAT REQUIRE STRONG
COMMITMENTS FROM EVERY EVERYONE
I IN ORDER TO KEEP THE PROJECT
MOVING. IN OAKLAND WHICH IS
HOME TO A HALF OF OUR FUNDS IN
OFTEN OUR SYSTEM ARE THEY HAVE
A NEWLY ESTABLISHED DEPARTMENT
OF TRANSPORTATION WITHIN THE
CITY I THEIR LEADING AN EFFORT
TO INSTALL BUS ONLY LANES IN
THE CORE OF DOWNTOWN. AND ONE
SECTION OF THE BUS ONLY LANES
FOR OUR B. R. SYSTEMS OPERATE
AND WE ESTIMATE A TRAVEL
SAVINGS OF ABOUT 30% AND 20%
PROJECT AND I. IN RELIABILITY
THIS IS ONE EXAMPLE OF HOW
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS CAN TAKE
STEPS TO HELP IMPROVE TRANSIT
RELIABILITY AND PERFORMANCE AND
ULTIMATELY HELPED INCREASE
RIDERSHIP. AT EIGHTY TRANSIT WE
HAD A STAFF LEVEL WELL AS TO
OUR BOARD OF DIRECTORS WORK
WITH OUR LOCAL. TO ENSURE THEIR
DECISION THE ULTIMATE HAVE A
IMPACT I TRIED SERVICE WE
PROVIDE. NOW A BIT OF THE- TONY.
THERE'S A VISOR DO I OR THE
DECISIONS THEY MAKE A DIRECT
AND ON OUR LET USE DECISION
RIGHT AWAY JUST PARKING LANES
BUSTLING ARE ALL THIS IS BY LOW
ME THAT DIRECTLY IMPACT THE
QUALITY OF OUR SERVICE WHICH AT
THE END OF THE DAY DRIVES
RIDERSHIP UP OR DOWN THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME THIS MORNING
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF. IT EVEN
ALL THE INFORMATION THE
CHALLENGES THAT TO THE FAA SAYS
AGENCIES- WITH- A VERY- VERY TO
RAIN AND RIDERS AT THE THAT THE
THAT YOU SERVE PUBLIC THAT YOU
SERVE. OF MISTER MARK. HE WAS
SURE THANK YOU ALL FOR THE
PRESENTATION OF MR TRYING YOU
USE THE PHRASE SPEED UP THE BUS
NETWORK AS BEING CRUCIAL TO ALL
OF OUR EFFORTS CYBER ASSUMING
YOU'RE TALKING A FISSION SEES
LIKE ELECTRIFIED. B. R. T. STOP
START. TIMES DEDICATED LANES
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS HE JUST
EXPAND A LITTLE BIT ON. ON YOUR
THINKING AS ON HOW WE ACTUALLY
SPEED UP THAT NETWORK SURE
YEAH. IT'S SPEEDING UP THE
NETWORK IN TERMS OF TOTAL
TRAVEL TIME SO WHEN YOU LOOK AT
YOUR TRIP YOU'RE LEAVING YOUR
FRONT DOOR YEAR WALKING OR
ROLLING TO A BUS STOP YOU'RE
WAITING FOR THE BUS GETTING ON
THE BUS AND YOU'RE MOVING. AND
SO IN ALL ELEMENTS OF THAT WE
WANT TO TRY TO. REDUCE BARRIERS
TO IT THOSE OF THE STEPS OF
YOUR TRIP AS IT RELATES TO
BEING ON THE VEHICLE I
DEFINITELY. HAVE OUR- PROGRAM.
OUR IS BANDS BE BY THIRTY NOW
WE ARE GOING IMPLEMENT FIRST ZB
DEPLOY ON A ORANGE LINE PURITY
PROJECT BECAUSE THERE ARE
SYNERGY BETWEEN. ELECTRIC BUS-
RANGE AND- THE ABILITY TO- TO
KIND EXTEND THE AMOUNT OF YOUR
TRAVEL THE BUSCA MAY WITHIN
THE- BATTERY- I CAPACITY- AND
THE SPEED OF THE BILL AS WELL
SO WE ARE WORKING ON-
ELECTRIFYING THE WAR SO I FOR
OF THE SILVER LINE WHICH IS
NOTHER ONE OF OUR BE OUR CHEAP
PROJECTS IT'S SORT OF A HYBRID
RT AT OF THE SECOND AND THEN
MOVING ON TO OUR TYRAEL SO-
WHAT WE'RE ALSO DOING IS. THE
OTHER THINGS THAT YOU CAN ONLY
AT THIS THE BOSTON WERE
IMPLEMENTING BOARDING WE'VE AND
THAT I WE HAVE AN ORANGE LINE
BUT WE'VE IMPLEMENTED THAT ON
THE SILVER LINE ARE SEVEN
TWENTY ON ON WILSHIRE CORRIDOR%
AND THE SEVEN FIFTY FOUR WHICH
IS OUR VERMONT QUARTER RAPID
THOSE ARE THE DO. DOORS WE
GENERATE. THINGS ARE THIRTY
SEVEN THAT BRINGS A DAY AND BY
IMPLEMENTING BORE YOUR LAW
PEOPLE TO GET IN THE BUS AT ALL
DOORS AND THAT'S OF MINIMIZES
THE TWELVE I AM AT YOUR STOPS
ROSS AND IT'S A STRAIGHT UP MY
SORT OF RATIONAL STOPS PACING
SERVICE THERE'S A OF THINGS
COULD DO IN BUT REALLY THE BIG
PUSH ON HIM. SPEAK IS WORKING
WITH THE LOCAL JR AMAZON THE
BUS LANES TRANSISTOR PRIOR YOU
KNOW CHIU JUMPERS AND ALL OF
THOSE FANCY THINGS. FOR SOCIAL.
WITH THE MS THE RIVER OF ALL BY
MY WHERE HIS. THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR YOUR FOR AND I A MEMBER
FROM THE SENATE VALLEY- SO LA
METRO- AND- YOU MENTIONED-
PROPOSALS FROM THE LEGISLATURE
ON THAT OFFER FREE RIDERSHIP IN
SOME FORM FOR TO ASSERT
POPULATION IN MY QUESTIONS
ABOUT YOUTH. THE KNOW THE
RIDERSHIP FOR YOUTH YOU KNOW I
THINK IF WE GET THEM WRITING
EARLY AS YOUNG PEOPLE AND- THEN
THEY'LL INCREASE THEIR
LIKELIHOOD OF CONTINUING- TO BE
A- YOU KNOW TO USE PUBLIC
TRANSIT- AND I WAS WONDERING IF
ELEMENT. HAS A PLAN FOR THAT
ARE NOT SURE WHAT YOU CURRENTLY
OFFER YEAH I MEAN WE ACTUALLY
OFFER DISCOUNTS ON OUR ON OUR
AFFAIRS- IF YOU LOOK AT OUR OUR
SO STAND FAIR THE AVERAGE.
YOU'LL FAIR TO A DOG SEVENTY
FIVE YEAH BUT OUR AVERAGE FARES
DOWN PROBABLY SIX FIVE SENSORS
BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT OF
DISCOUNTED FARES OUT THERE FOR
SENIORS DISABLED- STUDENTS-
HIGH SCHOOL KIDS AND UNDER AND
SO FORTH AND THEN ALSO COLLEGE-
IT STUDENTS AND VOCATIONAL
SCHOOL THE CURRENTLY STUDENTS
HAVE TO PAY. I SOME. YEAH THE
DO PAY THERE WAS AT DISCUSSION
AT OUR RECENT BOARD MEETING THE
TALKED ABOUT INTO FREE FARES
FOR STUDENTS- THAT ARE OF THE
GREATEST NEED IT'S THE LOWER
INCOME AND SO FORTH- WE ARE
STUDY RIGHT NOW TO SEE SIR HOW
WE PRIORITIZE THE DIFFERENT
CONSTITUENT ARE RELATIVE TO I
WAS MEDIAN HIS HIS LAST. I'M
AND WE'RE ALSO LOOKING OUT THAT
WOULD DO IN TERMS OF IMPACT OUR
THE TO PROVIDE SERVICE ABILITY
TO MAINTAIN THE SYSTEM AND SO
FORTH. OKAY THANK YOU SURE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER S. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. IT THE ENTIRE
DISCUSSION THAT WE'RE HAVING IS
SO TIMELY- THE LEGISLATIVE
LATINO CAUCUS JUST HAD THEIR
POLICY RETREAT. AND ONE OF THE
DISCUSSIONS THAT WE HAD WAS THE
FACT THAT. OFTENTIMES ARE
TALKING ABOUT JUNE ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES BUT MANY MANY
OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES CAN AFFORD TO LIVE
IN TWO ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE.
THAT WE REALLY HAVE TO BE
TALKING ABOUT. TRANSIT WE'VE TO
TALK ABOUT THE INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR TRANSIT WE TO TALK ABOUT
HOW WE GET MORE PEOPLE OUT OF
THEIR CARS AND INTO THE
SYSTEMS. I UNDERSTAND THAT
TODAY IS OF INFORMATIONAL AND-
AND I APPRECIATE THAT MOST
EVERYBODY IS FROM LOS ANGELES
OR THE BAY AREA. I DID HEAR ONE
COMMENT ABOUT FONTANA EARLIER
AND I APPRECIATED THAT- I'M
FROM THE INLAND EMPIRE AND I
KNOW THAT WE HAVE BIGGER
CHALLENGES- BUT- MY QUESTION IS.
WHAT WHAT WILL BE
IMPLEMENTATION LOOKED LIKE DO
WE HAVE A TEN YEAR PLAN A WE
ALREADY LOOKING AT WHAT WE NEED
TO DO SO THAT AS WE MOVE
FORWARD GOING TO GET PEOPLE OUT
OF THEIR- THE SINGLE WRITER-
ATTITUDE- THAT WE'RE GOING TO
GET PEOPLE TO FIND AT FIND WAYS
TO TAKE. TRANSPORTATION EDIT MY
COLLEAGUE IS THERE IS LESS
SOLUTION NOW US MEMBER GONZALEZ
INTRODUCED LET'S JUST GEN SO
THAT STUDENTS WOULD FREE. AGAIN
WHO REACH AND- A WRITER SO TO
SPEAK BUT WHO WERE- WHERE ARE
WE ON A PLAN- SO THAT WE CAN IT
THE WE KNOW WE NEED TO REDUCE
THE NUMBER OF VEHICLES ON THE
ROAD. WE KNOW THAT PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION IS A PERFECT WAY
TO DO THAT. AND WILL BE SO WE
HAVE INDIVIDUAL IDEAS BUT AS A
STATE. WHERE ARE WE ON PLANTS
ARE WORKING WITH THE ON PLANTS.
HELLO I FEEL WE HAVE A SAYING
IN OUR INDUSTRY WHEN YOU'VE
SEEN ONE PUBLIC TRANSIT
OPERATOR YOU'VE SEEN ONE PUBLIC
TRANSIT OPERATOR BECAUSE THE
NEEDS OF OUR COMMUNITIES ARE SO
UNIQUE I I'M FROM BOB
REPRESENTING MONTEREY SALINAS
TRANSMITTER COUNTY A GRADUATE
OF REDLANDS HIGH. IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE SPELL I LIVED FOR QUITE
AWHILE SAN FERNANDO STATES I
KNOW VERY. MUCH THE ISSUES THAT
YOU BASE THEIR. AND I'D SAY YOU
KNOW WE HAVE COME YOUNG CAL IS
THE ENVY OF MANY OTHER STATES
WITH SOME OF OUR SALES PROGRAM
THAT THE TRANSPORTATION
DEVELOPMENT ACT. AND THEN THE
S. ONE FUNDING THAT CAME
STATES- THERE ARE PROGRAMS- AT
THE STATE LEVEL THE CALIFORNIA
GRATED TRAVEL- PROGRAM WHERE
WE'RE LOOKING AT UP WITH SINGLE.
THANGAL IMAGE THAT YOU. THIS
CROSS A BE A EXCEPT BY TRADE
OPERATORS LIKE YOU AND ALL YOU
DON'T HAVE TO HAVE A DIFFERENT
CARD TO STOP AT DIFFERENT TO A-
FIRST. ALL RIGHT WHY DON'T WE
HAVE A SINGLE CARD YOU CAN CAN
USE ON A SINGLE- TRANSIT
OPERATOR SO MAKING THE PAYMENT
ACCESSIBLE AND RE LOW BALL-
NOTE LOADED ON YOUR PHONE AND
GO SOUTH THERE ARE. PLANS BEING
FROM THE BACK BUT- JEFF WHAT WE
CALL EACH. IS DRIVEN BY LOCAL
LAND USE PLANNING DECISIONS
THAT IN SOME CASES WE HAVE NO
CONTROL OVER AS THE OPERATOR
OUR SELF YEAH WE CAN COMMENT ON
THE INVITE ALL. ASPECT THAT WE
CAN COMMENT AT PUBLIC HEARINGS
BUT ULTIMATELY- OFTENTIMES WERE
SHOOT FORMED IN. AFTER THE FACT
WHEN MAYBE THE DESIGN DIDN'T GO
AS PLANNED SO THERE STE WE HAVE
MANY GOOD TEMPLATE. FUNDING AND
PERSPECTIVE WERE THE WHERE THE-
OTHER STATES BUT WE ARE ON TO
GO. AS FOR AS CORPS. TRAVEL
THROUGHOUT REGIONS- AND THAT
THAT'S ALL I CAN SAY THAT I
THINK- EVEN THOUGH WE'RE ALL
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT- WHAT SHE
HERE ESPECIALLY FROM US AND
FROM PROFESSOR TAYLOR AND HIS
COLLEAGUES IS THAT THERE ARE
OTHER STRATEGIES. A SIMILAR
WE'RE TRYING TAKE A SEAT
THROUGH THEIR HOPES RESTRUCTURE
STUDY REALIGN THE HOUSE WITH
YOU KNOW THE WAY PEOPLE TRAVEL
TODAY THAT'S WHAT WE'RE GOING
TO. THE NET GEN AND A I THINK
THE FIRST ORDER REALLY TO GET
THE NETWORK HELLO OF US HAVE
LOOKED AT OUR NETWORK IN LAW
TIME IT'S THEN WE'VE HAD YOU
DIFFERENT. BEFORE OUT NOW
REALLY TRAVELING AND MONDAY
THROUGH FRIDAY ANYMORE AND WE
NEED BE SURE THAT ACCOUNTING
FOR THAT IF NOT WE'RE MAY
ALIGNING ARE SIR WITH WITH THE
TRAVEL PACK THAT THAT EXISTS
TODAY SO ONCE RESET YOUR SIX A
LOT OF US ARE IN TO THESE STOP
TO SPEEDING UP. ASPEN RELY. KEY
UP FOR OUR CITY. AND WE GO
ABOUT IT IN IN SLIGHTLY WAYS.
BUT YOU TALK TO A OF OUR UNIQUE
COMMUNITIES THAT WE SERVE AND
THEY ALL SAY. FIVE ALL YOU KNOW
DOESN'T MATTER. TO BEYOND THAT
WHAT WE NEED TO DO. OKAY AND
WHEN YOU GET BEYOND THE FASTER
CAR RELIABLE YOU NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE- THE- CUSTOMER
EXPERIENCES IS NICE THE QUALITY
OF SERVICE I THINK. MISTER
TAYLOR THE QUALITY OF RIDE-
ZERO MISSION BUSES ONE THING
AGAIN PUTTING AMENITIES- ON
YOUR BUSES BUS STOPS ARE
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT BECAUSE
THAT'S THE ACCESS. NETWORK
ITSELF AND MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE FEEL SAFE SECURE
COMFORTABLE- ON ON THE VEHICLES
IS REALLY CRITICAL AHEAD HE IN
THE COMPREHENSIVE ANALYSIS TO
SEE DO YOUR DO YOUR ROUTES
MATCHER POPULATION SHIFTS HAVE
HAVE EMPLOYMENT CENTERS CHANGED
OR- LOW INCOME HOUSING OR JUST
WHAT WHERE PEOPLE LIVING IN
WHERE THEY TROUBLING TO. AND
SIDES. TO GROW SERVICE BUT
REALIGNING YOUR SERVICES I'D
WE'VE SEEN MUCH SUCCESS AND SAN
DIEGO MTS IS GROWING RIDERSHIP
SIMPLY BY REALIGNING THEIR
SERVICES AND I BELIEVE IN-
CENTRAL COUNTRY THE COUNTY-
CONCORD AREA THEY'VE ALSO SEEN
RECENT RIDERSHIP GROWTH JUST BY
DOING THIS THE WHAT YOU'RE
DOING NOW BUT I'M IN TODAY I
BELIEVE WE'RE ALL GOOD IT'S
PROCESSING NOW. WE HAVE ACCESS
TO NEW TO NEW DATA USING DATA
DATA GENERATED BY CELLPHONE
USERS THAT- MAKES IT MUCH
EASIER FOR US TO IDENTIFY
SHIFTS AND TRAVEL PATTERNS AND
WILL BE SAYING THAT. IN
ADDITION TO FAIR DISCOUNT
PROGRAMS- IN MONTEREY WE'VE
BEEN APPROACHED BY OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICT THEY WANT TO PURCHASE
DEEPLY DISCOUNTED PASTORS AND
WE WILL DO THAT FOR THEM- THE
DIFFICULTY WITH FREE AS IF IT'S
NOT BEING PAID FROM STE. ARE
YOU KNOW THAT IT'S NOT REAL DOT
ARE USED MAKE A ROLL BY QUICK
AND- SO WE HAVE TO PAY FOR THE
BUS AND PAVE THE DRIVERS AND IF
WE TAKE THE FAIRS AWAY. AND
IT'S NOT COMING FROM SOMEWHERE
ELSE- WE NEED TO FIGHT WE HAVE
TO MAKE THAT UP FOR. WE DON'T
ANYBODY TO OKAY TO DO IT FREE
THAT TOO WE'RE NOT INVOLVED
HAVE A QUESTION IF I MAY THIS
WOULD CAUSE. EASY TRANSIT WAS
CREATED THROUGH LEGISLATION OR
HOW WAS IT CREATED CORRECT
WHERE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
DISTRICT. OKAY VERY GOOD IN THE
MY LAST QUESTION I STEPPED OUT
TO MEET WITH SOME PEOPLE FROM
I. T. AND- MUSIC YEAH. HEARING
AND WHAT THAT WAS MADE IS. WE
USED TO HAVE SCHOOL BUSES. AND
NOW WE'VE TAKEN AWAY THE SCHOOL
BUSES BECAUSE OF. A PROBLEMS
WITH WITH WITH FUNDING. SO NOW
YOU HAVE ALL THESE PARENTS NOW
GETTING IN THE CAR- DRIVING
THEIR CHILDREN TO SCHOOL. IS
THAT THE LINES ARE LONG WHILE
THERE YOU TO TAKE THEIR
CHILDREN OUT- OF. WHEN SCHOOL
IS ARE NOW ELECTRIC SCHOOL
BUSES WHAT ARE YOU THOUGHTS ON
GOING BACK. NURSE BUSES. SO I
CAN I CAN SPEAK TO THAT EASY
TRANSIT WE ACTUALLY HAVE A VERY
ROBUST- SCHOOL A SERVICE IT'S
NOT- DEDICATED SCHOOL SERVICE
BECAUSE BY FOR ALL REGULATIONS
I THAT IS NOT ALLOWED IT WOULD
BE CONCERT CHARTER SERVICE WHAT
WE- TAKE OUR- STATE. THIS I AYE
AYE WORKERS. IN BASICALLY THE
EAST TO SAN FRANCISCO AND THEN
THOSE BUSES TURN AROUND AND
THEY PICK KIDS AND TAKE TO
SCHOOL I'M SO. DO YOU THREE
THREE TRIP WITH ONE BY ONE
OPERATOR I WE CARRY ABOUT. THAT
THEN. ON A GIVEN DAY BUT IT IS
A CHALLENGE DO YOU HAVE
CAPACITY ISSUES WERE NOT. TO
FULLY UP MINE- I AM SERVICE TO
IT LIAM WITH THERE'S. WELL
SCHOOL TIMES TO START BEFORE
EIGHT THIRTY FOUR MIDDLE OF
HIGH SCHOOL AND EIGHT AM FOR
MIDDLE SCHOOL WE'RE EXPECTING
TO SEE IT. A PRETTY BIG HIT ON
FINANCIALLY DISSIPATING ABOUT
SEVENTY BILLION DOLLARS. A YEAR
I'M SORRY TO BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE THAT THAT
WE PROVIDE. MOST OF THE
DISTRICTS OUR SERVICE THEY
DON'T YELLOW WILL BUSES. AND SO
WE HAVE- FILLED THAT NEED I'M
WITH PUBLIC TRANSIT. THANK YOU
CAN THANK YOU MISTER THANK YOU
FOR THE- THANK YOU FOR THE
RESPONSES AND ALL THE
INFORMATION YOU PROVIDE TO US
THIS MORNING BECAUSE THIS. HAS
BEEN IN FROM NINE TO OR NOT- IN
A STRING INFORMATIVE FANS I'M
GLAD WE TOOK THE TIME TO DO IT-
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO- A
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION CALTRANS SENT
TO. BEGIN WITH THE ITEM THAT WE
PULLED FROM THE- OF VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR RELATING TO
PEDESTRIANS. SAFETY WHO ARE-
YOU'RE GONNA PRESENT ON THAT
ISSUE TO STEP FORWARD. HELLO
WELCOME- THE NEW- DIRECTOR OF
CALTRANS I THINK THIS IS YOUR
FIRST APPEARANCE BEFORE THE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE WILL.
HOPEFULLY IT'LL BE A GOOD
EXPERIENCE FOR YOU. BUT I'M
SURE IT WILL BE A GOOD EXERCISE
I HOPE SO IS THE HOPE SO AS
WELL WELCOME THANK YOU.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. GOOD
MORNING- GERMAN THE GERMAN
BLOOM AND THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- AGAIN TALKS OF A
SHOCK AND I'M YOUR- CALTRANS
DIRECTOR AS OF FOUR AND A HALF
MONTHS AND WITH ME IS- MISTER
GILBERT PRACTICE SONS WHO IS-
THESE ARE ACTING BUDGET CHIEF
WAS BEEN ON TOP ROUGHLY A MONTH
AS WELL SO THERE'S ABOUT
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS THAT'S
RIGHT IN OUR SUITE WE KNOW ALL
THE STUFF VERY WELL- SO THINGS
WERE FOR HAVING US. THANKS FOR
HAVING US HERE THIS THIS
MORNING WELL DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION REQUEST- A TWO
YEAR LIMITED TERM INCREASE OF
TWELVE POSITIONS AND TWO POINT
TWO MILLION DOLLARS FOR
PEDESTRIAN AND BICYCLE
POLITICALLY INVESTIGATION VEST
OCCASIONS CONSISTENT WITH THE
FEDERAL HIGHWAY SAFETY
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM AND
CULTURAL STRATEGIC MANAGEMENT-
PEDESTRIAN BICYCLE TARGET. BUT
HIGHWAYS THE IMPROVEMENT. AND
FOR CHIEF IN A TOWARD ZERO DE
GOLD THANK FOR THE AND BY
PERFORMANCE MEASURES SO THIS
WAS AN ITEM THAT YOU- GERMAN
YOU WANTED TO TALK ABOUT
SPECIFICALLY SO- THAT IS OUR
REQUEST- IN THIS IN THIS
UPCOMING BUDGET. GREAT CAN YOU
GIVE US AN IDEA ON THE- QUAYLE
GO ABOUT PRECEDING. A WITH THE
INVESTIGATION AND-
IMPLEMENTATION OF REFORM SERVER.
PLANS WITH RESPECT BY CAN OF
PETITIONS SAFETY. SO WHAT YOU
KNOW ONCE WE ONCE WE ARE HIRED
ADDITIONAL STAFF WE WILL BE
ABLE TO USE THAT ADDITIONAL
STAFF TO WILL BE ABLE TO
DEDICATE THEIR TIME- TO THIS
ISSUE A LITTLE BIT MORE- A
LITTLE BIT MORE CLOSELY WERE
SEEMS UP SOME VERY DRASTIC
INCREASES THE YOU MAY YOU MAY-
ON THE FRONT. OUR OVERALL
SAFETY NUMBERS ARE THAT WE SEE-
ROUGHLY THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED-
FATALE HE'S- ON OUR
TRANSPORTATION NETWORK AND IF
COP I COME TO USING THE TRUCK
PATIENTS. AND ROUGHLY TO THREE-
OF THOSE BUT WHAT ALSO IT IS
TEN A DAY IS THE NUMBER IS
ROUGHLY TO NUMBER TEN PEOPLE A
DAY DIALED OUR TRANSLATION
SYSTEM ROUGHLY TWO TO THREE OF
THOSE. ARE ALL. THAT ARE WHAT
WE CALL THE MOST USER SO-
SOMEONE WALKING TO ONE BIKING
OR- AND TRY OF SOMEONE TRYING
TO GET ACCESS TO TRANSIT OUR
COLLEAGUES WHO JUST- LEFT THE
LEFT THE PANEL HERE- NOTICE
VERY WELL. SO WE'LL BE ABLE TO
HAVE. STAFF THAT ARE FOCUSED ON
THIS ISSUE A LITTLE BIT MORE
CLOSELY- IT WILL BE. GOING IN
THE FIELD DOING INVESTIGATIONS
UP WILL BE USING INFORMATION
FROM OUR PARTNERSHIPS- WHO IN
THE ROOM TO THE C. ANOTHER
LOCAL LAW ENFORCE THE LAW
SUBMIT TO. OUR PERHAPS ISSUE.
AND BUT YOU KNOW IN SOME QUE BE
A REAL ISSUE A THAT'S A DONE A
FIVE. WHERE SOMEONE WAS YOU
KNOW SOMEONE DRINKING DRIP AND
DRIVING OR SUPPORT WAS
DISTRACTED AND IN SOME CASES IT
MAY BE ACTUAL INFRASTRUCTURE
ISSUE- WHERE. ARE YOU KNOW THAT
POOR LIGHTING OR THERE WAS A
BAD CROSSWALK OR WHATEVER IT
MAY BE- BUT WE'LL HAVE MORE
STAFF THAT WILL BE TO DEDICATE.
TO ADDRESS THEM ONE. THANK YOU.
I'D LIKE TO MOVE ON TO. THE
NEXT ISSUE. THERE ARE RARE A
WILDFIRE SIXTY I'M LOOKING. YES
THIS IS- ISSUE NUMBER TWO AS
WELL FAR LITIGATION I THINK
YOU'VE ASKED FOR SOME
ADDITIONAL- POSITIONS IT IT TO
THEM YES WHAT WE DID SHERMAN-
THAT PERMIT STATION REQUEST AN
INCREASE OF POINT SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR FORTY FOUR FOR YOUR
LONG TERM. RESOURCES FOR
INCREASE IS IN THE LEGAL
VISIONS WORKLOAD SO FROM WHILE-
VIOLETS SHOULD THE WORKLOAD
FIRST REGARDING MY FOR A LIL
LITIGATION SEEDS THE LEGAL TENS
OF THIS THING THANK CANNOT.
CURRENT LAW AND FUND. THERE ARE
MOST WILDFIRE LITIGATIONS THAT
MAKE COINCIDE WITH EACH OTHER
DURING THE NEXT YEAR WITH THE
NUMBER OF PLAINTIFFS RANGING
FROM SIX HUNDRED TO ROUGHLY
FIFTEEN HUNDRED TO OVER FIFTEEN
HUNDRED I SHOULD SAY TIMELY AND
DEFENSE OF WATER LETTING THEM
REQUIRE DEDICATED RESEARCH SAYS
SPOKE PERFECT TO THE IMMEDIATE.
METS AB SO WHY- DO THIS IN
HOUSE AS OPPOSED TO HIRING- A
QUALIFIED LAW FIRM- THAT
ALREADY HAS AND- EXPERTISE IN
THE AND THIS TYPE OF LITIGATION.
SO IT WHAT WE'RE FACING THIS
ISSUE- PRETTY PRETTY HAD ON AS
THE AS WE'VE SEEN THE WILDFIRES
THAT HAVE PICKED UP- ACROSS THE
STATE RECENTLY. PERSONALLY I
WAS THE DAY I WAS SWORN IN IN
TODAY'S JOB THE CAN KATE FIRES
STARTED ACROSS THE STATE- AND
OUR DEPARTMENT OUR STAFF HAD TO
YOU KNOW HOW TO IMMEDIATELY
REACT THIS- BUT THE ON. ALL
HANDS ON. BACK BEAMED OUT
RESPOND TO. BE FOCUSED EVERYONE
IS ROOM KNOWS WHAT THAN I DO
WE'VE HAD SEVERAL OF THE FIRES
THAT WE ARE- WE'RE HAVING TO GO
THROUGH LITIGATION ON RIGHT
NOW. I THINK THAT THE EASIEST
WAY TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION IS
WE BELIEVE WE'VE GOT THE
EXPERTISE BECAUSE WE'RE DEALING
WITH THE STRUGGLING. WE'VE GOT
THE EXPERTISE IN HOUSE. TO DEAL
WITH THAT- THEIR COST-
CHALLENGES AS RELATES TO. I
SOMETHING LIKE THIS- WE LOOK AT
UPWARDS OF PROBABLY THREE
HUNDRED DOLLARS THREE HUNDRED
DOLLARS AN HOUR. BOB AND COST.
IF WE WERE TO GO TO. A PRIVATE
ENTITY TO HELP US WITH THIS
LITIGATION SO WE THINK IT'LL BE
MORE EFFICIENT IF WE DID THIS
WORK IN HOUSE- AND- AND THE
COST AS WELL- WILL BE. WE
BELIEVE A LOT HIGHER- IF WE
WERE TO OUTSOURCE. TO A PRIVATE
FIRM TO HANDLE FOR US ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU- THIS LA- HAVE ANY
COMMENTS TO. THANK YOU MINUTES
THAT THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE- HELLO GERMAN WOMAN
MEMBERS- BELIAU RECOMMENDS THAT
THE- COMMITTEE APPROVE
AUGMENTATION FOR COUCH AND JUST
LEGAL DIVISION. AND I
ASSESSMENT WE FIND IT LIKELY
THAT WORK LOAD WILL INCREASE
STEMMING FROM THE WILD BY
LITIGATION. AND THAT IT'S IN
THE INTEREST OF THE STATE TAP
CALTRANS SUFFICIENTLY FUNDED TO
THE BAND IN ANY LAWSUIT REGARD
BEEN- IN REGARDS TO WHAT FOR
LITIGATION. OVER AND LOOKING
INTO THIS ISSUE FURTHER WE
IDENTIFIED THAT THE DEPARTMENT
HAS THE LEVEL SERVICE SCORES
RELATED THE TREE AND BRUSH
ENCROACHMENT. LEVEL SERVICE
SCORES IN THIS AREA OF HAVE
BEEN AROUND SEVENTY AND RECENT
YEARS. AND A RECENT REPORT-
FROM TRAINS GET TO THE
APPOINTMENT THE GOAL OF NINETY
WE HAVE IT. HELLO HELLO SERVICE
SCORE ARE WHAT CONTRIBUTED TO
THE WILD FIRES. BUT THEY ARE
CONCERNING GIVEN THE SEVERITY
OF WILD FIRES THAT OCCURRED IN
RECENT YEARS- AND WE BELIEVE
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT THE
COMMITTEE MAY BE INTERESTED IN
ASKING THE DEPARTMENT- AND IF
YOU LOOK IN YOUR AGENDA. YOU
HAVE A LIST OF QUESTIONS THAT
IT. THEN WE RECOMMEND THAT YOU.
DEPARTMENT AND GUARDS HOW IT
CONDUCTS- VEGETATION MANAGEMENT.
CAN CAN YOU. DEFINED WHAT THE
LEVEL OF SERVICE SCORER MEANS-
YES OF COURSE- LEVEL SERVICE
SCORES ARE- CONDUCTED BY
CALTRANS PERIODICALLY- THEY
RANGE FROM ZERO TO A HUNDRED
BUT ZERO BEING LOW AND A
HUNDRED BEING HIGH- THEY'RE
DONE ON A DISTRICT WILL BASIS
THAN A SAMPLING OF THE STATE I
IT'S THEM AN AGGREGATED FROM
DISTRICT WELL STATE LEVEL. TREE
IMPRESSION QUOTE FROM MARTIN
STANDING IN BOTH CALTRANS IS
DOING IN TERMS OF CONDUCTING
ITS VEGETATION MANAGEMENT WITH
TRIM BRUSH ENCROACHING ON THE
STATE HIGHWAY SYSTEM WHAT GOES
INTO DETERMINING- A SCORE. FROM
MY UNDERSTANDING IN DETERMINING
A SCORE IT'S BASED ON HOW WELL
THIS SAMPLING OF THE STATE
HIGHWAY SYSTEM- REFLECTS OUR
ACCOUNT AND IS- ABIDING BY ITS-
MET ITS MAINTENANCE POLICIES-
BUT I WOULD BELIEVE THAT THAT
BE A BETTER QUESTION DIRECT
DEPARTMENT TO HOW EXACT. TO
CALCULATE. THE PART AND NOT
RESPOND TO UP A LITTLE BIT DOWN
THE WE I KNOW THAT I WAS GONNA
HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN SO IT IT
IF- YOU'RE NOT PREPARED TO
ANSWER THE QUESTION TODAY IT'S
SOMETHING THAT- WE ADDRESS
STAFF LEVEL TWO YEAH AND THEN
WE CAN GET BACK CHAIRMAN WE CAN
WE CAN GET BACK TO YOU WHAT
WHAT DETAIL ON ON HOW THIS IS.
HOW THE SPORT SEVEN HUNDRED HOW
TO ELLIS OF SIG JUST BRIEFLY
THAT WE GO THE WAY YOU APPROACH
THIS IS THAT WE HAVE A REAL
BASED OUT APPROACH SO THE AREAS
THAT WE THINK ARE- THAT ARE
MORE LIKELY TO CAUSE ISSUES FOR
US. IN THE STATE SO ON THOSE
THOSE AREAS MORE SO THAT HAVE.
THE HOUSE WILL HAVE. IF YOU
WILL OUR AREAS WE DON'T SEE AS
A POTENTIAL HAVE AN EIGHT A
HIGHLIGHT REASON TO BE
CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT WE FOCUS
HEAVILY ON THOSE AREAS AREAS WE
THANK WILL CAUSE THE MICHIGAN
ISSUES FOR US OF AS RELATES TO
FIRES WE FOR ONE OF THE AREAS.
THAT MAY IMPACT. SOME OF THE
SCORING OF THAT THAT. WE SEE
THAT WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
OVERALL SCORE FOR- FOR THE
ENTIRE STATE SYSTEM SOME AREAS
MAY- MAY SCORE- IN IN THE IN
THE PORT. POOR CONDITION BUT
WITH THIS ON A HIGH HIGH- HIGH
RISK HERE. IS WHAT DO. AND THEY
ADD THE DIRECTORS IS COMMENTS
LEVEL STE THE SERVICE SCORES
ARE ALSO BASED ON. THE AMOUNT
OF MAINTENANCE- CAN BE PROVIDED
FOR THAT FUNCTION AS WELL AS
THE PRIVATIZATIONS THE EFFORT
NO I DIRECTED TOWARDS
MENTIONING YOU KNOW WHEN WE
HAVE THE WILDFIRES DOES TAKE
HIGHER PRIORITY CLEARING OUT
THE BURNED AREAS BECAUSE THAT'S
AT RISK FOR THE MOTORING
PUBLIC. BUT A HIGH PRICE
ALREADY YOUR- WHICH WHICH- TO
OTHERS. I THAT MAYBE MORE
BECAUSE- IT IS NOT A SLEEP A AT
TWO THE MOTOR AND- SO I RESULT
CAUGHT. BILLS OF SERVICE SCORES
YOU KNOW NECESSARILY. PIECE
BASS WE WOULD LIKE SO BECAUSE
OF THAT IT TAKES OF ANOTHER
CYCLE TO GET TO THE QUESTION
BECAUSE THE PART. SO IN. IF I
WERE IN AN NOT ANOTHER WAVE IT
WILL BE IN ORDER TO ACHIEVE
MAXIMUM LEVELS OF SAFETY AND
FOR EXAMPLE HIGH FIRE. ZONE
AREA. OF RESOURCES MIGHT BE
DIRECTED THERE AS OPPOSED TO
CLEANING UP TRASH ON THE SIDE
OF ROAD IN AN URBAN AREA- SO
THERE WOULD BE LESS OF THAT I
GUESS THE- DOWNSIDE IS THAT.
ROUGHLY IN AND GET OUT BY WAY
OF EXAMPLE AND- I THINK THE
DOWNSIDE OF THAT- IS THAT IT-
LENDS TO THE PUBLIC PERCEPTION
THAT INFRASTRUCTURE WORK IS NOT
BEING DONE- AT AT AT THE LEVEL
THAT THE- EXPECTS AND- FALSE.
FALSE ASSUMPTION SYSTEM WIDE
BUT WHEN PEOPLE SEE THAT. ARE
ON ON THE ROADWAY. IT LEADS TO
IT BUT A NAGGING PERCEPTIONS.
DEFINITELY SOMETHING IF THAT
WOULD BE. A STEP PIECE OF WOOD.
ONE TO WORK ON APARTMENT HAVE A
AND- THAT. NO IT IS PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THE END OF- ALL
THREE OF THESE ITEMS YES. OKAY
ALL RIGHT YES WE'RE GOING TO
PAUSE FOR A SECOND AND- DO ADD
ONS BOTTLE. THIS IS FOR VOTE
ONLY ISSUES ONE THROUGH FOUR
AND SIX THEIR NINE THE MOTION
WAS I. PATTERSON RIVAS. THANK
YOU OF. AND DOES SO AT MY
REQUEST WE'RE GONNA- FULL THIS
ITEM OPEN HOUSE SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE THE DIALOGUE THAT WE
BEGAN HERE TODAY AND THEN- WILL
MOVE ON TO ISSUE THREE AND THEN
WE'LL TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT. OKAY
THE DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION REQUEST A TEN
MILLION DOLLAR AN AFFRONT
TRANSFER TWO POINT ROUGHLY TWO
POINT FIVE MILLION ANNUALLY
OVER FOUR YEARS FROM THE LOCAL
AIRPORT LOAN ACCOUNT TO THE
AERONAUTICS ACCOUNT. THE
TRANSFER WILL PROVIDE AN
INCREASED ANNUAL LOCAL SYSTEMS
FUNDING CAPACITY OF TWO POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS. TO FUND
THE AIRPORT IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM
A MATCHING GRANT PROGRAM. THE
HOUSE THE CAP OF A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND FOR- INDIVIDUAL
GRANT DETERMINED. SO THAT CAP
IS DETERMINED IS BY USING OUR
HISTORICAL DATA OVER THE PAST
FIVE YEARS YOU KNOW WEEKS HAVE
DEMONSTRATED THAT WERE SEEN
THAT OVER 90% OF THOSE
APPLICANTS APPLYING FOR THOSE
GRANT. BEYOND A HUNDRED FIFTY
DOLLARS TO FEEL VERY
COMFORTABLE AT THAT AMOUNT
WOULD SATISFY WHAT WE NEED.
OKAY ELIA COMMENTS. I HAVEN'T
SO WE HAVE NO CONCERNS
REGARDING THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE- REQUIRING THE CDFA TO
COLLECT THE FUEL TAX DATA AND-
THIS WILL HELP THE STATE-
GATHER INFORMATION TO COMPLY
WITH THE FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS
IN THE FUTURE- AS FOR THE
REQUEST TO TRANSFER FUNDS FROM
THE LOCAL AIRPORT SLOW THE CAP
ON TO THE- AERONAUTICS ACCOUNT.
FOUND PROPOSAL TO BE IS THE ON
THIRSTY. THE LADY AT THE AMOUNT.
AND MANY CAN ADMINISTRATIVELY
TRANSFER FROM THE LOAN ACCOUNT
TO THE AERONAUTICS ACCOUNT IF
THE TWO POINT FIVE MILLION IS
INSUFFICIENT- AND COVER THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO- ON
THERE IS TO MONITOR THE ISSUE
AND REYES VISIT WHETHER OR NOT
THAT HUNDRED FIFTY THAT CAP IS
TEN. TO FISH AND TO ME IS A
THEIR PART MOVING FORWARD.
RIGHT TO THE DEPARTMENT THAT'S
JAMES MORE THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- I WOULD LIKE TO JUST
REITERATE THE ALEJO'S COMMENT
THAT IF THIS TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION IS INSUFFICIENT TO
PROVIDE THE MATCHING FUNDS UP
TO THAT HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLAR CAP- WE HAVE EXISTING
STATUTORY FOR. TO DO MORE TO
ENSURE THAT ALL APPLE WILL
LEAVE. 5% MATCH UP TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS. OKAY
SEC GOOD TO KNOW. THAT IS A
PUBLIC COMMENT ON- ITEMS SUCH A
TWO OR THREE AT AND THE
PEDESTRIAN BIKE SAFETY ISSUE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
STEVE BIG WITH THEIR AND
REDUCES HIS FOR THE
PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERS AND
CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT ON THE
BICYCLE AND PEDESTRIAN SAFETY
ISSUE URINALYSIS NOTES THAT.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN
AUTHORED LEGISLATION IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THAT SET UP A
TASK FORCE TO TAKE A LOOK AT
THIS ISSUE THE TASK FORCE IS
NOT NEEDED THEIR WORK THE
MIDDLE OF NUMBER OF
COMPREHENSIVE RECOMMENDATIONS-
THIS MONIES NECESSARY TO
IMPLEMENT THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS
IMPROVE. BICYCLE PEDESTRIAN
SAFETY WE SUPPORTED. THANK YOU.
DO YOU WANT TO GO BACK A GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS JIM CUMMINS INTERNATION
OF OPERATING ENGINEERS. WE
REPRESENT AMONG OTHERS WE
REPRESENT THE MAINTENANCE
WORKERS IN CALTRANS. ON THE
LEADER ABATEMENT ISSUE I THINK
WE'RE DOING WELL IN MAKING A
LOT OF PROGRESS. AND WE'RE
TRYING TO MEET HAVE BETTER
DISCUSSION OF THE DEPARTMENT
NOW BECAUSE PART THAT LITTER
ABATEMENT PROGRAM ALSO INCLUDES
HOMELESS AND CHEMICAL WEAPONS
SOME OF THE OTHER ISSUES. AND
WE ARE HAVING A TROUBLE WITH
OF. CRUDE MEANT. IN RETENTION
CALTRANS TO BE ABLE TO COVER
ALL THE WORK DICTATES DICTATED
BY THE MISSION OF THE
DEPARTMENT SO WE HOPE TO. HAVE
BIGGER AND BETTER CONVERSATION
WITH THE DEPARTMENT ON THAT TO
SEE IF WE GET OUR GOAL THERE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND WE
WILL TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT ON A-
A TRANSIT TO INFORMATION ITEM
ALSO I APOLOGIZE FOR NOT TO
CALLING THAT OUT EARLIER. HI AM
WITH THE CALIFORNIA AIRPORTS
COUNCIL WHICH MANY GIVE
COMMENTS ON AND THE DIVISION OF
AERONAUTICS IN THE TRANSFER- SO
WE REPRESENT THE THIRTY ONE
COMMERCIAL SERVICE AIRPORTS IN
THE STATE AND WE'VE BROUGHT
FORWARD TWO SEPARATE ISSUES
RELIEF TO BE CONSIDERED WHEN
THE TRANSFER TEN MILLION
DOLLARS. AND THEN THE SECOND.
THE CREATION OF EIGHT TRACKING
FORSMAN SAYS RADIATION FEEL
TAXES SO FOR THE EIGHT TRACKING
SYSTEM WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
SWEEPING CHOI FOLLOWING THE
SINCE TWENTY FIFTEEN. IT IS
MUCH NEEDED REST ABLE TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH THIS QUESTIONS
WITH THE I AEA MOVING THE STATE
INTO COMPLIANCE. ANY POLICY.
THE TEN MILLION DOLLARS
TRANSFERRED VISION OF ARE NOT.
THIS IS VERY ENCOURAGING FOR
AIRPORTS. THE DIVISION HAS BEEN
WOEFULLY UNDERFUNDED IN THE
PREVIOUS YEARS AND WE'VE SEEN.
ACQUISITION AND DEVELOPMENT
GRANTS HE SUSPENDED WE'VE SEEN
IN. A I. P. GRANTS HAVE TO BE
RETURNED- TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT BECAUSE STATE
AIRPORTS HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO
LEVERAGE THOSE DOLLARS WITH THE
MISSING STATE. GREAT TO MATCH-
SO WE'RE ENCOURAGED TO SEE THAT
TWO POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
OF THE NEXT FOUR YEARS. AND WE
WOULD SIT GOT STE OF YOUR
LITTLE LATE GRAN GOAL THIS YEAR.
SO EXPECT TO SEE AN UPTICK IN
AIRPORTS APPLYING FOR THAT
STATE MATCH OVER THE NEXT TWO
TO THREE YEARS JUST BECAUSE IT
GIVES THEM A BIT MORE TIMES.
HELLO WITH OUR CURRENT GRANTS
APPLE BUT MUCH AND- THE- FOR
HAVING SHIFT HERE MANY MITCHELL
PROBLEM ACTUALLY COMMENTING ON-
ITEM NUMBER ONE ABOUT PUBLIC
TRANSIT RIDERSHIP- I REPRESENT
SACRAMENTO REGIONAL TRANSIT AND
ALONG WITH OUR PARTNERS EVEN
THOUGH- WE RESPECTFULLY I AGREE
WITH THAT THE RESEARCH AND THE
TREND STATEWIDE I'D LIKE TO
POINT OUT THAT SACRAMENTO OR
TEASE ACTUALLY HAVING
INCREASING SHIP. FIGURE ALLOW
YOU ARE SO RIGHT FREE PROGRAM
WHICH WE WERE ABLE TO ACCESS DO
A GOOD JOB WITH THE CITY
SACRAMENTO FOR LOCAL MEASURE
SEEN INCREASES OF UP 2721005%
OF STATE RIDERSHIP FROM. AND
FORWARD HELLO PARTNER TO SHARE
THAT THIS IS AN EXPENSIVE TASK
HOWEVER IF YOU'RE ABLE TO THINK
OUTSIDE THE BOX AND LOOK
ACTIVELY I OTHER FUNDING
SOURCES I THINK COULD BE DONE.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT ELECTED
TO THE COMMITTEE TO THE CHAIR
IT'S THAT WE HAVE TO VALUE AND
PUT OUR CUSTOMERS FIRST
DIMENSION ABOUT FREQUENCY OF
TRAVEL BUT ALSO ENSURING THAT
WE HAVE SEAT. SECURE AND A
WELCOMING ARM BY MEN FOR
WRITERS NOW WE'RE FACING A
LARGE. IT WAS CARE INDEPENDENT
MAKE SOCCER T. PRIORITIZE
SAFETY COMMUNICATIONS FOR BOTH
THE WRITERS AND OUR- WORKERS
AND OUR STAFF. AND ALSO WE AT
TRY TO WORK WITH OTHER PARTNERS
EXTERNALLY- TO BE PUSHED
INNOVATION AND EMBRACE
TECHNOLOGY WE NOW HAVE TNC.
SHIPS WE HAVE MICHAEL MAJORITY
OPTIONS AT OUR LIGHT RAIL LINES
WE'VE SEEN INCREASING GROWTH IN
OUR LIFE. THANKS FROM THIS
MONTH ALONE WITH 14%
COMBINATION. LOOK BAD THANKS S.
EMBRACING C. V.'S CONVERTING
OUR A MICRO TRANSIT MOBILITY
OPTIONS AS WELL AS PROVIDING
TRANSIT ON DEMAND AS AN OPTION
FOR USERS. WE LOOK AT
TECHNOLOGY SUCH AS- CENTRALIZE
EVERYTHING IN ONE APP WE ASK
OUR CUSTOMERS WHAT IS BEST FOR
YOU. SO THAT YOU CAN HAVE A
MORE ACCOUNTABLE CHOICE. WE
THEN LIST AND SO I'LL- PRESS
THE CAN. ARE LOOKING AT.
RIDERSHIP DECLINE WE SAY
THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US
TO FLIP THIS NARRATIVE AROUND
WE ARE ONE OF THE FEW CITIES IN
THE LAST YEAR TO WITH NAME. AND
WE HOPE TO SEE THIS TREND
GROWING AND WE APPRECIATE ANY
SUPPORT FROM THE LEGISLATURE-
TO THIS ISSUE THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ALL FOR
YOUR COMMENTS AND- I THANK YOU
DIRECTOR FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
THIS MORNING GOT WILL HOLD UP
AND- BOTH OF THESE ITEMS AND
RETURNED TO THEM- WHEN WE GO
THROUGH THE NEXT A- CYCLE OF
REVIEW. OF THANK YOU. ACTUALLY
BE TAKEN THIS MORNING. WILL
MOVE ON TO DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR
VEHICLES AND- WELCOME CHAIR
TANK. TO ARE. YOU ARE HEARING.
WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN- WITH
ISSUE FOR ITS INFORMATION ONLY
THAT'S THE REAL ID UPDATE. AND
I KNOW IT'S A LITTLE BIT EARLY
TO BE- OPINING ON THE TOPIC-
BUT THERE IS. A HAS BEEN
EXPRESSED SOME CONCERN- THAT-
THE- A CORONAVIRUS SAID MAY
HAVE AN IMPACT ON- ARE OUR
PLANNING KERR FOR ADDRESSING
SOME OF THESE ISSUES SO YOU CAN
WORK AT ANY EARMARKED IF YOU
HAVE ANY INFORMATION THAT BE
GREAT. GOOD MORNING BLOOM AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS GOOD MORNING-
THANKS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DRESS THE COMMITTEE TODAY I'M
STEVE GORDON DIRECTOR OF THE
PART AND MOTOR VEHICLES I THINK
THIS IS YOUR- FIRST AS A TO
WORK- COMMITTEE ALSO IT IS SO
WELCOMES GOOD TO HAVE YOU
ABOARD YEAH. WE HAVE A NUMBER
OF A- THE DEFECTORS HERE. SO
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE AND
BEING COACHED TO DO SOMETHING.
I'M NEW- NEW RIGHT. GET YOUR
ACT TOGETHER ALL RIGHT I'LL DO
BETTER SO. I'M STEVE GORDON AT
DIRECTOR DEPARTMENT MOTOR
VEHICLES WITH ME IS THESE GOT
OUR CHIEF BUDGET OFFICER. AS A
NEW DIRECTOR OF EXCITED ABOUT
THE OPPORTUNITY TO MODERNIZE
THE V. OPERATIONS TO BETTER
SERVE OUR CUSTOMERS. IS AN
ISSUES FOR FIVE. AT YOUR BLOOM-
APPEAR TO COVER ALL THREE OF
THESE ISSUES DURING MY OPENING-
AT FOUR ADDRESS THEM SEPARATELY
WHICHEVER YOU PREFER. LET'S TO
THEM WANTED A TIME. ALL RIGHT
GREAT THE FIRST ONE I THINK IS
ITEM AT ISSUE FOR REAL ID JUST
AN UPDATE YEP YES- WELL REAL
IDEAS BEEN- PRESENTED- HAS
PRESERVED THE BE WITH. STORE
CHALLENGE AS YOU KNOW MILLION
CALIFORNIA'S MUST COME INTO THE
V. FIELD OFFICE TO REQUEST A
FEDERALLY COMPLIANT WE CARD.
AVOID TALKED TO HER FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY ENFORCEMENT DATE.
THE FEDERAL REAL ID ACT
REQUIRES THEM TO PRESENT A REAL
LADY TO GET A REALITY IN PERSON
AND SHOW UP OUT WITH A VERY
SPECIFIC SET OF DOC. I CITY
MUCH UP BUT- MEMBER THE
CALIFORNIA A- STATE WE'RE NOT
MANDATING CALIFORNIA'S TO GET A
REAL ID BASED ON OUR SURVEY OF
OTHER VOLUNTARY STATES AT DMV
ASSUME TO PARTICIPATION RATE OF
75% WHICH REPRESENTS ABOUT
SIXTEEN MILLION POTENTIAL REAL
ID CUSTOMERS. WINTERS THE LOWER
ANTICIPATION RATE AT THE ONSET.
THAT INCREASE WOULD- THAT WOULD
INCREASE AS WE GOT CLOSER TO
THE OCTOBER FIRST ENFORCEMENT
DATE. PROBABLY EVEN MORE
CHALLENGING NOW WITHOUT THE
CORONA VIRUS AS AS THE
CHAIRMANSHIP. SO FAR PROXY
SEVEN POINT SIX MILLION
CALIFORNIANS HAVE A REAL ID THE
TOTAL PARTICIPATION RATE HAS
BEEN LOWER THAN EXPECTED- WE
HAVE SEEN PARTICIPATION RATE
INCREASE- WITH EACH MONTH BUT
GIVEN THE CURRENT YEAR TREND
IT'S UNLIKELY THAT SIXTEEN
MILLION. I WILL REQUEST A D.
BETWEEN NOW AND OCTOBER FIRST.
TO BE CLEAR DB DOESN'T
DISSIPATE OBJECTS MADE TO
CONTINUE AS WE MOVE CLOSER TO
THE REAL ID ENFORCEMENT DATE.
AND WE EXPECT TRAFFIC TO WRAP
UP DURING THE SUMMER AND THE
FALL. THE DEAL WITH INCREASED
TRAFFIC DEPARTMENT ENCOURAGING
RESIDENT TO COME INTO A FIELD
OFFICE NOW RATHER THAN WAITING
FOR THE ENFORCEMENT DATE. AND
WE ARE INCREASING OUR CAPACITY
SO WE CAN PERFORM RELY MORE
RELATED TRANSACTIONS PER MONTH.
DEPARTMENT IS LAUNCHED A MULTI
MULTI CULTURAL STATEWIDE PUBLIC
AWARENESS AND EDUCATION
CAMPAIGN AND ACTUALLY ON THREE
FRONTS. THE FIRST RENT IS
HELPING PEOPLE UNDERSTAND
WHETHER NOT THEY NEED A REAL ID
OR NOT. ARE THERE SOME
CALIFORNIA SINCE WE ARE NOT A
MANDATORY STATE THAT DON'T
REQUIRE ONE OR DON'T WANT ONE-
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THEY'RE
WELL INFORMED. FOR THE ONES
THAT DO- WANT OR NEED A BILL
IDEA ON MAKE SURE IN FACT THE-
WHEN THEY COME INTO THE OFFICE.
AND ALSO WE'RE TRYING TO
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO COME AND
NOW WE WANT TO SMOOTH OUT TO
THE- COMMANDERS NO REASON WE
SHOULD EVEN TO THE LAST MINUTE
AND- WE TEND TO DO HAS. AS
HUMAN AND YOU COME UP LAST
MINUTE WE CAN SMOOTH. OUT HAVE
A GREAT UP FOR THE DAY THEY
SHOULD. I. OUTDOOR POSTERS. A
PRINTOUT OF ALSO BEEN PURCHASED
IN NINE DIFFERENT LANGUAGES- IN
DECEMBER WE'VE PLACED- ADS IN
IN THEATERS IN SAN FRANCISCO
AND LOS ANGELES. I REPRESENTED
ALSO STATED MULTIPLE COMMUNITY
EVENTS AND DEVELOP- LOCAL
COMMUNITY PARTNERSHIPS HI MARCY
IS ALSO AMPLIFIED OUR MESSAGE-
IN PUBLIC RELATIONS THIS IS A-
TEN MILLION DOLLAR EVIDENT
RENTS TO- SEPTEMBER OF THIS
YEAR. THAT CAMPAIGN IS ACTUALLY
QUITE NIMBLE- YOU'VE PROBABLY
SEEN OUR MESSAGES CHANGE OVER
OVER THE PERIOD. WE STARTED THE
CAMPAIGN WITH WELL SHOULD YOU
GET A REAL IDEA SORT OF RELY
THE AWARENESS AND NOW BECOME A
MUCH STRONGER NUDGE TO GET IN
AND GET A REAL ID NOW AND IT
EVEN CORPORATE. BUT HE MET YOU
BY TO SEE YEARS RESOLUTE. THE
KIND OF KEEP IT TOP OF INTERPOL
AND SEASONAL. TODAY THE R. C.
EFFORTS TO. RESULTED IN MORE
THAN SEVEN HUNDRED MILLION
PAID- IMPRESSIONS THAT'S AN
ADVERTISING CHAVEZ EYEBALLS ON
ON THE ON THE VERY SAD. AND IS
ALSO GENERATED MILLIONS OF
TRANSACTIONS ON THE DMV IS
WEBSITE WHICH IS REALLY THE
START OF THE PROCESS WHERE
PEOPLE ARE STARTING TO FILL OUT
THE APPLICATION- SO THESE PAID
EFFORTS HAVE ENHANCED OUR-
EFFORTS TO DRIVE. PROTECTION
XIN WE'VE ALSO. BEEN VERY
HEAVILY AND- HEROES. I AND
GETTING YOU TO DRIVE AWARENESS
AND TRY TO. MAKE WHERE JUST
CONVERTED TO ADD TO ACTION AND
THAT BOTH IN ENGLISH AND
SPANISH AND AS WELL AS OTHER
LANGUAGES. INCLUDING AT. THE
COP SHOWS IN SPANISH BUILDING
IN THE IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
SO I WANT TO THANK YOU CAN FIT.
INTO DISCUSS EVERITT I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT
THE COMMITTEE MAY HAVE. SO I OF
A TICKET THAT. YOU ARE MAKING
SOME PROGRESS IN BRINGING DOWN
THE- THE WAIT TIMES FOR. A VERY
SERVICES AT THE- ALL. BUT MY
UNDER. IS THE NOW. THAT THE
COURT OF PEOPLE WHO ARE WAITING
TWO AND A HALF HOURS OR MORE-
HAS BEEN INCREASING. AT YOU
COULD. OF US THAT ISSUE AND
WHAT DOES YOUR DEPARTMENT IS
INTENDED TO DO ABOUT IT TO BE
GREAT YEAH THE FIRST I WANNA
MINIMIZE AT THE PEOPLE DESERVE
TO THE RIGHT ON THE ON THE
CHART THAT SPURS PUT ON THE
ENERGY LBC REPORT THERE ARE
PEOPLE THAT ARE CROSS THAT
DISTRIBUTION. I THINK TWO
THINGS TO MESSAGES RIGHT THE
OVERALL WAIT TIMES ARE DOWN
DRAMATICALLY FROM WHERE THEY
WERE- DURING THIS UNDER THE
SUMMER OF TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY EIGHTEEN. NOW THEY'RE
DOWN LAST MONTH THEY WERE DOWN
SIX MINUTES FOR APPOINTMENTS
AND AROUND THIRTY MINUTES FOR
PEOPLE WITHOUT UPON ITSELF
REALLY NEAR ALL TIME RECORD
LOWS FOR THOSE NOW OUR
INTENTION IS NOT TO CONTINUE TO
HAVE ABSOLUTE WILL RECORD- WAIT
TIMES OUR INTENTION IS TO NOW
GET MORE. GREAT THAT CAPACITY
WHICH IS ACTUALLY DRIVEN DOWN
THAT WAY TIME AND ACTUALLY FILL
THAT CAPACITY WITH WITH PEOPLE
THAT NEED RELATED TRANSACTIONS
IN THE OFFICE. OUT FOR THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE OUT ON THE
RIGHT OF THE DISTRIBUTION CURVE
THAT THAT YOU MENTIONED THAT
MISTER CHAIR. IS WE ARE WORKING
ON ON DIFFERENT SCHEDULING-
ALGORITHMS TO MAKE SURE THAT
IT. DOES MATCH CUSTOMER DEMAND
TO MAKE IT WE CAN ACT EIGHT
PEOPLE OUT AND EIGHT. HUNDRED
FOR SOMEONE COMES INTO OUR
OFFICE BE. FIVE EIGHT. WE
ACTUALLY. THE BULLS ARE. UNTIL
AT LAST PERSONS OFFICIALLY
SERVED ON WE CLOSE OUR DOORS.
SERVE LAST PERSON SOMETIMES I
CAN REALLY ALONG AT THE TIMES.
BUT WE'RE GONNA LOOK INTO THAT
AND THERE'S AND WHAT WE'RE
TALKING- A LESSON 1% PROBLEM
BUT IT'S IMPORTANT ONE
PRESENTED. THE OPTICS ON A ARE
BAD BUT ALSO WE WANT UNDERSTAND
WHY PEOPLE ARE WAITING. AN HOUR
TO I APPRECIATE YOUR- SAYING
THAT IS AN IMPORT. IMPORTANT
ISSUE. IF YOU'RE THE PERSON WHO
IS IN. AND TILE AND WAITING TWO
AND A HALF HOURS IT'S A BIG
DEAL TO YOU AND. AND TO I THINK
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT- THAT
YOU'RE- TRYING TO ADDRESS IT- I
ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT CUSTOMERS
AND CERTAIN FIELD OFFICES AT
THE YOU KNOW. GEOGRAPHICALLY
ARE EXPERIENCING- WAIT TIMES
HOW. HOW DOES THAT COME TO PASS
WELL I THINK EACH OFFICE IS AN
INDEPENDENT ENTITY THEY HAVE
THEIR OWN STAFFING THEY HAVE
THEY HAVE THEY HAVE THEIR OWN
MANAGEMENT- AS- PEOPLE ON THIS
COMMITTEE ARE ARE AWARE THAT
SOME OPERATE ARE MORE EFFICIENT
AND MORE EFFECTIVE THAN OTHERS.
AND YOU KNOW YOU'VE GIVEN US
FUNDING TO GO OFF AND BUILD A
LAYER OF MANAGEMENT THAT ARE
CALLED AREA MANAGERS IN THIS
AREA MANAGED TO HAVE A MUCH
GREATER TOUCH ON THOSE LITTLE
OFFICES. THERE INITIATIVE IT
WOULD BE ABLE TO WORK CLOSE.
AND SHOULD BRING THEM IN LINE
WITH THE SCHEDULING MECHANISMS
WE WANT THEM TO HAVE MAKE SURE
THEIR RESOURCES ARE ALLOCATED
APPROPRIATELY THROUGHOUT THE
DAY ME. TO GET. THE TOOLS THE
FACT SOURCE IN AND SUPPLY
IMAGINE IT IS A VERY OLD
PROBLEM AND WE'RE TRYING TO USE
NOW HOW THAT SOLUTIONS BEEN
SOLVED OTHER INDUSTRIES
APPLYING THAT SAME TECHNOLOGY
WERE JUST ROLLING THAT OUT AS
WE SPEAK TO CONTINUE TO MAKE IT
SORT MORE SCIENTIFIC TO SAY
OKAY HOW MANY PEOPLE I KNEW
THAT IS SCHEDULED TO MEET OUR
CURRENT AND PATTERN OR
CONVERSELY AS YOU'RE WELL
AWARE. YES WE MORE TECHNOLOGY
MAKING THINGS MORE MOBILE AS
WELL AS OPEN UP OTHER CHANNELS
YOU KNOW WHAT DO WE DO TAKE
SOME OF THOSE HIGH DEMAND ITEMS
OF THE OUT OF THIS INPUT MY BUT
THE BOTTOM PROVIDE IS ONE OF A
PARTNER SUCH AS SUCH AS THE
JUST. NOTHING HOW LONG DO YOU
THINK IT'LL BE BEFORE WE
ACTUALLY. ARE A- TO DISCERN RIZ.
YEAH I THINK WE'RE GOING TO
TALK. A LOT OF URBAN CORE
BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE MOST OF
THE CONGESTION IS IT'S NOT A
100% OF IT. BUT WE'RE BE THAT
PROBABLY BY VERY READY SUMMERS
AS LACKEY BEFORE SUMMER SO
MUCH. THE TARGET IS KIND OF
EARLY JUNE. SO BEFORE SUMMER
OFFICIALLY START. SEARCHING FOR
US OF- FINALLY- I MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THERE'S A
HIGH TURNOVER RATE AND- SOME OF
FIELD OFFICES SO WITH THE-
VACANCY RATE TO. BUY AND HOW
ARE YOU GOING ABOUT FILLING
THOSE VACANCIES- THE VACANCY
RATE AGAIN VERY IS BY OFFICE
BUT IF YOU LOOK BACK TO THE-
INCOME THE AGAIN CRIMINAL
FUNDING THAT THE TWO HUNDRED
FORTY TWO MILLION THE ASSEMBLY
GAVE US WERE SORT AROUND 90% OF
THOSE PEOPLE BEING HIRED.
OFFERS BEING GENERATED THAT
THEY'RE AT VARIOUS STAGES OF
GOING TO TRAIN AND SO ON. BUT
WE DO HAVE SOME AREAS AGAIN IN
IN MORE COMPETITIVE DISTRICTS
THAT OUT OR TURNOVER RATE. AND
WE- DO YOU SEE THE STEPS THAT
IT TAKES IN THE IN THE HIRING
PROCESS ABOUT NINETY DAYS TO GO
FROM YOU OPEN IN A POSITION TO
ACTUALLY YOU KNOW THE FIRST
OFFER BEING GENERATED WE REDUCE
THAT THE THIRTY DAYS WE SPED UP
OR REDUCE THE CYCLE TIME OF
THAT PROCESS SO WE CAN HIRE AN
ON BOARD MORE QUICKLY AND IS
NOT A NUMBER OF OTHER
SIMPLIFICATION THINGS WERE
DOING BUT IT'S GONNA BE A
COMBINATION OF SPEEDING UP
THOSE PROCESSES AND BEING ABLE
TO ANTICIPATE WHAT PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO LEAVE I MEAN WE ARE
NOT. FINANCIALLY COMPETITIVE-
IN SOME AND SOME MARKETS AND AT
THE CAN AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TEAMS DISTRICT AND YOU CAN
IMAGINE IF YOU'RE IN SAN
FRANCISCO OF BEING THE IN THE
EMPLOYEE AND BEING COMPENSATED
AT A COMPETITIVE MAY WITH WITH
UP THERE HELLO OF TURN PART MAY
IF YOU'RE IN PERSON OTHER PLACE.
THAT THAT'S EACH OF. WE HAVE
MAKE SURE. THAT OUR- FOR. SOME
OF THE THOSE A JUST GONNA HELP
THE PEOPLE TO BE HE THE BE
ENTERED IN THE VALUE OF SIR AND
YOU SEE THAT WERE WILL AND ABLE
TO CHANGE I THINK THAT'S A LAW
OF THINGS THAT ARE MANAGEMENT
HE HAS BEEN BROUGHT IN TO DO AN
WERE ACTIVE WORKING ON THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN TANGO AND I FOR
TAKING AN ACTIVE INTEREST IN
THE ISSUE UGH UGH MAKING SURE
OUR SITE IS LOOKING TO. SARD
RESULT OF LOWERING THOSE WAIT
TIMES SO. AND I SUSPECT GERMAN
TING AT SOME QUESTIONS. AS
CHAIR YES. REALLY APPRECIATE-
YOUR EFFORTS- JUST JUST A
COUPLE QUESTIONS- I THINK IT'S
GREAT THE- ADVERTISING HAS
DEFINITELY GONE UP I THINK IT'S
MUCH MORE VISIBLE. I SEE IT
QUITE OFTEN ON SOCIAL MEDIA
WHICH IS WHERE I. PRIMARILY
INTERFACE WITH IT- I'VE I THINK
IT'S GREAT THAT YOU'VE DONE
ENGLISH AS WELL AS SPANISH I
JUST WANT TO. UNDERSTAND WHAT
YOUR PLANS WERE FOR OTHER
LANGUAGES ESPECIALLY THE
DIFFERENT ASIAN LANGUAGES. YEAH
THERE'S MATERIALS AVAILABLE
TODAY AND ADVERTISING CAMPAIGNS
THAT ARE TIED TO BOTH CANTONESE
WELL AS MATTER DESERVE TO ASIAN
LANGUAGES. ANDERSON LANGUAGE
WELL IT. AND I'M NOT THAT
YOU'RE DOING A RADIO OR TV FOR
WHATEVER REASON WE ARE CALLING
A TWO DIFFERENT THINGS AND I'M
ASSUMING THEY'RE THEY'RE
THEY'RE USING LIKE DIFFERENTLY
BUT BACK BACK TO YOUR BROADER
BROADER PERSPECTIVE AND WE ARE
CERTAINLY ADVERTISED IN OTHER
LANGUAGES AS WELL TO REACHING
OUT TO THE MONKEY HE TO THE
VIETNAMESE COMMUNITY TO
COMMUNITY JUST TO NAME A FEW SO
I THINK YOU'LL SEE THAT WE HAVE
A DISTRIBUTION ACROSS MANY MANY
LIKE WE TRY TO REACH THE
COMMUNITIES WHERE THEY ARE. AND
TRYING TO YOU KNOW IN COMMUNITY
TAKE HIS ACTION WITH EVERYONE
ELSE. OKAY BUT I GUESS IT'S NOT
THE BEST. MORE SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS WHAT. ADVERTISING DO
YOU PLAN TO DO IN ASIAN
LANGUAGES AND IN WHAT MEDIUMS.
WELL I DON'T HAVE THAT DETAIL
WITH ME BUT I'D BE HAPPY TO.
GET YOU THAT INFORMATION OFF
LINE I KNOW I HAVE IT BUT I
JUST DON'T HAVE IT HERE. I
THINK IT'S- VERY CRITICAL
BECAUSE IT'S- PART OF OUR STAY.
AND IT TOOK ME THAT CAN BE
EASILY REACHED IF YOU
COMMUNICATE TO THEM AND- THEY
ARE WE TO WHERE THEY ARE AND
THEY'RE WHERE THEY GET MOST
INFORMATION IS THROUGH ETHNIC
MEDIA. SO I MEAN IT'S AN AND
THEN THE NICE THING IS IT'S
MUCH CHEAPER THAN. TRADITIONAL
MAINSTREAM MEDIA SO YOU'RE
ACTUALLY GETTING READY AT. A
LOT MORE BANG FOR YOUR BUCK IF
YOU ACTUALLY- ARE TARGETING IN.
VARIOUS AREAS IN THOSE IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES AND WE ARE STILL
LOOKING FOR TO TAKE YOU UP ON
YOUR GENEROUS OFFER OF MEETING
WITH US GET IT'S A PRESS
ATTENTION. IN IN NATIVE
LANGUAGE GET IT IS INTO THIS
COMMUNITY STILL. ANOTHER WE CAN
PULL THAT IN SORT OF SLIPPED A
LITTLE BIT. OVER SILICON BUT
WHEN YOU'RE BACK IN YOUR
DISTRICT YEAH I THINK. THIS IS
A MAJOR ISSUE FOR ME AND ALL MY
COLLEAGUES THAT WE WILL ALL BE.
HAPPY TO ASSIST. GETTING ON THE-
ON THIS EFFORT. FOR COMMUNITIES.
SO IN THAT. AVERAGE THE RAPPER
BUT THE- CAMPAIGN. HAVE YOU
SEEN A COME. UP IN REAL ID
APPLICATIONS TO GO ALONG WITH
THAT. WELL WE- APPLICATIONS ARE
KIND OF TRICKY TO THE ANSWER IS
REALLY YES SO WE'RE DRIVING
PEOPLE TO. MINE FOREMAN THAT
HAS GONE UP SUBSTANTIALLY SO
NOW WE'RE SEEN SOMEWHERE ON A
WEEKLY BASIS APPROACHING FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE THAT.
COME IF YOU WILL TO THE TOP OF
THE APPLICATION. BOB TRY TO DO
NOW IF THIS WERE A WEB. STORE
THAT WE WERE AMAZON HERE WE
WILL TRY TO GET PEOPLE ON THE
SITE WE GET THEM TO PUT UP IN
THE SHOPPING CART WE GET TO THE
CHECKOUT SO RIGHT NOW WE'RE
GETTING THEM ON THE SITE. WHAT
WE HAVE SOME ACTIVE MEASURES
THAT ARE JUST BE NOW. TRYING TO
TESTING THE HYPOTHESIS OF THIS
CONCEPT OF A SAME DAY
APPOINTMENTS OF THE UNITED
SPOKEN ABOUT. RIGHT PUT SAID-
URGENCY AND SAY LOOK YOU GOT TO
SCARCITY EVENT YOU CAN HAVE A
SAME DAY APPOINTMENT. IF YOU
FILL OUT THE APPLICATION- SO
ESSENTIALLY. GET INTO THE
SHOPPING CART. AND THEIR
CARROT. FOR COMPLETING THE
APPLICATION IS THE SAME DAY
UPON WHICH LET'S CALL IT FOR
THE NEXT COUPLE OF DAYS TRYING
TO DRIVE PEOPLE. TO COMPLETE
THE PROCESS. AND NOT PUSH THEM
OUT TO THE RIGHT WHICH ARE KERN
EMPLOYMENT STRATEGY. DOES SO
THIS IS A WAY TO ACTUALLY. GET
THEM TO. EXECUTE FULLY EXECUTED
IN RECEIPT. CLOSE TO FOUR
THOUSAND A WEEK. IF WE CAN
IMPROVE THE YIELD ON A FOUR
THOUSAND A WEEK. THAT THAT SHE
ACTUALLY. DOES GET TOWARD AT
SIX. BILLION AND WE CAN. DEAL
BY AGAIN WE'RE GOING TO TRY. A
BUNCH OF SORT OF SOCIAL TAX. TO
SEE WE CAN ACT. GET THEIR
LANGUAGE THERE ARE SCARCELY.
RIGHT TIME FRAME. TO GET PEOPLE
TO COME. THE PROCESS TO GET IT
INTO THE OFFICE. AND TO WERE
RUNNING THROUGH THOSE EXERCISES
NOW AND WE'RE MERE WE'RE TYING
THAT TO THIS. DAY APPOINT ICON.
THE CALL THE- THAT REALLY THAT
JUST LAUNCHED A FEW WEEKS AGO
OUT OF PROOF OF CONCEPT NOW TEN
TWENTY THREE OFFICES AS OF
MONDAY. THAT'S CRAZY YOU
DROUGHT FOUR THOUSAND A WEEK
WHERE WERE YOU BEFORE THE
ADVERTISING CAMPAIGN STARRED.
YOU NOT HAVE TO GO BACK IN I'M
NOT SURE HOW WE ARE MEASURING
THAT BEFORE SO I CAN FOLLOW UP
ON WITH THAT. SUCH A HEAVY. NOT
TO BE GREAT BECAUSE THE BECAUSE
IT JUST BEGIN TO UNDERSTAND.
YOU SPEND ALL THIS MONEY WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT IT'S ACTUALLY
WORKING. YEAH AND SOME OF THAT
THAT JUST TO BE PERFECTLY CLEAR
I THINK SOME OF THAT WAS. TIED
TO THIS MICROSITE WHICH IS WHAT
WE ROUTE ALL THE TRAFFIC.
GOOGLE ANALYTICS WRAPPING. I
DON'T THINK THAT EXIST. BEFORE
THAT OR MUCH BEFORE THIS. THING
ABOUT WILL BE HAPPY TO SHARE
WITH AND WHATEVER DO. WE HAVE.
LOOK UP LIKE I SAID. THANK YOU.
IF YOU. HAVE A- OF THAT FOR.
WEEK WHEN YOU'RE CAMPAIGN
STARTED GOING. YOU HAVE A SENSE
OF. YES THAT FIRST WEEK WHERE
YOU ARE. YOU KNOW. GIVES YOU
SOME. BASELINE OF EFFORT OF
WHERE YOU. WHAT ONE POINT IN
THE REPORT MENTIONED THAT WE
HAVEN'T REALLY SEEN A KIOSK
USAGE CO OP AND YOU HAVE A
HYPOTHESIS AS TO WHY THAT WAS
SURE I THINK WO THINGS ONE IS
THAT ON AVERAGE YOU KNOW MORE
MORE KIOSK OUT THREE HUNDRED
AND FORTY S. OKAY US NOW SO THE
TOTAL USAGE IS RELATIVELY FLAT
ACROSS MORE DEVICES SO THE MORE
CONVENIENT BUT WOULD EXPECT HIM
TO UP IN IN USE IT AT THE SAME
TIME GIVEN WE ARE PRESENTLY.
WITH THE KIA PAYING YOUR MONEY.
YOUR IS ACTION OR TO SAVE WHERE
GOT YOUR SUPERMARKET SO ENDED
WE COMMUNICATED THIS TO OUR OUR
GAS SUPPLIER THAT. MOST PEOPLE
WOULD PREFER TO DO THE
TRANSACTION ON A MOBILE DEVICE
ON THE COMPUTER AT HOME
SOMEWHERE IN TRANSIT WHERE THEY
MIGHT BE- AS OPPOSED TO GOING
TO KIA SO THIS IS JUST GO TO
COMPETING STRATEGY FOR THE SAME
EYEBALLS AND SELL. CATION OVER
A LONGER I WASN'T EXPECTED TO
HAPPEN THIS. IS TO ACTUALLY
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
TRANSACTIONS THAT HAPPEN THE
KIA CAPITAL TO GET BECAUSE
WE'VE- GIVEN THEM A MORE
CONVENIENT SOLUTION. GOT AND
THAT THAT WAS THAT'S MY
QUESTION SO PERFECT. SO YOU SEE
MAYBE YOUR RAMP DOWN FROM THE
KIOSK MAY BE THE KEY ALSO JUST
ONLY BE IN THE MOST. REMOTE
PARTS OF THE STATE WHERE YOU
YOU KNOW WOULD YOU WOULD YOU
JUST DON'T HAVE. WE HAVE
OFFICES WHICH JUST AREN'T VERY
TO EACH OTHER. AND ARE WE
REALLY GONNA WRAP UP THE ONLINE
PRESENCE STILL YES AT THE-
WOULD BE. THAT YES FOR US ARE
WE PAY ONLY ON A PERCH. BASIS
OF THE STATE IS REALLY NO RISK
IN HAVING INFINITE CHAOS OUT
THERE THE VENDOR AS BUT- IS A
BILL TO IN. THE KEEP CAN DO
EIGHT. YOUR STE. REAL TIME INC.
AS IT SEEMS LIKE LOTS OF PEOPLE
ARE YOU'LL KIOSK TO SERVE A
VITAL ROLE IN THE COMMUNITY. SO
SOME OF THE MOST- CROWDED
OFFICERS ONE OF THE- BIGGEST
CHALLENGE THAT WE HEARD WERE
FRANKLY JUST EVEN A LACK OF
SPACE EVEN AS YOU HAD. PEOPLE
COME IN- IT WASN'T YOU KNOW WE
COULD HIRE TWENTY MORE STOUT
THAT THEIR WORK. WINDOWS
COMPUTER SIXERS HOW ARE YOU.
GRAPPLING WITH THAT POTENTIAL
ISSUE YES SIR OTHERS COMPLETED
ONE IS STILL WORSE WE ARE WE
ARE AGAIN AGGRESSIVELY MOVING
NON URGENT DMV FOCUS
TRANSACTIONS OUT OF THEOFFICE
WE JUST RE LAUNCHED OUR
AUTHENTICATION APPROACH I'M
SURE YOU'VE USED OUR OUR
WEBSITE IN BEFORE TO
AUTHENTICATE YOU NEEDED TO A
LOT OF INFORMATION. AND IT WAS
THE STATE WAS NOT MODERN BUT WE
JUST RELAX ABOUT WEEKS AGO
RETURNING TO RELAUNCH A SERIES
OF APPLICATIONS SO WE THINK
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE SOME
CLIENTS ARE THE UP THERE ARE
SEATED KLEIN. TRANSACTION
OFFICE BUT IT'S STILL TOO SOON
TO TELL AS WERE RE LAUNCHING
THOSE APPLICATIONS. IN THE
OPPOSITE SELF I ARE KEEP
TRAGEDY THERE IS WE'RE REASON
TEXT MESSAGING SO WHERE TO MAKE
SURE THE SITE ARE. VERY CAN
CONSIST SO WHEN YOU COME INTO
THE WE SHOULD SAY OKAY WE
YOU'RE WHERE YOU ARE IN LINE
WE'RE GONNA WE'RE GONNA ASK YOU
FOR YOUR MOBILE NUMBER RENTABLE
GETTING READY ACTUALLY WHEN
YOU'RE A THIN LINE. WE HAVE THE
NEXT EVOLUTION OF THAT'S SHE
COMING IN ABOUT THIRD. MINUTES
FORTY IS WHAT WILL BE WILL BE
FROM OUR AMERICAN THAT THAT'LL
BE SHOULD YOU DO WITH YELP
IT'LL SHOW WE YOU ARE IN LINE
SEALED HOW MUCH TIME YOU. TO DO
OF ERRANDS WHATEVER YOU MIGHT
DO SO THAT WE WON'T BE CROWDING
THE LOBBY SO I THINK THOSE
COUPLE OF DROUGHT IS HARD B.
THE- YOU CAN. WERE IN. GRADE AT
ALL WE- WALL AROUND I MEAN THIS
ISN'T. WE HAVE TO YOU THE
SPACE. AS FISHING THE WE CAN
AND ANOTHER ANOTHER STRETCH OF
A TO A- ADD TO THAT. HILL AS
YOU'VE SEEN SOME OF OUR- THAT
WE STARTED WITH MAKE. DOING A
WHAT'S CALLED A- TO MAPPING.
EVER STEP OF THE- YOU KNOW THE
STOCK WATCH YOU CAN PICTURE THE-
YEAH THEY MEASURE THAT PROCESS
THAT FOR REAL IDEA TWENTY. WE
ARE NOW TEN MINUTES SCRIPT SO
THAT'S ANOTHER WAY WE'RE GONNA
BE GETTING. IT HERE THERE BROWN
BECAUSE- YOU REDUCE EIGHTEEN
IT'S BECAUSE- WHAT WE- SAW THE
PROCESS. WERE ON IT I MEAN WE
ACTUALLY DID. PROCESS AND HOW
WE DID BUSINESS PROCESS RE.
HARBOR HARBOR USE THAT IN YOUR
VOCABULARY. BUT WE AGGRESSIVE
BEAT UP A TARGET WILL WHY TO
TAKING TWENTY MINUTES I HAVE
SAT THROUGH A NUMBER THE HAS
ACTED IN A FEW. OF THEM WE CAN.
THAT FIRST. ARE IN. YOUR THE
PAPERS. THERE'S NO VALUE IN
THAT TRADE. WHAT'S SEE LOOK AT
THE STEP FIND OUT WHY WE'RE
DOING THE AND THEN WE WILL.
ACROSS YA AND SOME DOES THE
SAME THING WE JUST. IT SO IT
WOULD WE JUST PULL THAT PER.
THE PART. WENT DOWN TO ITS
ESSENCE AS YOU WOULD DO IF I.
THAT WE SAID WHAT ARE THE- AT A
TO ASK WHAT ARE THE NON. ADDED
WE'VE A WAY TO ELIMINATE ALL
THE NON VALUE ADDED TASK AND
THAT GETS YOU TO TEN MINUTES.
YEAH I THINK IT BE WOULD IT BE
HELPFUL. FOR YOU TO JUST.
COMMUNICATE WITH ALL I MEAN ALL
OF US WE SEND OUT. EMAILS EVERY
WEEK OR TWO WEEKS ON A FRIDAY
OF ISSUES I KNOW THAT. I'M NOT.
AN INMATE WAS. FROM BEING. SO
IT WOULD BE HELPFUL BECAUSE
WE'RE TELLING OF TO GO IN. FOR
REAL ID. BUT YOU SHOULD ALSO
TELL US. THEY SHOULD GO IN FOR.
GRACE PART OF THAT CAN BE.
ISSUE BE HEY. IF YOU WANTED. IT
ON THESE TWENTY THINGS. GO THE
KIOSK OR GO ONLINE RIGHT DON'T
DO NOT. DON'T GO AWAY. AND I
THINK THAT WOULD BE I THINK
HELP FOLKS I THINK WE'VE GOT
INTO THIS HABIT OF GO GO IN GO
AND GO IN AND GET YOUR ID. AND
OBVIOUSLY WE DON'T. TELL THEM
WHAT TO NOT GOING FOR THEY JUST
MAY JUST OUT OF HABIT JUST. WE
WILL ACTUALLY TAKE INTERNET TO
GIVE YOU THAT IF YOU WILL THE
PRESS KIT ABOUT WHAT WHAT TO
SAY WHEN JUST WHEN IT'S THE LAW
GOOD LUCK HELP PAN. AND GRAY I
THINK A LOT THE LAST FOUR. WAS
REALLY GOT ROUTE. TIMES I KNOW
THAT. YOU TEND TO YOU. THIS OF
AVERAGE WAIT TIMES WHICH I
DON'T. ALWAYS FIND
EXTRAORDINARILY HELPFUL GIVE A
SENSE OF WHAT THE MEDIAN WAIT
TIME THIS YOU KNOW I DON'T I
DON'T HAVE THAT HANDY BUT I'D
BE HAPPY TO CIRCLE BACK I
UNDERSTAND TWO DIFFERENT WAYS
TO LOOK AT THE NUMBERS YOU KNOW
WHAT IS THAT MID POINT IS WHAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT FOR JUST
THE OVERALL AVERAGE AVERAGE
JUST CAN'T BE- THIS WILL BE
DECEIVING BUT AT THE SAME TIME
YOU KNOW YOU'RE YOU'RE LOOKING
AT A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T WANNA.
IT I AM NOT. MEETING WITH. YOU
BETTER KNOW. JUST BECAUSE- WE
KNOW THAT SOME. YOU KNOW WE
HAVE A LOT. OFFICES THERE ARE
IN MORE REMOTE LOCATIONS. MIGHT
MY GUESS IS THEY DON'T HAVE AS
MUCH. WAIT TIMES AND WE'RE NOT
GONNA. WE'RE NOT GONNA GET RID
OF THESE OFFICES. BECAUSE THEY-
THEY SERVE. YOU KNOW PARTS OF
THE STATE THAT NEED THAT
SERVICE. BUT MY SENSE IS
THEY'RE NOT. GETTING NEARLY THE
AMOUNT OF TRAFFIC AND- THEN
DIDN'T SAY IN MY- IN MY-
PARTICULAR CITY OR MY
PARTICULAR DISTRICTS I THINK
IT'S JUST IT'S JUST HELPFUL TO.
BUT AND IF DIFFERENTIATE. GREAT
OKAY BUT DID NOT APPRECIATE THE
THANK YOU CHAIR DID I HEAR YOU
SAY EARLIER THAT WITH RESPECT
TO REAL IDEA THAT YOU ACTUALLY
ONLINE CAN DO THIS IN YOUR
BUNNY SLIPPERS- YES SIR. WE'LL
GET IS NOT RECALL THAT A
REFERENCE TO MR TANG MYSELF. I
HAVE NO KNOWLEDG OF FOOTWEAR
BUT I DON'T BELIEVE THE H. AS
AS A REQUIREMENT OF FOOTWEAR SO.
TING AND THEN THEM IS RIVAS AS
QUEST I JUST WANNA QUESTIONS TO
THE TO THE BUDGET PROPOSAL THIS
YEAR IS FOR- A TWO HUNDRED
MILLION- AT NINETEEN ALMOST TWO
THOUSAND POSITIONS IS THAT IN
ADDITION. TO THE TWO FORTY TWO
TWO THOUSAND POSITIONS THAT WE-
DID LAST YEAR I'M GONNA TO
MISTER LEE SCOTT FIFTH. SUPPORT
FOR CURRENT HEARD FOR NINETEEN
TWENTY TO GET THE ADDITIONAL.
NINETEEN HARPER. AND THEN IN-
FOR. BUT IT WAS FOR ROUGHLY
ABOUT A HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
OUT OF THE TWO AND THREE FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR TOLD BUDGET I
BECAUSE IT WAS REAL IDEA TO BUY
STUFF FOR OPERATIONAL PREVENTS
THAT AND NOT NUMBER DOES
SLIGHTLY DIPPED IN BUDGET- TO
ROUGHLY A HUNDRED AND FORTY
FOUR NINE GOT IT AND THEN AND
WHAT. OF THOSE HOW MANY THERE'S
A TEMPORARY POSITIONS VERSUS
FULL TIME GET GO KNOWING THAT
THIS REAL ID IS SORT OF YOU
KNOW FIGURE THIS YEAR BUT
OBVIOUSLY WE WOULD HOPE THAT
WOULD TELL OFF IN THE COMING
YEARS RIGHT AT THE MOTHER RIGHT
NOW IT IS ONLY FOR TWO YEAR
LIMITED TERM WE JUST HAVE I
CAN'T TYPE IS THE SENSE OF AND
THAT WILL BE FREE OF OPERATING.
A GO FOR BUT THE IS THAT
RELATIONSHIP KIND OF OFF UP AND
THAT'S TO YOUR LIVE FOR THAT TO
THE POSITIONS OR JUST A PORTION
OF THAT I'M I'M SORRY IT'S JUST
IT TO THE RIGHT YET MATT SEATED
APARTMENT FINANCE- THE PROPOSAL
WAS FOR- ROUGHLY. TWO THOUSAND.
AND THEN THE PROPOSAL ONE
HUNDRED AND- EIGHTY EIGHT. I'M
LONG GONE. HOWEVER AT THE LET.
ON TWO YEARS FUNDING. FOR THANK
YOU. ASSEMBLYMEMBER AVIS THANKS
FOR BEING PATIENT NO THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION- SO I AM I
REPRESENT THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY- PROCLAIM A WHERE YOU
JUST OPENED A DRIVER'S LICENSE
CENTER RECENTLY AND THEY KNOW
YOU WERE THERE FOR THE GRAND
OPENING- I'VE HEARD GREAT
FEEDBACK FROM CONSTITUENTS ON-
THEIR EXPERIENCE THERE THERE'S
THIS IS AN APPOINTMENT FACILITY
ACCEPT APPOINTMENTS RIGHT THE
CENTER. AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
GOING THAT'S WHAT I PLAN TO GET
MY REAL ID WHICH I STILL
HAVEN'T EIGHTEEN I DON'T HAVE
BUNNY SLIPPERS BUT I WILL ASK I
DON'T BUT I WILL HOLD MAYBE
I'LL GET SOME IN TO FILL OUT I
PARTED. I BUT HEARD IT YOU KNOW
YOU JUST WALK IN AND- YOU KNOW
IT'S A GREAT EXPERIENCE ARE
THERE PLANS- FOR ESPECIALLY
MAYBE IN THE SUMMER MONTHS TO
OPEN UP TEMPORARY. OFFICES FOR
REAL ID PROCESS SEEN THAT MAYBE
LIKE LIKE THIS THAT DON'T
REQUIRE APPOINTMENTS. YEAH I
THINK- WERE PLANNING A COUPLE
OF STEPS ONE STEP IS YOU
CONTINUING TO TEST YOUR RELY
THE SATURDAYS AS YOU MIGHT HAVE
CAUGHT IN SOME OF OUR PRESS
RELEASES WE'RE DOING A NUMBER
REAL ID SATURDAYS IN TARGETED
DISTRICTS. AND THE PLAN IS ALSO
EVEN TO LOOK AT SOME OF OUR
OFFICES TODAY THAT ARE OPEN ON
SATURDAYS AND MAYBE EVEN TEST
THEM TO FIND OUT IF THEY COULD
BE DEDICATED TO REALIZE THE
WHICH IS GOING TO INCREASE OUR
CAPACITY FOR THOSE PERIODS. AND
THE REASON WE THINK IT'S OKAY
TO DO THAT IS THAT AS I
MENTIONED WE HAVE WELL BODIES
ARE NOT REQUIRED BUT USING WEB
SERVICES USING MOBILE USING
VARIOUS OTHER APPLICATIONS WE
CREATED A MECHANISM ALONG WITH
KIOSKS TO DO ALMOST EVERYTHING
ELSE AND BY BY SUMMER WE EXPECT
TO BE AT A POINT WHERE. YOU
DON'T. BELIEVE YES 7580% OF
THINGS THAT YOU NEED I MEAN FOR
THE SAFER VEHICLE REGISTRATION
SERVICE CAN BE DONE BY
ALTERNATE MEANS STRONGLY URGE
PEOPLE TO USE US SO WE ARE
GONNA TEST A NUMBER OF THINGS
AND WE CONTINUE TO LOOK AT. TO
OUT. I WOULD. THINK A NUMBER OF.
CALLING DMV T. THEIR THEIR
CENTER A VERY. TO POP UP TO BE
DOING THIS PER. FOR WE'RE GONNA
BE DO SOME TO IN ACTS. IN YOUR-
IT'S IN THE BROADER BASIN. WITH
LA ACTS A PARTICULAR TO
ACTUALLY GO TO A TRUE MOBILE
SERVICE. THE THINK ABOUT WHAT
WE DO WITH DISASTER RECOVERY
TODAY'S. VERY HAPPY WITH HIM TO
GO OUT THE FEEL WITH A BUNCH OF
EQUIPMENT WE'VE ACTUALLY. BEEN
ABLE TO NOW. PROTOTYPE THAT
DOWN TO TABLETS OR STILL IN
PROTOTYPE PHASE WE CAN GET THAT
ON A COUPLE OF TABLETS YOU CAN
IMAGINE. THAT WE COULD GO TO
THE AIRPORT TO THE
INTERNATIONAL TROUBLES I SPOKE
WITH THE BURBANK AIRPORT
ADMINISTRATOR YESTERDAY- AND
WE'RE GONNA WE'RE GONNA TEST
AND FIND OUT IF. IF PEOPLE ARE
WILLING TO DO BUSINESS OUT THIS
WILL GIVE US A WAY TO EXPAND.
AND BE MUCH MORE AGILE ABOUT
WHERE WE GO NOW I DELETED WITH
I THINK ABOUT GOING TO AN
EVENT. ROSE GOT. OF IT. TIME IS
OFF RIGHT. BUT WERE STILL.
EXPLORING SO WE- WHEN IT'S SAFE
TO GO TO AN EVENT TO BE ABLE TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THAT. BY BE
MEASURABLE SO I THINK THE
INTENT IS TO CONTINUE TO
BROADEN THAT BASE TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE THAT OUT REACH CAMPAIGN.
AND BE MORE EFFECTIVE THEY
SHOULD THE WE DID. A WHICH IS
HAD A CAR WITH THE Q. R. CODE
TELLING PEOPLE TO GET THE REAL.
THE WE WANT TO SELL YOUR TO THE
REALITY. I MEAN. WE COLLECT
YOUR YOUR FINGERPRINT. LET ME.
IN ANY. PAYMENT TO HAPPEN. AND
I'LL BE SURE TO GET YOU IN THE
PROCESS SO THAT THE- FIELD.
OFFICE PORTION. THE EXPERIENCE
IS DONE. SO NOW YOU HAVE TO DO
IS. PUT ON THE BUNNY SLIPPERS
UPLOAD YOUR DOCUMENTS FILL. THE
CAJUN.AND MATCH THOSE TO MATCH
AND. OKAY SO. GREAT YES. GREAT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR THE PRESENTATION AND-
I'D BE A HARD PRESSED NOT TO
DRAW A COMPARISON TO THE ISSUES
YOU'RE ADDRESSING AT DMV- AND
THE- INNOVATIVE APPROACH YOUR A
TAKING TO THEM- TECH TO
ADDRESSING THE PROBLEMS THAT
HAVE ARISEN- TO. HAPPEN TO IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY JUST LAST.
RING SYSTEM. X. SOME THE
APPROACHES THE YOUR USING ARE
APPLICABLE IN THAT SETTING AND
I HOPE SOMEBODY'S LISTING OF
WHO MIGHT WANT TO CALL YOUR
OFFICE TO JUST GET SOME
FEEDBACK ON HOW WE ADDRESS A-
OF MAKING THE TRANSITION TO A
NEW VOTING SYSTEM- WORK BETTER
MORE EFFICIENTLY. THE BREAK UP
I WILL TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THIS AT THE END OF THE- A DMV-
ISSUES WILL MOVE ON NOW TO
ISSUE FIVE MOTOR VOTER
RESOURCES WERE HOLDING ALL
ITEMS OPEN. OKAY SO THIS A
QUICK SUMMARY THAT ARE GOING TO
ITEM FIVE SO THIS IS THE BC
PORTION THE PART AS TEN BUDGET
CHANGE REQUEST BOB. BEFORE YOU
TODAY THE FIRST POSSIBLE BE
MOTOR VOTER RESOURCES AND LATER
WE'LL DISCUSS NINE PROPOSES
THAT IT TO SWING SPACE
RELOCATION CAPITAL OUTLAY FOR
OUR FIELD OFFICE PROJECTS IN
TOTAL TV'S REQUESTING SIXTIES
MILLION PER BUDGET YEAR MAY
TWENTY ONE. NINE POINT SIX FROM
THE NBA MOTOR VEHICLE ACCOUNT-
FIFTY MILLION FROM PUBLIC
BUILDINGS CONSTRUCTION FUN AND
FOUR MILLION THE CHEN. ISSUE
I'VE VOTER READ. DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION FROM THE GENERAL FUND
OF ADDITIONAL THIRTY EIGHT-
ADDITIONAL THIRTY RESOURCES.
ONGOING AND SIX POINT FOUR
MILLION FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. FISCAL YEAR AND FOUR POINT
NINE MILLION IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO AND FOUR POINT ONE
MILLION IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE. AN ONGOING FOR THE
CONTINUED IN THE NATION OF THE
MOTOR VOTER PROGRAM. WE'RE ALSO
QUESTION ONE TIME FUNDING OF
900-100-0420 TWENTY ONE FOR
CONTINUED INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY VENDOR SUPPORT AND
KNOWLEDGE TRANSFER. IT IS
ADDRESSING THE E. NY ASSESSMENT
ON MOTOR VOTER THEIR
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WERE
PUBLISHED BACK IN AUGUST OF.
NINETEEN DEPARTMENT ESTABLISHED.
ROSS IS TO ENSURE THE TIME
RELEASE OF SOS RECORD IN FACT
YEAH BUT YOU KNOW WE JUST
FINISHED THE FIRST THE PRIMARY
CYCLE AND- WE ACTUALLY WERE
MEETING ALL OF THE FEDERAL
STANDARD IN STATE STANDARDS.
AND WE ACTUALLY EXCEEDED THOSE
AND AN AFFRONT TO THE PROPER IS
QUITE STABLE. SO IN ADDITION WE
HAVE COURSE COMPLIANCE WE HAVE
A NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT ARE
THAT ARE PART OF THIS POOL OF
RESOURCES AND HE'S BEEN
ASSIGNED TO THE PROGRAM WANT TO
MAKE SURE WE- HAVE IT FUNCTION
VERY HIGH LEVEL. IT'S ALSO
IMPLEMENTED PROCESS
IMPROVEMENTS MOTOBLUR WORKFLOW.
I MENTION A MOMENT AGO. THE OF
CHANGE OF ADDRESS SKINNY TIME
AS WELL AS STREAMLINING-
PROCESS THE THAT THE DL AND ID
RENEWAL SO THOSE ARE ALL THINGS
THAT IMPROVE THE CYCLE TIME AND
THE- EFFICACY OF THE PROGRAM
ITSELF. THE TV NETWORKS OF
FORMED WORK GROUPS TO ADDRESS
ONGOING VOTER REGISTRATION-
RECORD COLLECTION PROCESSING
AND DELIVERY ACTIVITIES. THE
PREVIOUS TWO FUNDING- ONGOING
FUNNY- LEVEL REQUESTED IN.
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY SEVENTEEN
AND EIGHTEEN- MOTOR VOTER B. C.
B. OF TWELVE POSITIONS AND
THREE POINT ONE MILLION IS NOT
SUBMIT SUFFICIENT TO.
ADMINISTER THE- A MINISTER AND
PROCESS THE WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED
WITH THE MOTOR VOTER. PROGRAM A
BUDGET AUGMENTATION FROM THE
GENERAL FUND IS NEEDED TO
COMPLY. TO COMPLETE THE
DEVELOPMENT OF AND MAINTAIN THE
MINISTRATION OF. THE MOTOR
VOTER PART WITHOUT COURTNEY
WITHOUT CONTINUED TO ADVERSELY
AFFECT. THE APARTMENTS
REGISTRATION AND LICENSING
OPERATION QUOTE ENDANGER
COMPLIANCE IN. FIVE DAY IN A-
TIME IS OF DOT. TO THE SECTOR
OF STATE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ALEJO SAID THANK YOU WE SO WE
AGREE WITH THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION THAT YOU MAY
WANT TO GET THAT ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION FROM THE DEPARTMENT
ON THE OUTCOMES OF THE PROGRAM
I THE PROCESS EFFICIENCIES THAT
THEY HAVE IMPLEMENTED I'M AS
WELL AS THE WORKLOAD THAT
ROUNDING VOTER REGISTRATION
THAT AND IT SEEMS THAT THERE
THAT THEY HAVE MET YOU KNOW THE
FEDERAL AND STATE FIREMEN'S
FIVE. CONCERNING THE
REGISTRATION DEADLINE BUT AT TO
ME YEAH TO GET THAT THIS
INFORMATION MAY ALLOW THE LESS
CARE DETERMINE THE PURPOSE
STOPPING LEVEL- I'D GIVEN AT
THE NET OF POSITIONS THAT ARE
REQUESTED ARE FEWER THAN ONE
SOUTH- HAVE BEEN ASLEEP SUPPORT
PROGRAM. THANK YOU BERMAN
FINANCE NO COMMENT. LET'S MOVE
ON TO ISSUE SIX WE WOULD LIKE
TO ADD A COMMENT ON THE LA ALL
COMMENTS OF THAT'S OKAY SURE-
SO. WHAT DO YOU HAVE YOU HAS
CURRENTLY DONE AS WE KIND OF
REVISED LIKE OUR PLATFORM SO IN
THE BEGINNING- WINTERED ABOUT
JUST ONE FOR COMING AND PEOPLE
HAVE TO UPDATE IT TO THE DMV
SYSTEM AN UPDATED AND TO THE
SECRETARY OF STATE PORTAL. WE
KIND OF ELIMINATE THAT STEP TO
HAVE IT JUST ONE STEP NOW WHERE
WE CAN ENTERED AT ONCE AND THE
TIRE DATEABLE CAPTURE IT- WE'VE
ALSO KIND OF REVISED ARE
SORTING SO AS THE BILL COMES IN
WE ARE TAKING OUT. THAT PAPER
THAT NEEDS TO MOTOR VOTER
IMPROPER TYPE IT ON THE- AND-
AS WELL AS- WE WILL BE DOING.
MORE MONITORING. SO THAT WE CAN
KIND OF TRACK IT REAL TIME TO
SEE WHAT IT IS THAT THE SYSTEM.
AS WELL AS HAVING A REPORTING
TOOLS. TO KIND OF A LOOK BACK
TO SEE HOW SUCCESSFUL WE'VE
BEEN. AS WELL DOING SOME
TRAINING WITH THEN- DEPARTMENT.
OF ANYBODY WHO. TOUCHES MOTOR
VOTER. AND WITH THAT I JUST
WANTED TO. KIND OF SAY THAT WE
DID DO A QUICK LOOK BACK. IN
FEBRUARY. AND I NEED I PERCENT
OF ALL OUR RECORDS DID GO OVER
TO SECRETARY OF STATE IN THE
WHOLE REASON WHY I. MAY BE OUT
OF HER PURSE. BECAUSE YOU HAVE
SET. THIS PROCESS OF PLAY.
SOMEWHAT TO SUBMIT A- CHANGE OF
ADDRESS. SOME OF HIS. OUR
RECORDS WHICH THAT CAN KICK IT
OUT. SO I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE A DRESS THAT IT
WAS MORE OF A TIMING ISSUE. WE
WEREN'T SURE EXACTLY WHERE WE
CURRENTLY BE WE NEED TO. HAVE A
LOT MORE POSITIONS ON THE FRONT
END. BUT NOW GOING FORWARD ON
JULY FIRST WILL BE SUFFICIENT
AND- TECHNICALLY. YOU'RE AROUND
FOR SHOOTING FOR A FIVE DAYS WE
NEVER HAVE TO CHASE THE TEN DAY
AND FIVE DAY. GREAT THANK YOU
FOR. PERSONAL INFORMATION-
ISSUE SIX PLEASE. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS- MY NAME
IS MATTHEW MISSY TO WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- BEFORE
YOU IS THE- MOTOR VEHICLE COUNT
FUND CONDITION. AS YOU LIKELY
KNOW THIS MVA IS- PRIMARILY
FUNDED FROM VEHICLE
REGISTRATION OF A BASE VEHICLE
REGISTRATION FEE OF SIXTY
DOLLARS AND A C. H. P. FEE OF
TWENTY SIX DOLLARS BOTH OF
THOSE- HAVEBEEN AND INDEXED
FOR INFLATION. IN THE YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE WE
EXPECT ABOUT FOUR POINT FOUR
BILLION IN REVENUES COMBINED
WITH A IN AN EXPANDED BALANCE
FROM LAST YEAR OR FROM THE WHAT
WE EXPECT THIS YEAR WE CAN ADD
FOUR HUNDRED THIRTY THREE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THAT FOR A
TOTAL OF FOUR POINT TWO
BILLION- EXCUSE ME. IT'S
ROUGHLY OF FOUR POINT EIGHT
BILLION IN TOTAL RESOURCE THE
MINISTRATIONS PROPOSING ABOUT
FOUR POINT TWO BILLION IN
EXPENDITURES WITH TWO AND A
HALF BILLION FOR C. H. P. AND
ONE POINT ONE BILLION FOR DMV.
A SEVERAL CRASHED COST
PRESSURES OF ON THE FUNDING
INCLUDING REAL ID AND EMPLOYEE
COMPENSATION COSTS- AND CAPITAL
OUTLAY PROJECTS- THESE EXPENSES
HAVE- ARE ARE PROJECTED TO
OUTPACE REVENUE WHICH IS
RESULTING IN THE PROJECT A
NEGATIVE FUND BALANCE IN TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE. BUT
YOU SEE ON THE AGENDA. GIVEN
THAT WHILE WE CONTINUE TO
MONITOR THE FUND- AS THAT TIME
APPROACHES WHERE WE ARE-
SHOWING A NEGATIVE BALANCE THE
ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING OF
FOLLOWING TO HELP. WE ARE EACH
CHANGING THE WAY THE
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY IS
FUNDED- AND THAT IS REDUCING
THE MP A EXPENDITURES THAT THAT
THEY EXPAND BY ROUGHLY THREE
MILLION- WE ARE. HAVING DMV
CHARGE IT'S ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS FOR COLLECTING THE
TRANSPORTATION IMPROVEMENT FEE.
WE WILL BE CHARGING THAT TO THE
ROAD MAINTENANCE AND
REHABILITATION ACCOUNT AND THAT
SAVING ROUGHLY SIX POINT SIX
MILLION EACH YEAR WE ARE
PROPOSING TO FUND CAPITAL
OUTLAY PROJECTS THE CHP IN DMV
OFFICE REPLACEMENTS- USING
PUBLIC BUILDING CONSTRUCTION
FUND. AND WE ARE CONTINUING TO
SUSPEND THE NON ARTICLE
NINETEEN GENERAL FUND TRANSFER-
FOR THE NEXT FOUR YEARS. SUCH
AS WITH RESPECT TO THOSE- OTHER
SOURCES- I UNDERSTAND THAT OLD.
THAT THAT THAT WILL RESULT IN-
IN THE OUT YEARS AND THEIR- AT
NOT BEING THE DEFICIT THAT'S
PROJECTED BUT- IN THE IS ARE
THEY'RE SUFFICIENT FUNDS
AVAILABLE IN THE OUT YEARS
THOSE FUNDS. YES THERE ARE
WE'VE WE'VE TAKEN A LOOK AT
THOSE- THE ROAD MAINTENANCE AND
RELOCATION ACCOUNT FOR EXAMPLE
HAS SUBSTANTIAL REVENUES AND
THEY ARE INCREASING. AS A
RESULT OF SB ONE CORRECT I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE WE'RE NOT
DISPLACING. THE PROBLEM. AND
BRING IT SOMEWHERE ELSE. THANK
YOU OUT OF JUSTIN ADD REALLY
QUICKLY IF I COULD- THE- THE
MINISTRATIONS PROPOSING WHAT WE
BELIEVE IS THE MOST FISCALLY
PRUDENT. FIVE STRUCTURE FOR
DRESSING LONG TERM OFFICE
REPLACEMENT NEEDS FOR CHP
INDIAN V. AS WELL AS
MAINTAINING OUR SB EIGHTY FOUR
LOAN REPAYMENT. COMMITMENTS SO
WE MAINTAIN POSITIVE FUND
BALANCES IN THE SHORT TERM- AND
AS- WE- APPROACH FOR THE OUT
YEARS WE WILL CONTINUE
MONITORING THAT. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU. THE QUESTION SIX.
ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS THAT
YOU WANT TO MAKE ON THAT AND WE
CAN NOW MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
SEVEN. NUMBER SEVEN FACT TO THE
DMV AND DMV'S OR MAYBE CITIES
ARE CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECTS THE
DEPARTMENT HAS THREE CONTINUING
CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECTS THAT
ARE PROPOSED TO BE FUNDED FROM
THE PUBLIC BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION FUN- THESE
PROPOSALS ARE DEFINED
CONSTRUCTION THE CONSTRUCTION
PHASE A PREVIOUSLY APPROVED
FIELD OFFICE REPLACING PROJECTS
IN DELANO. RIDLEY SANTA MARIA
TOLON TELLING A BUDGET YOUR
REQUEST OF FIFTY POINT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS. THE V. IS ALSO
REQUESTING NINE POINT SEVEN
MILLION FROM THE MOTOR VEHICLE
ACCOUNT TO CONTINUE
RECONFIGURATION. AND REPLACING
PROJECTS IN OXNARD INGLEWOOD
EUREKA AND SAN FRANCISCO AND
FOR THE STUDY OF STATEWIDE
PLANNING AND CITED INVOCATION
FOR FUTURE CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROJECTS. THANK YOU GET THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS OUR
EFFORTS I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS. AT THE LA OWN
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. HEY I'M SO
WE ONLY REYES ISSUE WITH WINE
CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECT AND
THAT'S PARTICULARLY THE SAN
FRANCISCO FIELD OFFICE
REPLACEMENT PROJECT AND THE
DEPARTMENT PROPOSES DESIGNED
THE PROJECT TO BE- MEETINGS
HERE IN THE ENERGY REQUIREMENTS
MEANING THE TOTAL AMOUNT OF
ENERGY THAT USE ON ANNUAL BASIS
WILL BE- AT EQUAL TO THE
AMOUNT. THAT WE NEED. I'VE
RENEWABLE ENERGY CREATED ON
SAY- AND WHILE THE WE
RECOGNIZED ENERGY CONSERVATION
CAN HELP REDUCE THE STATE'S
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS- HELP IT
REALLY ACHIEVE THE- CLIMATE.
CHANGE RELATED GOALS I'M- THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS NOT BEEN
ABLE TO SHOW THAT THE COST
EFFECTIVENESS OF SUCH MEASURES.
I'M IF THE PROJECT WERE TO
SHOWN TO ME NOT BECAUSE COST
EFFECTIVE THE STATE COULD
POTENTIALLY ACCOMPLISHED- MORE
ENERGY SAVINGS USING OTHER
METHODS- BY INVESTING IN OTHER
PROJECTS. WITH THE SAME AMOUNT
OF FUNDS. IF YOU HAVE A
QUESTION THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WILL. FOR L. L. OKAY
JUST GOT A KIA SEE WHAT WERE
THE OTHER METHODS BE YOU
MENTIONED HE COULD BE
ACCOMPLISHING THINGS THROUGH
OTHER METHODS. RIGHT SO OF ANY
WE CAN BE INVESTING IN OTHER
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS THAT.
YOU KNOW MAYBE THE BETTER
LOCATIONS FOR SOLAR ON ENERGY-
OR INVEST THE OTHER- OTHER THE
BUILDINGS THAT MAYBE MARCH WELL
SUITED FOR. TO FINANCE. HELLO
HELLO RANDY CATS THE PART OF
FIVE NO CONCERNS WITH THE WITH
THE STAFF COMMENTS OF- JUST NOT
WITH THE LA YOU KNOW THAT
THROUGH SOLAR- WE'RE HEARING
THAT. THROUGH TECHNOLOGY
CHANGES AND IMPROVEMENTS THAT
THE RETURN ON INVESTMENT IS AS
LITTLE AS EIGHT YEARS- ON BASED
ON ENERGY SAVINGS FOR SAY THE
RIDLEY UP PROJECT- AND THEN
LATE WE ALSO KNOW THAT. WELL
WELL WELL WE'RE WE'RE SENSITIVE
TO ALLAY THOSE CONCERNS WE
WOULDN'T WANT THE SAN FRANCISCO
PROJECT DELAYED AS IT'S A SIX
YEAR OLD BUILDING WITH A
NUMEROUS FIRE LIFE SAFETY
ISSUES. THANK. IS THERE ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT ON- ISSUES. FOUR
FIVE SIX TWO SEVEN. SEEING NONE
THERE'S NO ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
SO- FROM THE DíAS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR BEING HERE FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY AND- WILL HOLD
ALL THOSE ITEMS OPEN HAND TO
CALL FORWARD CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROL FOR ISSUES EIGHT NINE
AND TEN. COMMISSIONERS SO VERY
PATIENTLY WAITED IN THE BACK OF
THE ROOM THROUGH ALL THE OTHER
DEPARTMENTS. MAYBE NEXT THE
ARRIVAL RIGHT STAFF IS THE
SUGGESTING THAT MAYBE NEXT YEAR
YOU THE FIRST. MAYBE. WELCOME
COMMISSIONER A MORE YOU'RE MORE
THAN WELCOME TO JUST AUNCH AND
TO ISSUE EIGHT- THE E.
CIGARETTE TO A TEXAN FORSMAN
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE AND MAYBE
YOU CAN WORK INTO YOUR REMARKS
WHY- C. H. P. IS THE RIGHT
AGENCY TO BE DOING THIS BECAUSE
IT IS LIKE WE DO A LOT OF
TOBACCO ENFORCEMENT. I'LL AND
THE GOVERNMENT. WELL GOOD
MORNING GERMAN WOMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE COMMISSIONER WAR
STANLEY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY COME BEFORE YOU TO
TALK ABOUT OUR- OUR BUDGET FOR
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
I WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THIS IMPORTANT
GETTING US PREPARE FOR TODAY AS
YOU STATED WE HAVE A FEW ITEMS
THAT THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO
DISCUSS THE TO NOW START OUT
FIRST AS YOU REQUESTED. AND
WITH THE E. CIGARETTE TAX
ENFORCEMENT AND ALSO HERE WITH
ME. HIS ASSISTANT CHIEF SHONDA
RAY FROM OUR LEGISLATIVE OFFICE.
SO WE HAVE A B. C. P. BEFORE
YOU THAT REQUEST TEN POSITIONS
AND A SEVEN MILLION DOLLAR
PERMANENT AUGMENTATION. FROM
THE ELECTRONIC CIGARETTE
PRODUCTS TAX FUNDED FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. TO STAND OF
A TASK FORCE CHARTER COMBATING
ILLICIT PEIPING DEVICE AND
PRODUCT IMPORT EXPORT
MANUFACTURING TRANSPORTATION
DISTRIBUTION AND SALES. FOR THE
PAST SEVERAL YEARS THE USE OF
ELECTRONIC CIGARETTES COMMONLY
REFERRED TO AS VAPING HAS
INCREASED GREATLY. THIS NEW
POPULARITY HAS LED TO A MARKET
OF ILLICIT VAPING DEVICES AND
OTHER COMMODITIES. NOW THESE
UNREGULATED AND BLACK MARKET
PRODUCTS CAN CONTAIN DANGEROUS
ADDITIVES FOUND IN BOTH PEIPING
FLEW- LIQUIDS AND IN
CONSTRUCTION OF THE DEVICES. AS
OF DECEMBER OF LAST YEAR THE
CDC PLACES NUMBER OF EACH
CIGARETTE VAPING PRODUCT- LONG
INJURIES AT TWO THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED NINETY ONE. AND THE
NUMBER OF DEATHS ON A NATIONAL
BASIS AT FORTY EIGHT. NOW TO
ADDRESS IS RAPIDLY INCREAING-
YOUTH- MOVEMENT THAT USE THESE
NICOTINE BASE RAPING PRODUCTS.
THE PROPOSED BUDGET SEEKS A NEW
NICOTINE CONTENT BASED E.
CIGARETTE TAX. NEW TAX WILL
BEGIN IN JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AND WENT TO DOLLARS FOR
EACH OF THE FORTY MILLIGRAMS OF
NICOTINE IN THEIR PRODUCTS. THE
TAXI WILL BE USED FOR
ADMINISTRATION OF COURSE MEANT
YOU PREVENTION AND HEALTH CARE
WORK AT WORK FORCE PROGRAMS.
NOW PROPOSAL LEVERAGES THE OVER
SEVENTY UNIFORM OFFICERS THIRTY
FOUR STATIONERY COMMERCIAL
VEHICLE INSPECTION FACILITIES.
AND NEARLY FOUR MILLION
CONTACTS THAT WE MAKE EACH YEAR
AND ALSO A SPECIALIZED
INVESTIGATION TEAM- DELETE THIS
TASK FORCE IN COOPERATION WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE SO WE
CAN PROVIDE FOCUS ENFORCEMENT
WITH THE INTENT TO INVESTIGATE
AND TO DISRUPT THIS FLOW.
POSTED VAPING DEVICES AND
PRODUCTS BEING DISTRIBUTED
THROUGHOUT. HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
AS AN INITIAL FOUNDATION FOR
THE PROGRAM WERE ASKING FOR ONE
SERGEANT TO SUPERVISE A STATE
WIDE PROGRAM. AND NINE OFFICERS
BEFORE SPECIALIZED CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATIONS AND ENFORCEMENT
TARGETING THESE ILLEGAL VAPING
DEVICES AND IN THE IMPORT AND
EXPORT MANUFACTURING
TRANSPORTATION AND DISTRIBUTION
OF SALES WE PROPOSE THREE POINT
FIVE MILLION OF THE SEVEN
MILLION TO BE ALLOCATED- FOR
CONTRACTING WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE T. WITH THESE
EFFORTS WE HAVE RECEIVED THE
LETTER COMMITMENT FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE-
ENDORSING THIS AFTER. THE SEAT
THE OJ WE HAVE A HISTORY OF
WORKING TOGETHER WITH
SPECIALIZED TASK FORCES ON
VARIOUS ENFORCEMENT EFFORTS.
THIS PROPOSAL KIND THAT
COMBINES THE UNIQUE STRENGTHS
OF BOTH DEPARTMENTS AND
LEVERAGES OUR EXPERTISE AND
RESOURCES. TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE CAN BE WHICH CAN BE
LABELED AS AN ACADEMIC. AND
WHAT I'LL DO NOW IS ALL THAT
THE SYSTEM CHEAP TO RATE TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT DOJ DOES
AND THEN I'LL- GO WITH SOME
OTHER COMMENTS ON. A GOOD
MORNING. I THINK TO THE
QUESTION- Y. C. H. P. AND WHAT
ARE THE OTHER AGENCIES DO AND
AS COMMITTEE STAFF POINTS OUT
ME NOW SAYS THERE ARE SOME
EFFORTS IN THIS AREA. BUT WHAT
WE'RE FINDING IS WHETHER TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH FOR
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE. THESE
EFFORTS ARE MORE FOR THE
ENFORCEMENT ARE UNDER AGE TO
USE. OF OTHERWISE LEGAL
PRODUCTS AND WHAT WERE INTENDED
TO FOCUS OUR EFFORTS ARE. IS
ILLICIT PRODUCTS SO ELITE
PRODUCTS AND WHEN IT COMES TO
VAPING. EVEN THOUGH THERE'S NOT
A LOT OF NOT AND THERE ISN'T A
LOT OF KNOWLEDGE WE ADMIT THAT
IN THIS. PART OF THAT IS
BECAUSE THERE'S NOBODY REALLY
FOR DONNA WE'RE NOT AWARE IN
OUR RESEARCH IN OUR EFFORTS WE
HAVEN'T FOUND ANYBODY THAT'S
TRULY FOCUSED ON. THE
ENFORCEMENT OF THE BLACK MARKET
AND THE ILLICIT PRODUCTS AND I
THINK THAT'S WHERE. WE WOULD
HAVE SOME EXPERTISE WHETHER
IT'S AN ILLICIT DRUGS OR
OTHERWISE- CRIMINAL ENTERPRISES
THAT'S WE DO HAVE SOME
EXPERTISE THAT WE GET MIND
TOWARDS. DISRUPTING THIS
UNDERSTANDING WHAT. IS ACTUALLY
OUT THERE. AND MAYBE GET A
BETTER HANDLE ON WHERE THE
STATE GOES. IN THE FUTURE WITH
THESE EFFORTS. SO I. TAKE YOUR
POINT THAT THE A CH P. HAS SOME
EXPERTISE IN IN THESE AREAS
BUT- SO DOES LOCAL LAW. FIRST
MAPS JUST UNDERSTAND AND DEPART
VOEPEL HEALTH I THINK IS. GONNA
GET ôNG EFFORTS WITH RESPECT
TO- TOBACCO ISSUES. THIS SEEMS
TO BE A SHIFT AND I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND. WHERE THE- THE
EQUITIES LANARKSHIRE WHAT I
THINK PART OF IT IS IT'S A
STATEWIDE EFFORT IN IN ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT RECENTLY
HAPPEN- WITH THE RECENT
LEGISLATION THERE AUTHORIZES
EACH P. WITH THE- REGIONAL
ORGANIZE. RETAIL TASK FORCES
WE'VE HAD GREAT SUCCESS THERE.
AND WE FEEL THAT DOING
SOMETHING VERY SIMILAR TO THAT
WORKING WITH DOJ- WE COULD HAVE
IMPACT ON THIS ISSUE ALSO. ON
THE STATE WIDE ON THE STATE
WIDE BASIS. OKAY WITH OUR
EXPERTISE- IN IN CONDUCTING
THESE TYPES INVESTIGATION. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU- LA- AND-
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE PLEASE.
OKAY I'M YES SO WE FIND THE
PROPOSAL THAT- HIS TAKING
ACTION ON ILLICIT VAPING
PRODUCTS TO BE A REASONABLE ONE
GIVEN THE SERIOUS HEALTH
CONCERNS THAT- THAT ELICIT THE
PRODUCTS MAY POSE OUT TO THE
PUBLIC- BUT WE AGREE WITH THAT
THIS. S. STAFF THE COMMITTEE
STAFF THAT. AND THERE ARE SOME
CONCERNS WITH THE PROPOSAL
THREE MAIN CONCERNS WE HAVE
FIRST IS THAT THE SCOPE OF THE
PROBLEM IS UNCLEAR SO- AS THE
DEPARTMENT HAS MENTIONED WE
DON'T KNOW A LOT ABOUT- ABOUT
THE BLACK MARKET IS IT REALLY A
AT LEAST A CANNABIS ISSUE- OR
IS IT REALLY- THE VAPING ISSUE
REALLY I'M- SHOULD BE TARGETED
TOWARDS UNDER AGE YOU SAYS.
VAPE SO USED TO USE OF FAITH
YOUTH ADDICTION TO NICOTINE.
AND DEPENDING ON KIND OF HOW WE
DEFINE THE PROBLEM THAT WOULD
INFORM- THE MOST EFFECTIVE
STRATEGY TO ADDRESS THE HEALTH
CONCERNS THAT WE HAVE. AND
DEPENDING ON THE KIND OF OUR
UNDERSTANDING OF THE PROBLEM IN
MALES AND FOR- INFORMED. AT THE
TYPE OF STRATEGY THAT THE STATE
PURSUES I'M- TO AT TO JUSTICE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERN SO
ENFORCEMENT ONE STRATEGY- BUT
AS YOU'VE MENTIONED PUBLIC
HEALTH HAS ALSO BEEN ENGAGING
IN A PUBLIC AWARENESS CAMPAIGN
SO- SHOULD YOUTH EDUCATION OUR
PUBLIC AWARENESS ALSO BE A PART
OF THE STRATEGY THAT THE STATE
PURSUES- TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE
PHYLLIS OF A BAND THAT. THE DAY
SHIFT THAT BEING RELATED LONG
ON THE SET. AND THEN KIND OF
THAT THE LAST CONCERN WE HAVE
IS THAT- AS YOU MENTIONED. IT'S
NOT. PARTY THAT. NICE THEIR
EXPERT THEN I'M CRIMINAL VEST
BUT ARE YOU KNOW OTHER
DEPARTMENTS- TV PH FOR EXAMPLE
AT THAT HAS DONE- SOME TOBACCO-
AT WORK AS WELL AS- TO BUREAU
OF CANADA CONTROL WHO'S DONE
CANNABIS. FORCE AND SO. TO THE
EXTENT THAT WOULD MAYBE WE
THERE ARE OTHER DEPARTMENTS
THAT WE CAN LEVERAGE I'M YOU
KNOW THEIR PRIOR EXPERIENCE. AS
WELL AS LOCAL FORCED ME TO SEE
THAT MAY ALSO HAVE- PRIOR
EXPERTISE IN. DOING
INVESTIGATIONS IN THIS AREA.
RIGHT THANK YOU FINANCE. TEAM
IN A DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I
WOULD JUST ADD THAT- WE WOULD
UNDERSTAND AND CERTAINLY I GOT
THE IDEA THAT WAS THERE ISN'T A
LOT KNOWN ABOUT HOW THESE
PRODUCTS UNDER THE STATE THAT'S
ONE OF THE REASONS WHY WERE ON.
LEADING ON CH YOU TO HELP US
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S HAPPENING
WITH THAT AND WE INCOME I WOULD
EXPECT THAT THERE WOULD BE SOME
LEARNINGS FROM THE ACTIVITIES
THAT THEY'RE GOING UNDERTAKEN
THAT. ERRORS THAT WERE MUCH
MORE INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT THE
APPROPRIATE RESOURCES AND JUST
TO BE SURE TO THE WOULD BE AT
THAT TIME. THANK LET'S MOVE ON
TO ISSUE NINE. YES CALIFORNIA'S
CYBERSECURITY IMMIGRATION
CENTER. ALSO FOR DISCUSSING THE
DAYS ARE ROLE IN A LARGER
BUDGET REQUEST FOR THE FUNDING
OF POSITIONS TALKING AT THE
CALIFORNIA CYBERSECURITY
INTEGRATION CENTER ALSO KNOWN
AS THE CAL SIX. THE ELEVEN
POINT ONE MILLION DOLLAR
REQUEST FROM THE GENERAL FUND
FOR TWENTY FOUR POSITIONS. FOR
CALORIE S. THE CALIFORNIA
MILITARY DEPARTMENT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY AND THE CHP. THE CHP
PORTION IS NINE HUNDRED SEVENTY
SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM THE
GENERAL FRONT WITH NINE AND
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS ON
GOING TO FUND FOR OFFICER
POSITIONS THAT WOULD BE PART OF
THE CAL SAID. THE CAL SIXER AS
THE CENTRAL HUB OF CALIFORNIA
SO. ACTIVITIES AND COORDINATES
INFORMATION SHARING WITH LOCAL
STATE AND FEDERAL AGENCIES.
TRAVEL GOVERNMENT'S UTILITIES
AND OTHER SERVICE PROVIDERS
INCLUDING- ACADEMIC
INSTITUTIONS AND NON
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS.
STATE AND LOCAL MUNICIPALITIES
ARE BEING PRESELI TARGETED BY
CYBER ATTACKS SEEKING RANSOM
OPPORTUNITIES AND- AND ALSO TO
DISRUPT THE SERVICE ACROSS
PERMANENT DAMAGE OR DESTRUCTION
OF INFORMATION SYSTEMS OR
SENSITIVE DATA BASED. THE CAL
SIX WHO WAS CODIFIED AND BY AB
TWENTY EIGHT THIRTEEN AND
TWENTY EIGHTEEN SETTING FOR
THIS COMPOSITION AND
RESPONSIBILITIES. THE CAL SICK
IS INTENDED TO PROVIDE
RESOURCES- FROM MANY STATE
PARTNERS INCLUDING CHP. THE CHP
OFFICERS ASSIGNED TO THE CAL
SICK WILL BE. RESPONSIBLE FOR
INCIDENT RESPONSE OKAY COMPUTER
PRIONS IN. FORENSICS AND
EVIDENCE COLLECTION INVOLVING
STATE A CALIFORNIA OWN ASSETS
AS WELL AS LIAISON WITH THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY. THAT HAS
PRIMARY JURISDICTION WHERE THE
CRIME OCCURRED. THE SEAS P.
SHARES CRITICAL INFORMATION
FROM THESE CRIMINAL AND
INVESTIGATIONS WITH THE
PARTNERING AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS WITHIN THE CAL SIX.
PLAYING A VITAL ROLE IN
PREVENTION AND OVERALL STATE
SECURITY. THANK YOU ALEJO. FIVE
FOR THIS PARTICULAR PROPOSAL WE
HAVE NO COMMENT. NO COMMENT
FROM- FINANCE- LET ME JUST ADD
THAT IT'S NOT. I THINK COMMONLY
IN THE HOME AND- THAT- C. H. P.
PLAYS AN IMPORTANT ROLE IN THE
INVESTIGATION OF CYBER SECURITY
ATTACKS AGAINST OF VARIOUS
STATE ASSETS I. BUT I JUST WANT
TO CALL OUT THAT THE
SUBCOMMITTEE'S ACTION. AND IT'S
ULTIMATELY TAKEN ON- THE C. H.
P.'S PORTION OF THE CAL CSIC
PROPOSAL'S GONNA CONFORM WITH
ACTIONS THAT ARE TAKEN AND SUB
COMMITTEES FOUR AND FIVE- AND
THEY'LL BE HEARING BECAUSE OF A
LARGER. OBVIOUSLY A LARGER PART
OF THE BUDGET THAN WE HEAR-
HERE. AND WITH THAT WE CAN MOVE
ON TO ISSUE TEN. OKAY AND THAT
IS OUR CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECTS.
WE HAVE SIX CAPITAL OUT LEE AT
B. C. PEAS- THESE INCLUDE THE
WORK TO REPLACE FIVE C. H. B.
OFFICES THAT HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED THAT TO NO LONGER
MEET OUR PROGRAM REQUIREMENTS.
WORTH SIZE PERFORMANCE CRITERIA
REQUIRED UP REQUIRED TO THE
STATE OWNED BUILDINGS. THREE
OTHER PROJECTS THAT SANTA FE
SPRINGS BALLPARK IN THE QUINCY
AREA ARE IN THE DESIGN BILL
PHASE. THE VOTE ON AREA OFFICE
IS IN THE ACQUISITION PHASE.
AND WE'RE SEEKING FUNDING FOR
BOTH PERFORMANCE CRITERIA AN
ACQUISITION PHASE FOR THE
HUMBOLDT. AREA OFFICE
REPLACEMENT. AT THESE PROJECTS
ARE A TOTAL OF A HUNDRED TWENTY
SIX MILLION FROM THE PUBLIC
BUILDINGS CONSTRUCTION FUND.
AND FOUR MILLION FROM THE NBA
AS FAR AS THE SANTA FE SPRINGS
REQUESTING FORTY FOUR POINT
THREE MILLION BALLING PARK AREA
OFFICE FORTY THREE POINT ONE
MILLION IN THE QUINCY AREA
OFFICE THIRTY POINT ONE MILLION
FOR. RUN ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION- FROM THE NBA. ADD TO
FUND THE ACQUISITION PHASE OF
THE PROJECT. AND FOR THE
HUMBOLDT AREA OFFICE- TWO POINT
ONE MILLION FROM THE NBA TO
PROFOUND THE ACQUISITION AND
PERFORMANCE BASED CRITERIA.
WE'RE ALSO SEEKING FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM THE NBA
FOR STATEWIDE PLANNING. INSIDE
IDENTIFICATION AS PART OF OUR
ONGOING EFFORT TO REPLACE OLDER
FACILITIES. THAT NO LONGER MEET
THE DEPARTMENT'S NEEDS OR
CALIFORNIA SEISMIC SAFETY
STANDARDS. AND THEN LASTLY IS
THE CAPITAL SWING SPACE. AS
PART OF OUR CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROJECTS WERE ASKING FOR A ONE
TIME FUNDING AT ONE POINT
MILLION ONE POINT ONE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE FROM THE NBA TO FROM
THE COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
MANDATORY RELOCATION. OF C. H.
B. ASSETS AT THE CAPITOL I NEXT
TO THE CAPITAL'S SPACE BUILDING
CURRENTLY UNDER CONSTRUCTION.
THIS IS NOT A TEMPORARY MOVE
FOR THE CHP ALL SEATS BE
OPERATION CURRENTLY HOUSE IN
THE ANNEX BUILDING WILL BE
PROBABLY MOVED TO THE NEW SWING
SPACE. AND THIS INCLUDES OUR
SEATS P. PERMIT OFFICE AND OUR
CAPITAL- COMMUNICATION CENTER.
OF THE COST TO MOVE THE SEAS P.
RESOURCES FROM THE ANNEX TO THE
NEW SWINGS PLEASE INCLUDE THE
PROPER UNINSTALL. AND MOVEMENT
AND STAND UP A PUBLIC SAFETY
RADIO SYSTEMS NINE ONE ONE CALL
TAKING EQUIPMENT. AND
ASSOCIATED- INTERNET AND PHONE
SERVICE. THE TECHNICAL
EXPERTISE TO MOVE THIS IS
OUTSIDE THE EXPERTISE OF
DEPARTMENTAL PERSONNEL. AND
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH A
CALLOW YESTER PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMUNICATIONS DIVISION WHO
WILL ULTIMATELY FACILITATE THE
WORK ASSOCIATED WITH MOVING
BACK COMMUNICATIONS A QUICK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- I WASN'T
AWARE OF THAT- CHP WOULD BE-
MOVE AND- TO THE NEW BUILDING.
SO THAT'S A- GOOD TO UNDERSTAND
LA- ANY COMMENTS- WE DO NOT
HAVE ANY AND CONCERT WITH ANY
OF THE PARTICULAR CAPITAL
OUTLAY PROPOSALS- HOWEVER WE
AGREE WITH THE COMMITTEE STAFF
THAT- SHIFTING FROM CASH
FUNDING TO BOND FINANCING FOR
COUPLE OUT. CHECKS COST THE
STATE MORE. TERM GRADING
ADDITIONAL COST. THE IN THE
LONG TERM. THANK YOU FINANCE.
NOT CONCERNED NO COME IT'S
THERE'S NO QUESTIONS FROM THE
DIS IS THERE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ISSUES SEVEN EIGHT OR NINE.
GIVEN PATIENT. YES I'VE BEEN IN
AND OUT OF OTHER SUBCOMMITTEE
SOME- KELLY BE MY BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
ON ITEM EIGHT AND WE ARE VERY
MUCH IN SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED EAST
CIGARETTE TAX AND ALSO THIS
ENFORCEMENT PROPOSAL. IT IS
UNFORTUNATE THAT THE NATIONAL
OUTBREAK SHED LIGHT ON HOW
VAPING WHETHER CANNABIS OR
TOBACCO IS IMPACT PUBLIC HEALTH
OVERALL WE ARE STILL LEARNING
AS NOTED BY THE TESTIMONY HERE
TODAY. TAXING E. CIGARETTES
WITH STAMPS SIMILAR TO
TRADITIONAL COMBUSTIBLE
CIGARETTES MAY DRIVE MORE THE
MARKET UNDERGROUND ON THE
LIQUIDS AND THE DEVICES. TO
HELP MITIGATE THAT THIS
PROPOSAL IS VERY IMPORTANT.
COUPLED WITH PUBLIC HEALTH
CAMPAIGNS- AS NOTED BY THE LA-
AND LOCAL ENFORCEMENT- EFFORTS
A POTENTIAL FLAVOR BAND THAT'S
BEING CONSIDERED- THIS
ENFORCEMENT PROPOSAL WILL ALL
WORK TOGETHER TO GATHER
INFORMATION ABOUT THE INDUSTRY
AND AFFECT CONSUMER BEHAVIOR.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE DON'T
OFTEN SEE THE MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION HERE AND BUDGET SUB
VERY. HOMA HOPE YOUR EXPERIENCE
WAS A POSITIVE ONE. AND THAT
BRINGS US TO THE CONCLUSION OF
OUR- LENGTHIER THAN EXPECTED
HEARING I THINK ALL OF THEM ARE
LIKE FEAR THAN EXPECTED. HE
JUST GOES WITH THE TERRITORY OF
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION AND WILL STAND
ADJOURNED THANK YOU SIR. AFTER.